HELLO. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT IN
RETIREMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THESE ORDERS THE SENATE
WILL BE HOLDING IN THE CENTRAL
HEARING IT HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WHILE CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND
OUR EMPLOYEES TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS TO OF THE PUBLIC TWO
TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY ROOMS ARE A
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHERE WE ARE
TODAY RIGHT NOW AND TWENTY
FORTY IN THE CAPITAL FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT.
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTISAN NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR THAT.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE THAT YOU WILL NEED. IS.
249-538-4249 FIVE THREE EIGHT
FOUR. WILL REMOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENTED MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID TO STAY. BACK HE MORE
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING A HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS. PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES PARTICIPANTS WHO FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE USE. FOR NEW ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES SO THAT
THEY CAN ALL BE HEARD- WE HAVE-
THIRTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. SB NINE HUNDRED AND SB
NINE NINE SEVEN HAVE BEEN
PULLED. BEFORE THAT WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO TURN YOUR MICROPHONE SO WE
CAN HEAR YOU CENTER HILL. HERE
AN ARM AROUND HERE SENATE
JACKSON HERE. MITCHELL HERE
CENTER PAN DEAR DIARY OF A
QUORUM. THANK YOU THE SECRETARY
NOTES A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED NOW DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY EACH
SIDE WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE MEASURES
AND WE WILL LIMIT THAT TIME FOR
THOSE PARTICIPATING IN PUBLIC
COMMENT WISHING TO TESTIFY ON
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION WE WILL LIMIT THAT
TIME TO TEN MINUTES. ON EACH
SIDE OF A PARTICULAR BILL. SOME
OF THAT WE WILL NOW. NOW IT'S
YOUR OR MY FIRST AUTHOR
WELCOME SENATOR GROWTH I SEE
YOU DOWN THERE WELCOME THANK
YOU MISTER YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL SB. EIGHT ZERO SIX THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. SO
GOOD AT. A MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND APRIL OF TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT ISSUED
A DECISION IN A CASE THAT
CHANGE THE WORK LIFE OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
DEPARTING FROM THIRTY YEARS OF
CALIFORNIA LAW THE DYNAMICS
DECISION CREATED A NEW TEST TO
DETERMINE WHO IS AND WHO ISN'T
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. IN
THIS NEW MOST WRIST IN THIS ONE
OF THE MOST RESTRICTIVE RULES
OF ANY EMPLOYMENT TEST RELATING
TO WAGE AND HOUR. LAWS IT'S ONE
OF THE MOST RESTRICTIVE IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY LAST YEAR THIS
COMMITTEE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AB FIVE WHICH
CODIFIED THE DYNAMICS DECISION
INTO LAW. FOR PICKING AND
CHOOSING WHICH INDUSTRIES.
WOULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE WORK.
CONTRACTORS IN WHICH WOULD NOT.
LET'S NOT FORGET MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO CHOOSE TO WORK
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
THROUGH THE SINGLE MOMS TO USE
A NEW BRAT TO DRIVE WHILE THEIR
KIDS ARE AT SCHOOL. THE COLLEGE
STUDENT WHO WORKS AFTER CLASS
TO AFFORD THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING IN THE STATE. A
HAIRSTYLIST WHO WANTS TO SET
THEIR OWN APPOINTMENTS RENT
THEIR BOOTS AND SHOES TO WORK
AS THEIR OWN BOSS. THERE ARE
DOCTORS ARE INSURANCE AGENTS
ENGINEERS SOFTWARE DEVELOPERS
THERAPISTS TRUCK DRIVERS HAVE
BEEN DRIVING AROUND THIS
CAPITAL TODAY IN PROTEST.
STUDENT ASSISTANCE SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS ARTIST
THEM. OUR KIDS REFEREES ON
SATURDAYS WILL BE USED TO BE
ABLE TO GO WATCH OUR KIDS
GAMES. HOWEVER BECAUSE OF AB
FIVE OF THESE INDUSTRIES ARE NO
LONGER ALLOWED TO HAVE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN
CALIFORNIA. A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
EMPLOYMENT TEST SHOULD NOT AND
CANNOT APPLY. TO KEEP POURING
INTO DEPEND ON THIS VERY TYPE
THE INCOME TAX ABILITY. FOR
QUALITY BY PROVIDED BY
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR WORK.
THIS IS WHAT CAN ON THIS ISSUE
THE LAST TWO YEARS INVITING FOR
ALL. TO BE TREATED IN THE SAME
UNDER THE EYES OF THE LAW.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SB EIGHT OH
SIX. WOULD REPEAL AB FIVE IN
THERE BY THE FIRST THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS THE
DYNAMICS IS CODIFIED IN BY AB
FIVE. AND HAD ON THE JOBS IN
THE JOB CREATION OF FREELANCERS
ON IN OUR ECONOMY. MY BILL IS
EVEN MORE NECESSARY NOW WILL
BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT CODE
NINETEEN CRISIS. THE GOVERNOR
STAY AT HOME ORDER OVER FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
APPLIED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. THE ONE THING THAT
THIS CRISIS MADE CLEAR IS THE
WORK FORCE NEEDS FLEXIBILITY
NOW MORE THAN EVER. THE MORE
THE TRADITIONAL MONDAY THROUGH
FRIDAY NINE TO FIVE WORK MODEL
DOES NOT WORK FOR COUNTLESS
MOMS AND DADS THAT CURRENTLY
HAVE CHILDREN OUT OF SCHOOL AND
ACCESS TO CHILDCARE.
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS SUCH AS
DOOR DASH INTO THE CART SINGLE
OWNER OPERATOR TRUCK DRIVERS IN
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS HAVE
LOST THEIR INCOME AND THEIR
ABILITY TO FEED THEIR FAMILY.
DUE TO AB FIVE IN THIS CRISIS.
YET THERE ARE SOME THE MOST
ESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES IN THE
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS THAT WE
NEED RIGHT NOW. SB EIGHT OH SIX
AN EMERGENCY MEASURE IS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THESE NEEDS
BY ALLOWING FOR THE ACTING THE
FLEXIBILITY INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTING MODEL. SB EIGHT OH
SIX WOULD REPEAL AB FIVE AND
REPLACE IT WITH A NEW BROAD
FLEXIBLE. AND WORKABLE ABC TEST
FOR DETERMINING INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR STATUS. THE TEST
WHICH SUPPORTS WORKER FREEDOM
OF SAVING BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
UNLIKE AB FIVE STRICT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET A. B. C.
TEST WHICH REVOKES FREELANCING
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE ABILITY TO
EARN A LIVING FOR MILLIONS OF
FREELANCERS. NEW AB T. TECH AN
S. PIERCE WITH SIGNIFICANT
EXPAND INTO CAN. ALLOWING
FREELANCERS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AS
LONG AS THEY COMPLY WITH THE
SIMPLE EASIER TO MEET A. B. C.
TEST. SB EIGHT OH SIX WILL
ALLOW ALL HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS THAT CHOOSE THIS
TYPE OF WORK TO BE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AGAIN. AS SUCH THEY
WILL NO LONGER HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT TAKING
AWAY THEIR FREEDOM AND-FLEXIBILITY BY FORCING THEM TO
BECOME EMPLOYEES. I KNOW THE
OPPOSITION IS GONNA SAY THAT
WITHOUT AB FIVE BUSINESSES CAN
NO LONGER USE MISCLASSIFIED
WORKERS AND DENIED THEM
BASICALLY PER RIGHTS OR THAT MY
BILL WILL MOVE CALIFORNIA
BACKWARDS. TOO CONFUSING
STANDARD NOTHING COULD BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH. SB
EIGHT OH SIX IS A COMMONSENSE
RESPONSE THE DYNAMICS DECISION
AND EIGHTY FIVE OUR BILL WILL
PROTECT THE LIVELIHOOD OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS. WHO
CHOOSE TO WORK AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS IN HIS LIFE AND HIS
LIKELY WHOSE WERE PUT TO. TO
PUT IT WERE PUT AT RISK BECAUSE
OF THE COURT'S DECISION IN THE
LAW. THAT'S WHY SB ZERO SIX IS
IMPORTANT AND WHY MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION. ABOUT THE DYNAMIC
DECISION AND AB FIVE MY NIPPLE
NOT CREATE CONFUSION OR CARVE
OUTS. BUT RATHER PROVIDE
CLARITY TO THE ROUGHLY ONE
MILLION INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
AFFECTED BY EIGHT FIVE JUST
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK THEIR
OWN HOURS. ON THEIR OWN TIME.
CALIFORNIA BILLY IS THE LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO PROTECT WORKERS RIGHTS
AND FREEDOMS TO ENSURE THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
WHERE THEY WORK. WHERE THEY
WORK. WHAT THE WORK ON HOW MUCH
THEY EARN ESPECIALLY NOW DURING
THIS PANDEMIC LET'S HELP
CALIFORNIANS GET BACK TO WORK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME SIR AND
ON THE PHONE I DO BELIEVE THAT
CAN STONE REPRESENTING A. B. C.
AS MY PRIMARY WITNESS TO
SUPPORT. AND SHE'LL BE
TESTIFYING VIA TELEPHONE. I
THANK SENATOR GROUP SET UP
THEIR- WELL LET ME OPEN THE
OPEN FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY- MISSED OWNED A PLEASE
PROCEED AND THERE'S TEN MINUTES
FOR THE- SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE BEGIN. MANY MEMBERS ARE
THREE MINUTES FOR THIS. OKAY
GOT IT DOWN AND STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. IN
OUR HOUSE PLEASE THE SUPPORT
SENATE BILL EIGHT AFFECT
CREATES A NEW STANDARD FOR
DETERMINING IF A WORKER IS AN
EMPLOYEE OR AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR IT IS MORE CLEAR
THAN A COMPLICATED MULTI FACTOR
BOROUGH TAP. AND WATER THE LOOK
VERY RESTRICTIVE DYNAMAX AND
EIGHTY FIVE AB. ARE MEMBERS. OF
ALL ASPECTS OF THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IN COMPANIES BIG AND
SMALL WANT TO BE ABLE TO
LEGALLY UNFAIRLY USE IN THE
PLAN THE CONTRACTORS IN THEIR
BUSINESSES. IT'S LIKE THE MOVIE
IS THAT WITH ANY OTHER STATE WE
DO RECOGNIZE THAT EIGHTY FIVE
DOES A CONTRACTOR HIRED BUT
CONTACT GROUP THE COMPANY'S
PROVIDED. THAT THEY MEET
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS. UNDER
FIVE AND DYNAMIC. AND
CALIFORNIA ARE AT THE END THE
DAY THE WORKERS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T BE AN EMPLOYEE AND THEY
ONLY BE CLASSIFIED AS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR IT'S
THREE CONDITIONS ARE MET THE
WORK GREAT READ FROM THE
CONTROL AND DIRECTION OF THE
HIGHER ROOM. THE WORK OF THE
FOURTH WORK THAT IS OUTSIDE OF
THE USUAL COURT THE BUSINESS OF
IRON AND THE WORKER IS
CUSTOMARILY AND GAZED AT THE
INDEPENDENT. I THOUGHT ABOUT
THE CASE THAT. THE BEST. LEADS
MANY WHO THE WORK AND IT HAD A
CONTRACT. UNDER THE PACT IN AT
THE END OF. THE WORKER MAYBE
INDEPENDENT. IF THAT PERSON IS
FREE FROM THE CONTROL THE
DIRECTION OF THE HIRING AND HE
AND THEN EITHER PERFORMS WORK
OUT BY THE NEED FOR ABOUT
HIRING IN. BUSINESS OR OUTSIDE
OF THE PLACE WHERE THE HIRING
AND YOU'RE LOCATED. OR IF THAT
PERSON IS CUSTOMARILY ENGAGES
IN INDEPENDENT WORKER. WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF MEMBERS WHO. WELL I
USED TO CONTRA WITH WORKER. FOR
EXAMPLE THE HANG UP BY WILL BE
WHAT. I HAVE BEEN ONLY COMES UP
IN SOME. EVEN WITH THE EIGHTY.
UP FOR MANY CONSTRUCTING
CONTRACT TO THE MULTI FACTOR
TAP DEVELOPER A SIMPLER CLEANER
SOLUTION. STRONG EVIDENCE OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT EIGHTY FIVE
HAVE BECAUSE WITH A LARGE
NUMBER OF BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
THERE DO IT BEST AND THE
BRIGHTEST THEM BUT CERTAIN
SPECIFIC ABOUT THAT. ANYTHING
NOR CAL THE BOARDS ALTHOUGH THE
BENEFIT EVEN THOSE THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT. WITH INCREASINGLY HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT AND ECONOMIC
BUBBLE BUT OUR DATABASES WE
URGE YOU TO PROMOTE FLEXIBILITY
SO THAT MORE PEOPLE CAN WORK.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING BUT BELIEVES AND
FORWARD ENTER YOUR I. THANK YOU
MISTER JONES IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE HERE FORTY FIVE SECONDS
REMAINING FOR TESTIMONY FEET
AND WITNESS IN SUPPORT. LET'S
GO TO LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
PUBLIC TESTIMONY HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. AND WE HAVE
TEN MINUTES FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PORTION. PLEASE BEGIN EVENT
OCCURRED AFTERNOON THAT HAVE A
COME OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK BORDERS ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. FOR YOU THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH
SIX WE'RE GONNA WILL MOVE TO
ANY TESTIMONY IN ROOM TWO ZERO
FOUR ZERO ANYONE IN TWENTY.
FORTY ITS SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
OH SIX. SEE NO ONE THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB EIGHT OH SIX WE WILL
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO. BE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH SIX
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO
HAVE THE LINE THE LINE SIXTY
NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YES THANK
YOU OKAY. YEAH HI MY NAME IS
LISA ROCKS INCRIMINATE THE
CALIFORNIA I'M AN S.
CORPORATION OWNER AND THEY ARE
CREATIVE PERSON AND I. AM
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF IT A SIX
BECAUSE EIGHTY FIVE GILLES
GREEN AND INCOMES. THANK YOU
FOR THE TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE OF THE LINE. YES WE
DO HAVE. MINE. SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS A THOUGHTFUL FEAR AND-
A LINCOLN CENTER SO AND I AM A
MUSICIAN AND I AM DESPERATELY
IN SUPPORT OF IT SIX. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OUR NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN NUMBER
ONE TWENTY WELL IS THIS WE ARE
YOU THINKING OF ME YES- HI MY
NAME IS JENNIFER WALTON I'M A
PROFESSIONAL VIOLINIST AND
MUSICIAN CONTRACTOR- AB FIVE
INTENDED TO HELP OUT A FEW
WORKERS TO HAVE BETTER WORKING
CONDITIONS BUT WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IS EIGHTY FIVE. FIRED
ABOUT FIVE MILLION CREATIVE
PROFESSIONAL FREELANCERS
LEAVING US WITH ZERO INCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LONGER
STATE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION PLEASE. ARMY
MY NAME IS JENNIFER WALTON I'M
A PROFESSIONAL VIOLINIST
MUSICIAN CONTRACTOR. AND THE
AUTHOR OF AB FIVE USE A
SLEDGEHAMMER RATHER THAN A
SCALPEL TO TRY TO HELP TWO
HUNDRED MM YOU IF YOU COULD
PLEASE JUST SAY YOU'RE YOU'RE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEIR NEXT
TO A SPEAKER PLEASE. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS MARK KLEIN I'M A FULL
TIME GIG EMPLOYEE OR-
CONTRACTOR I- WORK FOR UBER
LIFT DOOR DASH POSTED RATES.
AND I ENJOY THIS TYPE OF WORK
JUST LIKE 75% OF US I SPEAK IN
BEHALF OF 75% OF ALL THE
WORKERS WE ARE TO BE
INDEPENDENT ALONG WITH 80% OF
ALL ACCORDING TO THE BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS 80% OF ALL IN
A BIT CONTRACTORS ENJOYING
FREELY CHOOSE IN THE CONTEXT
WOULD NOW BE AND- BECAUSE OF
THE DRACONIAN USER IF YOU COULD
JUST GIVE MY INTERNET ON YOUR
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE CAN. HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
EVERYONE SO PLEASE THE NEXT
SPEAKER. BOTTOM LINE ONE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MYRON DELLA ROSA I AM
IN. CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
EIGHT ZERO SIX THANK YOU. MINE
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS STOP ON
BALL I AM FROM VERO CALIFORNIA
I'M A CERTIFIED MEDICAL
ASSISTANT WORKING AS A
CONTRACTOR FOR A MIDWIFE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AS WELL AS
DOES MY HUSBAND WHO IS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ESTAMOS
GONNA I AM A CERTIFIED MEDICAL
LINK THERE BUT THERE I DO
ENGLISH SPANISH AND I PROVIDE
LANGUAGE SERVICES FOR ALL THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WILL NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF ACRE FEET. OFF MOST
OF THREE DIFFERENT THERE'S
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
I APPRECIATE MONEY TODAY. NINE
ONE FORTY FOR. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THERE'S A MIKE MATTINGLY
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND- I REPRESENT A
FUNKY FATHERS. AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHT OH SIX
I'M A MUSICIAN AND THE GIG
WORKER I HAVE FOUR FIVE
DIFFERENT GIGS I WORK AND THIS
JOB THIS BILL. IS GOING TO GIVE
ME BACK MY LIFE AND- ALLOW ME
TO ONCE AGAIN FEED MY FAMILY
AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR CUSTOMER GOING
UP ALONG THE FORTY UNDERSTAND
YOUR POSITION ONE OF SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS. ONE ARE SEVEN. MY NAME
IS BILLION DE L'ARTICLE CAN YOU
FIGURE. SEVENTY ONE YEARS OLD.
I WORKED TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTING JOB.
OPPOSITION AND I ALSO PART TIME
PROJECT OUT. AND GOD YES THERE
IS A FREEDOM OF BEAT OUT YOUR
CREDIT CARD TURKEY JOB ALLOWS
ME I'M SURE MANY THOUSAND.
YEARS TO WORK. CONSTRUED BY
HOURS WHAT I THINK. A LOT OF
YOU GIVE THEM. ONLY THANK YOU.
MOVE TO THE NEXT BIGGER THANK
YOU LINE ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JENNIFER SANTIAGO IS- FROM
GARDEN GROVE ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I AM A CERTIFIED
HEALTH CARE INTERPRETER AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. LINE ONE EIGHTY
YOUR MIND IS OPENED. YEAH I MY
NAME IS JESSE ROTH I'M BASED IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA I AM
SELF EMPLOYED AND OF THE
MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO OR AT. BUT I THINK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BY ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN DOEN'T RECALL LIFE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT ZERO
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER
ALL OVER O'CONNELL AS THE GIRL
TURNS I'M A WRITER REINVENTION
TROJAN YOGA INSTRUCTOR FROM
PASADENA CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THIS BILL AND I WISH
THAT YOU WOULD TREAT MINORITIES
BETTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE TESTIMONY NINE ONE SIXTY
SIX. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI
MY NAME IS KATARINA BOARD HE
I'M HERE IN IRVINE CALIFORNIA
ORANGE COUNTY I AM A STATE
COURT IN FEDERALLY COURT
CERTIFIED INTERPRETER I'M A
TRANSLATOR I WHILE FRANK WAS
SPANISH I'M AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF AT THE EIGHT ZERO THANK.
THANK YOU. NIN ONE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS PETER
BELIEVE IT SOME STANDING UP
CALIFORNIA THE FOUNING
DIRECTOR OF THE T. G. K.
PROJECT AND STRONG SUPPORT SB
EIGHT ZERO SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THERE MY NAME IS THE WAY OUT
I'M A PRIVATE TUTOR FOR SPECIAL
NEEDS AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES
I'M ALSO THE FOUNDER OF AND
POLITICAL EXPLOITATION OF
CHILDREN AND I WOULD LIKE TO
CALL IN TO SUPPORT AT THE EIGHT
OH SIX. THANK YOU. NINE ONE OF
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS BRIAN LITTLE OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
IT'LL SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M AARON GAIN I'M A
MUSICIAN WORSHIP LEADER AND
BAND LEADER IN ROCK IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I AM VERY VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE SB
EIGHT OH SIX. THANK YOU FOR THE
CALL NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS THE NAME
OF THE TUNNEL I LIVE IN
MONTEBELLO CALIFORNIA I'M A MOM
I HAVE A SMALL BUSINESS AND MY
HUSBAND THE TRUCK DRIVER AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT IT WE DON'T
THINK. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS ZACHARY HARDING
FROM MADERA CALIFORNIA- WITH
AMERICAN DRIVERS CLUB I AND
EIGHT DOORDARSHAN POST MATES
DRIVER STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
AS SPEAKER SB EFFECT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DEBBIE PART AND I'M FROM
CHANNEL CALIFORNIA AND THE
PRESIDENT OF A COMMUNITY
CHILDREN'S THEATER IN THE AREA
AND DUE TO THE- DEVASTATING
AFFECT ON OUR EDUCATION PROGRAM
I STRONGLY SUPPORT. SENATE BILL
EIGHT OH SIX. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS THIS IS REBECCA ST
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER THAT IS A
FIRST RESPONDER FOR SENIORS AND
FAMILIES IN NEED AS WELL AS A
MEMBER AT THE ACTOR'S EQUITY
UNION. PROFESSIONAL PERFORMING
ARTIST AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB EIGHT ZERO SIX THANK YOU IF.
AND NINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
NICOLE WILL CONVERT SOME I'M IN
ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA FIND LOW
RIDE SHARE DRIVERS TRANSCRIBER
AND A NUMBER OF OTHER.
FREELANCE PERTINENTES AND I AM
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU NINE ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES HELLO MY NAME IS SCOTT
FIRESTONE FROM ENCINO
CALIFORNIA I'M A FREELANCE TO
PERCUSSIONISTS DRUMMER STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH SIX
BECAUSE THE ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
USED TO HIRE ME ARE NO LONGER
ABLE TO DO THAT. THANK YOU FIND
ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I GET AFTERNOON SIMON
HAMEL IN BURBANK CALIFORNIA ANY
BILL THAT RETURNS THE FREEDOM.
TO CHOOSE HOW THEY WORK I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AND I AM SUPPORTER
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
SURELY GOLDMAN LA COUNTY- A
VIRTUAL ASSISTANT I'M ALSO A
SENIOR ALMOST SIXTY FIVE YEARS
OLD I HAVE DISABILITIES THAT
HAVE ALLOWED ME TO WORK. AS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR AND WORK
AROUND DISEASE THAT I HAVE AND
I. WRONGLY STRONGLY SB EIGHT OH
SIX. BRING BACK OUR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS KAREN
ANDERSON I'M THE FOUNDER AND
DMINISTRATOR OF FREELANCERS
AGAIN EIGHTY FIVE AND ON BEHALF
OF OUR ALMOST EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
FREELANCER MEMBERS BY STRONGLY
SUPPORT SHALL BE ABLE. TO
FIGURE LINE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES SIR MY NAME
IS NAY GROUP IN- FIND FROM
CHULA VISTA CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
EIGHTY EIGHTY. FIVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE MUSIC INDUSTRY
FOR TWENTY YEARS I HEAR AND
FEEL FOR ALL OF THE MUSICIANS
WHO HAVE BEEN ON THIS CALL. AND
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I
CONDITIONALLY SUPPORT SB EIGHT
OH SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR I'M PLEASED THAT
COULD YOU GIVE ME THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF- OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FILL.
THERE ARE FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
PEOPLE WHAT THE TIME HAS
EXPIRED FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
SO I WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE FOURTEEN
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINE. THAT
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH
SIX AND THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING WITH US TODAY WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO- THOSE WHO ARE
WANT TO TESTIFY IN. OPPOSITION
CENTERS ANY PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE IN
OPPOSITION GOOD AFTERNOON.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SERAPH LOCKS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WE
ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION. AND I
JUST WANT TO START BY SAYING.
ONE THING THAT THIS PANDEMIC
HAS LAID BARE IS THE DAMAGE
THAT MS CLASSIFICATION HAS DONE
TO OUR ECONOMY. AND DONE TO OUR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET. MS
CLASSIFIED WORKERS AND
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES THEY'RE
DELIVERING FOOD DAY ARE IN OUR
HOSPITALS THEIR TRUCKERS THEIR
JANITORS THAT ARE CLEANING OUT
CLEANING UP AFTER US. AND THEY
ARE DOING IT WITHOUT THE
BENEFITS OF THE RIGHT TO
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
TO WORKERS COMP TO ANY PD
PAID LEAVE IF THEY GET SICK OR
HEALTH BENEFITS. AND THIS IS
NOT JUST A PROBLEM FOR WORKERS
ARE INDIVIDUAL WORKERS WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN DURING THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS IS THAT COMPANIES THAT
ARE ALLOWED TO MISS CLASSIFYING
WHO CAN USE A CAN. FOURTEEN
PART TEST ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
SHIP SHIFTING THE COST OF THIS
ECONOMIC CRISIS ON TO
RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYERS AND ON TO
TAXPAYERS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THAT CAME OUT TODAY SAID
THAT OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS
WE'RE GONNA BE PAYING OUT FORTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN U. I.
BENEFITS TO WORKERS SIX HUNDRED
AND 50% MORE THAN WAS. THAT IS
GOING TO FALL ON RESPONSIBLE
EMPLOYERS WHO'VE BEEN EMPLOYING
PEOPLE AND PAYING INTO THAT
FUND. THINGS HAVE GOTTEN SO BAD
THAT FOR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS HAD TO COME IN
AND BAIL US OUT WITH THE P. WAY
THAT IS MONEY THAT TAXPAYERS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE. AB FIVE WAS A WAY
TO TRY TO REPAIR THE DAMAGE
THAT HAD BEEN DONE BOTH TO THE
ECONOMY BUT ALSO TO OUR SOCIAL
SAFETY NET TO OUR SOCIAL
INSURANCE WHICH MEANS.
COLLECTIVELY WE ARE THERE FOR
TO CARE FOR WORKERS DURING AN
EMERGENCY ALL OF US AND NOT THE
UBERS AND LEFT WHO- FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE U. I FIND
WE'RE GOING TO BE ON THE HOOK.
FOR PAYING FOR THAT LOAN THAT
WE'RE GETTING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BAIL US OUT. AND
SO AB FIVE WAS A WAY TO REPAIR
SOME OF THAT DAMAGE BUT ALSO
ALLOW FOR. EXEMPTIONS AND FOR
COMMON SENSE WAYS FOR THERE TO
BE SOME POPLE TO GO TO BACK TO
THE BROWN- TEST. AND TO THE
PEOPLE ON THE LINE WHO ARE
FREELANCERS AND JOURNALISTS AND
MUSICIANS. THE AUTHOR OF AB
FIVE IS STILL WORKING ON TWEAKS
AND FIXES AS THE BILL IS
IMPLEMENTED IN AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY AND TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN IS ONE OF THE WAYS TO DO
THAT. SO WE THINK THAT EIGHTY
FIVE IS STILL A SMART BILL
STILL HERE TO PROTECT WORKERS
AND THE ECONOMY AND TAXPAYERS-
BEYOND THAT THERE ARE. BILLS
MOVING FORWARD TO HELP FIX IT
AND SO WE WOULD URGE YOUR NO
VOTE ON SB EIGHT OH SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH REFLECT ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE- IN. ELSE IT
THE- IN. FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO
LIKE TO IN POP. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BOB ZERO ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL UNION HEALTHCARE
WORKERS THE ACTORS EQUITY GUILD
IN THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
NOW MOVING TO ROOM FORTY TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN.
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT OH SIX SEEING NO ONE-
THEN WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES ARE. PUBLIC WHO
WISHING TO SPEAK. VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT OH SIX WE WILL BEGIN. THE
PEOPLE WOULD WISH TO STATE
THEIR NAME THEIR POSITION ON
THE BILL AND THE THEIR
AFFILIATION THAT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL AND WE WILL HAVE. TEN
MINUTES OF TIME FOR OPPOSITION.
FOR THOSE OF YOU IN THE TO LIST.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT ZERO SIX PRESS ONE AND
THEN AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
DO HAVE LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M NOT IN OPPOSITION
I MEAN FOR ANYBODY WHO SAYS
THAT MONA GONZALEZ IS FIXING
THIS BILL DOESN'T REALIZE THAT
CALIFORNIA THE LATTER NOW
RADIOACTIVE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND NO ONE HI AND THANK YOU
YEAH ARE YOU SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE SIX
ZERO POLICE SO WILL MOVE TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT
THE OPPOSITION CALLER IS MIND
TWO TO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO TWENTY ONE.
THIS IS GREG COOK REPRESENT A
GREATER CALIFORNIA LIVERY
ASSOCIATION SIX THOUSAND
LIMOUSINE OPERATORS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU MISTER COOK. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO THE MIND OF ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THERE THIS IS JESSICA
SPENDER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THE MATTER MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE- GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THERE
ARE NINE PEOPLE NINE THANK YOU.
THANKS TO THE TO THE MIND OF
ONE FIFTY NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE FIVE ALIGN YOUR HELLO
THIS IS INSANE I'M I'M IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE YEAH I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS FALL
AND I FIND TOTALLY RIDICULOUS
THAT YOU. FOURTEEN PEOPLE OFF
AND DON'T LET THEM STATE AT
THAT. SIX HUNDRED MM WE HEAR
YOU AND APPRECIATE YOUR CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE NEXT TO
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
LINE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DRIVING GRAY
WELL IF YOU HAVE P. W. ACTORS
STATE COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JACQUELINE TURN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER TRADE
THE CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I ELECTED MERRY GO YOSHI
ARE A WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MINE TO
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION MACHINE AT. ALL
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
TAYLOR JACKSON THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO
IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
ATTACK THANK YOU. NINE ONE ONE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND EVERY
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND THE
UNITED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MINE ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I'M
DR KAREN KATZ LINE I HOPE YOU
LIKE ME ARE AGAINST- GET PEOPLE
HAVING ANY BENEFIT OF FREELANCE
INTERPRETING AND ARE YEAH YOU
CAN NOW- ISOLATED COLLEGE YOU
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING THERE BY MY
INTERPRETER. AS IT WILL BE
OVERLOOKED YEAH YEAH PEOPLE
JUST LIKE YOU MUST BE PART
THANK OSTER PROVOKE
TRADITIONALLY TODAY UP THANK
YOU YOU ARE OPPOSED NINE ONE
NINETY SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ONE NINETY SEVEN. ONE
MORE TIME FROM MINE ONE NINETY
SEVEN. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK COULD YOU
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN JUST
TO BE SURE THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL OF THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRISTEN BROWN OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. MINE TO THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY TWO THIRTY ONE
DROPPED FROM THE CAR OPPOSITION
TO. BUT ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. INCH IN OPPOSITION
THERE ARE NO FURTHER WITNESSES
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. AND THANK YOU
TO ALL OF OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS THIS SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THIS ITEM WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO TESTIFIED BOTH IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND I'D I
DO APPRECIATE WHAT THE GOAL IS-
IN THIS BILL TO. TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE INDEED SOME
LEGITIMATE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS OUT THERE IT HERE'S
THE PROBLEM HOWEVER. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST DECADE OR
TWO WERE PROBABLY THREE WE HAVE
SEEN THE DEFINITION OF
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR GROW AND
GROW AND GROW TO THE POINT
WHERE. PEOPLE REALLY ARE NOT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WHAT IT
IS THAT EMPLOYERS DON'T WANT TO
PROMOTE- ABIDE BY THE VARIOUS
LAWS HIM PROTECTIONS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE FOR WORKERS WE
PASS A NUMBER OF THESE BILLS
HERE. IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROTECT AGAINST DISCRIMINATION
TO PROTECT AGAINST WAGE STAFF
TO PROTECT ALL SORTS OF RIGHTS
THAT WORKERS WOULD OTHERWISE
HAVE SO. WHEN PEOPLE SAY-
THEY'VE LOST THEIR JOBS- THAT
ISN'T ACTUALLY CORRECT I DO NOT
BELIEVE WHAT I DO THINK IT'S
PART OF THE PROBLEM. IS THAT
EMPLOYERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HIRE THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO
THEY DON'T WANT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF A REAL
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONSHIP. THAT
BEING SAID THERE ARE SOME
SITUATIONS MUSICIANS AS AN
EXAMPLE- I KNOW A NUMBER OF
FREELANCE MUSICIAN SO I KNOW A
NUMBER OF FREELANCE WRITERS- I
KNOW A NUMBER OF PEOPLE-
INTERPRETERS. WHO HAVE
LEGITIMATELY HAVE THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES THE PROBLEM IS HOW
DO WE DISTINGUISH AND I WOULD
STAY I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE
ANSWER. I DO HOPE THAT WOULD TO
THAT SOLUTION BUT I DO BELIEVE
THE WATERS HAPPENED IN TODAY'S
WORLD IS THE PENDULUM HAS SWUNG
TOO FAR OVER. INTO THE
INDEPENDENT OCEAN EVERYBODY IS
IN IT PANIC CONTRA. AND ALSO
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A BIGGER
ARMY THEY HAVE THE BENEFIT IN
THE RIGHT IN THE. SO I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE FRUSTRATIONS A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE WHO FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAVE THOUGHT
THAT THEY WERE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS HAVE BEEN ABLE
BECAUSE HIM BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
ENFORCED. THE LAWS OF EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP AND THAT
NOW THAT THERE IS THIS A COURT
DECISION WHICH AB FIVE IS
ESSENTIALLY RESPONDING TO-
PEOPLE WHO. THOUGHT THAT THEY
WERE INDEPENDENT DIDN'T HAVE
ANY- REGULATORY IF YOU WILL-
ENTITLEMENTS- PAID LEAVE FOR
EXAMPLE ALL THE THINGS THAT
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
TO PROTECT EMPLOYEES IN THE
STATE. ARE NOW BEING TOLD BY
EMPLOYERS- WE CAN'T HIRE YOU
BUT THAT ISN'T TRUE. THE POOR
THE POINT IS THAT EMPLOYERS
DON'T WANT TO HIRE THEM THEY
DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO ABIDE BY
THESE REGULATIONS SO SOMEWHERE
THERE'S A HAPPY MEDIUM. I DON'T
THINK THIS IS YET BUT I. BRING
IN BILL AND I APPRECIATE THE
FIRST PEOPLE DISCOUNT WAY
THEY'LL THE LAW THE PART THAT
THEY HAD THE ABILITY TO YOU
KNOW TO DECIDE TO CHANGE. WHEN
THEY WORK BUT BUT THE FACT IS
THEY HAD DON'T. WOMEN ENACT
SOME THAT I MANY OF UP T HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON PROTECTIONS IN
THE WORLD PLACE WORKING ON OF
THE- OF. TO KNOW WHEN THEY GO
TO WORK THE GOING TO BE PER BY
PETE THAT NO THE- IF THERE ARE
OFFER THEY GET SICK ON THE JOB
THEY HAVE THE TO. APPLY FOR ON
A THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO FROM
COMP. INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
DON'T HAVE THOSE RIGHTS AND
THAT IS PART OF THE ROB PETER
SO- IT'S MY HOPE THAT AS WE
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION WE CAN
FIND THAT SWEET ART. PRINT IN
MORE RISK PROTECT. THESE ARE AT
THIS MAKE AND TING EMPLOYER
HIRE PEOPLE WHICH HAVE. EVERY
OF TO DO AND AT THE SAME TIME
TRUE ARE IN CAR. THE WAY THE
DEAF WORK. PUBLIC FIFTEEN YOU
OKAY A BEFORE EXPORT CHINS.
OPENING OUT WE CAN GET TO THAT
TO THE POINT SO. ALONG AROUND
SAYING THANK YOU FOR. YOUR
EFFORTS I DON'T AGREE WITH IT
BUT THERE IS A PLACE WE TO GO
TO BE A TO WOULD NOT. THE WHO
ARE INDEED TRULY A- CONTRACTORS
SAY SENATOR VICE MORALE THANK.
SENATOR HILL. SENATOR GROWTH
ONE ONE THERE WAS THIS THAT
I'VE HEARD YEARS AGO OP FOR ALL
IN FAVORITISM TOWARDS AND SO I
AT COURSE WAS NOT FAN OF A FIVE
IT IT'S CA CON TO THAT SAME AT
AND IT DOES WINNERS AND LOSERS
BUT WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT ISN'T
SO MUCH WHAT WE THINK- I KNOW
THE CALLS AND GET IN AND MIGHT
IN MY DISTRICT FROM
CONSTITUENTS AND I DON'T MEAN
EMPLOYERS BUT PEOPLE IN A GET A
CONDOM IT BURNS COMPLAIN I'M
JUST WONDERING- FROM YOUR
DISTRICT- NOT THE EMPLOYERS
BUT- PEOPLE THE ACTUAL IN THE
PAST CONTRACTORS DO YOU HEAR.
WHAT DO YOU IN YOUR NOW OF THE
WOODS BUT NOT JUST THAT YOU GET
A THE STATE NOW YOU'RE. LEAVE
OF OUR CAUCUS. CAN SHARE SOME
OF THE- CITY. ABSOLUTELY I
THINK YOU M. SIR SO IN MY
DISTRICT TIMES JUST LIKE ALL OF
YOUR ARE INDEED WHO BE THAT
THERE ARE HAS BEEN DISRUPTED BY
AB FIVE AND THE DYNAMICS
DECISION WAS A HEARING OR A
BILL THAT PASSED- SKEWS ME A
LAW THAT PASSED. BUT WE
CODIFIED THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
CODIFIED THAT THAT DECISION TO
LOG BUT IT ALSO CREATED
CONFUSION BECAUSE IT WASN'T
DIRECTLY WHAT THE DYNAMICS
DECISION WAS. IT CARVED OUT
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES SO EVEN
THOUGH THE LAW PASSED WHICH
SHOWS HOW BAD THAT LAW IS IN
THE FIRST PLACE AB FIVE MEANING
EVEN THOUGH THE SUPREME COURT
MADE A DECISION THAT SAYS THE
CLASSIFIEDS INDETERMINATE
CONTRACTORS A CERTAIN WAY THEY
WERE ALL UNDER THAT SAME RULE
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN AB
FIVE COMES ALONG AND CHANGES
IT. THEY EXCLUDE PEOPLE SO IF
YOU WERE ABLE TO CARVE OUT OF
THAT BILL YOU NO LONGER HAVE TO
REAP COMPLY WITH THE LAW THAT
THE COURT PASSED SO YOU HAVE A
LAW THAT COOPER PASS WHICH THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE STILL INSIDE
THE BILL LIKE OR SOMEONE ORDERS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA MENTIONED ABOUT. YOU
KNOW INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TRULY
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. IN THE-
THAT ARE TRULY INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. LIKE SALON OWNERS
AND WE LOOK AT YOU KNOW THERE
PROTECTIONS IN PP WILL THE
REGULATED BY THE CARS
COSMETOLOGY AND BARBER
INDUSTRY. AND THEY HAVE SOME OF
THE STRICTEST SANITATION
REQUIREMENTS EVER. AND EVEN
GOING BACK WITH THIS CALL THE
NINETEEN SING HOPEFULLY BUT AND
LATER STAGE TWO OR STAGE THREE
WHERE THEY GET TO BE ABLE TO BE
OPEN AGAIN. THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE EVEN MORE STRICTER
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO
PROTECT IN HAVE PP. THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE READY WILLING
AND ABLE TO DO THAT THEY BRING
US PLANS ALL THE TIME YOU KNOW
THIS IS WHAT WE CAN PUT IN
PLACE. AND NOT ONLY THAT WE HAD
ALL THOSE PEOPLE ON THE PHONE
AND I'VE BEEN GETTING MY PHONE
CALLS AND STAFF SAYS THE
PHONE'S BEEN BLOWING UP IN THE
OFFICE. BECAUSE THEY WERE
PEOPLE THAT WEREN'T ABLE TO GET
THROUGH AND SOME PEOPLE WAITED
AN HOUR AND A HALF ONLINE. AND
WE ALSO COLLECTED ONLINE
THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND SOMEWHAT
SIGNATURES THAT WE BROUGHT. IN
IN IN THE RECENT DAYS WHICH IS
NOT IN THE ANALYSIS WE HAD OVER
THIRTY FIVE INDUSTRIES. AND
CHAMBER PARTICIPANTS THAT CAME
ON BOARD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR. M. WHEN
THE DAY. TO SIT PASSED THAT WAS
A- RULING. IT WAS A COURT
RULING. AND THAT WAS FOR. EVERY
INDUSTRY WOULD BE PARTICULAR IT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. BUT
THEN WE CAME ALONG OR THE
AUTHOR CAME ALONG OF AB FIVE
AND- SHE SEPARATED OUT.
INDUSTRIES SO NOW YOU'RE
EITHER. COMPLYING WITH THE LAW
THAT THE COURT PASSED. OR YOUR
CUP STILL IN THE BILL. AND YOU
HAVE TO YOUR CALL IF YOU'RE IN
THE BILL YOU'RE COMPLYING WITH
THE LAW THAT. WAS PASSED. IF
YOU'RE OUT OF THE BILL AND WE
WILL BE CARVED OUT OF THE BILL.
THEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW. THIS JUST THIS
BILL JUST SETS AN EVEN PLAYING
FIELD SO THAT EVERYBODY'S ON
THE SAME PAGE IN EVERYBODY
COMPLIES WITH THE SAME LAW.
INDEED THE TEST. IN THE I'M IN
THE AB FIVE TEST. WITH THE A.
B. C. TIENEN. SOUND A LITTLE.
BUT THOSE THREE PROGRAM. ARE
PARAMETERS THAT ARE ALL. AND TO
MEET. SO LET'S JUST TAKE THE BE
PRIME BECAUSE THAT'S THE MOST
DIFFICULT TO COMPLY WITH. IT
SAYS THAT YOU HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH ALL THREE THERE'S NO
EITHER OR NOW MY BILL IS AN
EITHER OR- YOU COMPLY WITH. A
OR B. AND C. OR YOU CAN AS LONG
AS YOU COMPLY WITH AT LEAST ONE
TWO OF THE- TWO OF THEM WERE IN
THERE. SO PRIME BE. THE THIS IS
THE UNDER A. B. I. FIVE BILL
THE PERSON PERFORMS WORK
OUTSIDE THE USUAL COURSE OF THE
HIRING AUTHORITIES- BUSINESS.
SO IF YOU'RE A SALON OWNER AND
YOU A FULL. EMPLOYEE ARE IN
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN YOUR
BUSINESS OUR HAIR DRESSERS.
THEY CAN NEVER BE AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN THE SAME INDUSTRY.
IF THAT MAKES SENSE. SO WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO FIX IT AND MAKE
IT AN EVEN PLAYING FIELD AND
THAT'S ALL THIS BILL DOES. IT
DOESN'T ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE
CARVED OUT AND IT DOESN'T IT
LOOKS EVERYBODY'S UNDER THE
SAME IN AND OF THE SAME- RULE
OF LAW. I GUESS. IS THE BEST
WAY TO EXPLAIN IT AND I WANNA
THANK EVERYBODY WHO CALLED IN
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE LATEST US
SUPPORT THAT WE RECEIVED IN THE
STILL FOR MANY INDUSTRIES AND A
LOT OF INDIVIDUALSAROUND.
STATE THAT ARE. VERY UPSET WE
NEVER THOUGHT IN A MILLION
YEARS THAT. INDIVIDUALS IN THE-
MOVING IN AND- YOU'RE THE-
OWNER TO. INDUSTRY WITH. WITH
REPUBLIC CAUCUS THEY HAVE. OVER
THE LAST SEVEN. IN THE- BOMBING
SUPPORT HIS TERM. BECAUSE THEY
REALLY LIKE THEY'VE BEEN.
ROBBED OF THEIR WEIGHT MAKE A
LIVING. AND WE SHOULD NOT EVEN
WE SHOULD NOT. IF TO PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FOR. DURING THIS IS
THE WORK ON. TODAY. YES THIS IS
A ROOM FOR ME TO THE BILL YET
BUT NOT YET I HAVE A THANK YOU
I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES
SENATOR. YES AND I THANK YOU
YOU KNOW I REALLY ONE TO
COMMEND YOU THIS THE BILL I
THINK IT IT TO. YOU KNOW YOU'RE
CONSIDER OF CALLING YOU MIKE IS
TO OF IN CALL ME AND I HEAR IT
FOR. MULTI SENATOR THAT OF
THEIR KIDS ARE CALLING THEM
LOOKING FOR CHANGE THE FOR SOME
OF THE NEED REFER. OF AB FOR SO
THAT IT CAN BE MORE CALM.
REALLY MEET THE NEW OF THE K.
WORKING. UP AND UP CERTAINLY
THE ARE IN WERE IN CON ARE
ORDER AND APPROPRIATE THERE ARE
THOSE THAT HEAD AND MANY MISS
CLASSIFICATIONS AND ABUSES THAT
SHOULD BE CHANGED SO I. I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR-
COMMITMENT TO THAT CHANGE I
JUST DON'T THINK THIS IS THE
WAY TO DO IT BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING BACK IN AS WE SAW WITH
CARRILLO IT- JUST THE COURTS
MADE THIS. ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS AND THAT WAS DIFFICULT SO
I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I
CERTAINLY WOULD HOPE YOU WOULD
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION WITH
US AND WITH OUR COMMITTEE. AND
STAFF SO THAT WE COULD PERHAPS-
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN THAT SO
WITH THAT. I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. I'D LIKE TO TELL. WHO'S
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL
BEEN MOVED BY. MORE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS APPROACH SO. PLEASE
THE ROLL. OUR PLEASE TURN ON
YOUR MY- TO CAST VOTE. CENTER
NO. AND HELL NO. CENTER MARIE I
GENERAL HI CENTER JACK'S NO
CENTER JACKSON NO CENTER
MITCHELL NOW CENTER MID NO
CENTER PAN NO AND PAN NO. THE
BILL HAS A ONE I AND FOR KNOWS
IF. THANK YOU CENTER GROWTH
COULD WE GET RID CONSIDERING
FOR RECONSIDER GRANT DOUBLE YES
WE WILL GRANT RECONSIDERS
WITHOUT A THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR. SO THE HONORED IS SB EIGHT
THREE SENATOR KIRBY I. WHICH IS.
WELCOME SENATOR CARRIER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR. YOU
REPRESENT THE SB EIGHT NINETY
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S
MY PLEASURE TO PRESENT SB EIGHT
NINETY THREE A BILL THAT WOULD
GRANT A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION
PURPOSES TO HEALTH CARE WORKERS
TO PROVIDE DIRECT PATIENT CARE
IN ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS FOR
INJURIES INCLUDING MUSCO
SKELETAL INJURIES INFECTIOUS
AND RESPIRATORY DISEASES
INCLUDING NOVEL PATH THAT YOU
AND SUCH AS KOBE NINETEEN. LAST
YEAR IN THIS COMMITTEE ARE
PRESENTED A SIMILAR BILL TO
GRANT PRESUMPTIONS FOR A
BROADER SET OF INJURIES
INCLUDING CANCER IN PTSD IN
ADDITION TO THOSE IN CURRENTLY
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL DUE TO
YOUR CONCERNS. AND AFTER MANY
STATIONS I NEVER THE BILL TO
COVER TIONS THAT NURSES HAVE
EXPERIENCED IN OUR HOSPITALS
WITHIN ADEQUATE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT PROMPTED
ME TO INCLUDE NOVEL PATHOGENS
IN THIS BILL MANY OF YOU HAVE
SEEN THE STORIES OF NURSES
HAVING TO RE USE THEIR PP OR IN
THE WORST OF CASES WORK WITH NO
NINE PUTTING THEIR LIVES AND
THAT OF THEIR FAMILIES A GREAT
RISK. MY INTENT IS TO PROVIDE
THE PRESUMPTION OF A PASSAGE
WHEN WE IN THAT WHEN WE AND
OTHER SUCH LIKE THE ONE WE ARE
LIVING THROUGH TODAY. I DO NOT
INTENDED TO INCLUDE A
PRESUMPTION FOR THE REGULAR FLU
AND I'M HAPPY TO THAT MISSION
OFFER NOVEL PATHOGEN ACCORDING
TO LOT WHICH IS A TITLE THE
CALIPER COULD REGULATE. EXCLUDE
ORIENTS OF THE HUMAN EMPLOYMENT
VIRUS THAT OCCUR FOR. NOT
COVERAGE FOR A SYMPTOMATIC
COVERT NINETEEN WORKERS I'M
HAPPY TO AMEND THE LANGUAGE TO
REQUIRE WORKERS TO PROVIDE
PROOF OF A POSITIVE TEST AND
LASTLY THE REASON COVER
NINETEEN IS INCLUDED UNDER BOTH
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AND
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES IS
BECAUSE BECAUSE IT IS BOTH IS
BOTH AN INFECTIOUS AND
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS THE
LIKELIHOOD OF PANDEMICS HAS
INCREASED OVER THE PAST CENTURY
BECAUSE OF GLOBALIZATION. AND
CHANGES IN LAND USE AND OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT WHEN WE
FACE ANOTHER PANDEMIC WE CANNOT
FIND OURSELVES IN THE SAME
SITUATION WE ARE TODAY WERE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE
UNPROTECTED WHEN THEY ARE THE
ONES ON THE FRONTLINE SAVING
LIVES SB EIGHT EIGHTY THREE WE
WILL UPDATE OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM. HEALTH
WORKERS WHO INTERACT WITH OF
SICK INJURED PEOPLE EVERY. ARE
PROVIDED BENEFIT. PROVIDING
WORKERS COMP AND COMPENSATION
PRESUMPTION IS IMPORTANT TO
PROTECTING OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND EACH AND TO ENSURE
THAT WHEN THEY ARE INJURED
THERE NOT DENIED THE BENEFITS
THEY DESERVE OR THAT THERE IS
NO DELAY IN THEIR TREATMENT.
THIS WILL PROVIDE PARITY IN OUR
SYSTEM WHICH CURRENTLY GRANT
THESE PRESUMPTIONS TO CERTAIN
FIRST RESPONDERS ALL THESE
WORKERS RISK THEIR LIVES AND
WELL BEING EVERY DAY AT WORK I
ASK THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THE
CRITICAL DANGEROUS WORK HAVE.
HEALTH CARE WORKERS DO BY GRANT
PRESUMPTIONS AS WELL. I AM
PROUD TO BE A PRAGMATIC PERSON
AND ALWAYS CONSIDER DATA AS A
VERY IMPORTANT DRIVER OF GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY WE DO NOT HAVE
THE WHOLE PICTURE OF THE LAWN
FOR CLAIMS WE HAVE FIELD
EXPERIENCES AS YOU WILL HEAR
FROM THE MAIN WITH THIS. I ASK
YOU TO LISTEN CAREFULLY THEIR
TESTIMONY AND RELY FIX. IF
CLAIMS INCREASE IT IS BECAUSE
THE DANGERS OF THE WORKPLACE
HAVE INCREASED WE HAVE
CERTAINLY SEEN AS FOR ITS
OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS THE
DANGERS EVERY DAY. WORK HASN'T
BEEN THIS ARE HIGHER SO TO HAVE
WORK THE INCREASE FOR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS SB EIGHT
NINETY THREE IS A STEP. IN THE
CHAIN ECHO. J. THE CALL. THANK
YOU RESPECT. WHAT THEY A PHONE
JUST IN SOME. IS STEPHANIE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA THIS WHO WILL
ALSO PUT TECH ASSISTANCE FOR
ANY YOU MAY HAVE AND SHE
INTRODUCE THE TUNER THAT WERE
WILL TESTIFY AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY WE WILL NEVER ON TO
ANYONE WANTING TO. IN SO AND AS
WE KNOW WE HAVE THREE FOR THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF THREE MINUTES FOR
THOSE IN OPPOSITION SO PLEASE.
YOUR FIRST WITNESS. EDITOR
HE'LL STEP HE WILL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN STEP IT THANK YOU. EIGHT
ZERO HAVE YOU EVER HAVE THE
POWER THE THIRTY MEMBERS I TO
YOU AND I'M MOMENT HI I COME TO
AT A TIME WHERE THERE IS BEEN
LOCK OF LIFE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY NATION AN IMAGE OF
CALIFORNIA I JUST OFF THE CAN
BUT READING AND THEY OF OVER
NINETY ONE REGISTER NURSES
O'CLOCK LIVES AROUND COUNTRY I
NURSES ARE NOT YOU GARBAGE BAG
FOR IN CLASS THE BAD. WE DON'T
HAVE THE MESSAGE KEEP. PROBABLY
HEARD OF THE NURSE AT HOLLYWOOD
PRESBYTERIAN WHO YOU KNOW ARE
WELL IF WE TOOK CARE OF THE
CODE UPON THE PATIENT WITHOUT
IN IN NINETY FIVE ALL SHE HAD
WITH THE SURGICAL NOW AND THAT
PATIENT CO THE PART THAT SHE
DIED FOURTEEN DAYS LATER. WE
NEED. IT'S NOT ABOUT. WHAT
ABOUT IN JUST THIS IS LITERALLY
A MATTER OF LIFE AND THAT WE IN
THE STATE PARK OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
SIX AND COUNTY. HELLO BUT
POSITIVE NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN OVER
FORTY THAT. OF NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE WORKERS I JUST TALK
TO YOU ABOUT SIX OF MY OWN
MEMBERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY. IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE KNOW THAT
NURSES ARE GETTING. ACTION THE
JOB NO DUTY PH YEAH A FEW WEEKS
AGO THE FACT. THAT THE SHOW
THAT NEED ACTION THERE HAVE
BEEN ON THE JOB. BUT THEY LATER
AGGREGATED. NOT SHOW WHERE DEEP
IMPACT IT WILL HAPPEN NO WORD
ON THE JOB MOST AND DOES NOT
CARE IF YOU WORK IN A PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE FACILITY IT DOESN'T
MATTER TO GETTING AMERICANS ARE
BACKING. NO COLD WITH SHORT
MOVIE THAT DIDN'T. HAVE A
RESPECT. FOR THE NURSES. WHAT
FOR IS. OVER 90% WOMEN. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ONE PRESUMPTION
ALTHOUGH THEIR MAIL CANNOT IT
HE MENINGITIS BY OKAY. CANCER
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON. WE ARE
SITTING AT I TOLD YOU ARE I
DON'T WANT RATES BECAUSE-
CANCER OTHER INFECTIONS IN THE
BREAKDOWN OF FACTS 40% MORE
THAT INJURY A HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE MORE INJURIES TO WORK THEY
FIND TWENTY TWO PERCENT. PTSD
AND THAT'LL GO OUT BECAUSE THE
CODE. LITERALLY COMMITTED
SUICIDE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T DEAL
WITH THE DEATH TOLL IN OVER 24%
INCREASE IN MORTALITY RATES OF
OTHER CANCER DISEASE AND IT
HAPPENED RIGHT NOW. WE TREATED
OURSELVES WHAT THE RESPECT THAT
THEY DESERVE IT'S HEROES THAT
YOU SAY THAT THEY ARE IN THE
PRESS IN ON TV AND IN YOUR
DISTRICT THEY DON'T NEED A
SANDWICH THEY DON'T NEED A
PIECE OF PIE THE- P. P. THE-
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY. DO WE
SAY TO. MISTER ROBERTS AND I'M
SORRY. I THIS ROOM YOU'VE USED
WITH THE THREE NOT IN OUT INTO
OF ALL THAT BUT A LOT WELL YOU
GOTTA THE REPTILE THANK. WE
NEED HELP FROM. THE WORK COMP
SYSTEM AS WE WORK ALONE THE
HOSPITAL BILLION OF DOLLARS IN
CODE FUN WE CAN STAND THAT WE
GET THE NURSE BUT IT IS THERE
AND I YOU FOR YOUR- THERE ARE
YOU MISTER. APPRECIATE YOUR BE
HERE IN BEING PART OF CON TODAY
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC
TESTED. AND ANYONE IN TWO OR
THREE WISHING TO SPEAK. AND
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IT. MR TEAR
MEMBER SERRA FLOCKS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
REALLY THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANY PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE THERE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT NINETY THREE. SEEN NO
ONE THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIEW THE
TELECONFERENCE ENTER. IN
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT NINETY THREE AND WE
WILL BEGIN. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT NINE THREE.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATE COULD
YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND THEN- JUST AS A REMINDER TO
THE SPEAKERS ON THE PHONE IF
YOUR LINES ARE OPEN PLEASE MEET
ACCORDINGLY SO WE CAN AVOID ANY
FEEDBACK OR- YOUR- JIM
CONFERENCING SAID THAT WE DO
NOT RECEIVE ANY FEEDBACK THANK
YOU. WE DO HAVE. SIX PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE NINE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MATTER IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES AND CALL THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES USUALLY WILL CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MINE TO FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REALLY CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND TREVOR THERAPY BANKING TO
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MINE TO FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CENTER BORRERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MINE TO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISS
TERMINAL BUT- CURRICULUM
REMEMBER THE COMMITTEE I'M ARE
YOU SUPPORT TO FIND A MAP OF
THE UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS AND THE CALIFORNIA
REPUBLICAN ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER TO RICO. MINE TO
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHANE DAWSON ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND THE
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS
CALIFORNIA SCORE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE TWO FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY FIFTY
DROPPED MINE TWO ZERO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TO A SIX YEAR
OPEN. YOU MAY BE ON YOUR ON
YOUR END. MY TO A SIX AS ALSO
DROPPED. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE. THANK YOU WOULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR
SB EIGHT NINETY THREE PLEASE.
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
ON THE PHONE IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT NINE THREE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WANTED TO
APOLOGIZE TO MISS ROBERSON
BECAUSE I HAD ON MY LIST THREE
WITNESSES TESTIFYING AND I WHEN
SHE USED ALL OF THE TIME I WAS
CONCERNED THAT- THERE WOULD NOT
BE TIME FOR THE OTHER WITNESSES
FOR APPRECIATE SHE HAD ALL SHE
TO TAKE ALL OF THE TIME SO THAT
WAS GOOD I DID NOT KNOW THAT.
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR OF
APPRECIATE THAT SO HAVE YOU
HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON. AFTER
NOT OF GOD CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION MAY DIFFER MY TIME.
TO KILL THE UNDERTAKER IN HOUSE
EXPERT BUT ALSO WANTED AT THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IS EQUALLY AS
OPPOSED- FOR THE PURPOSES OF
TECHNOLOGY I'M- GIVING THEIR- A
POSITION AS WELL. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK. THIS IS THE THINKING OF
THE MASK OKAY THANK YOU. I'M
I'M A HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITALS WE JUST WE WANT TO-
ASSURE YOU THAT KEEPING
PATIENTS AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS
SAFE IS PARAMOUNT- TO OUR
ACTIVITY WE ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL TO THE COMMITMENT OF
THE FRONT LINE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. WHO COME TO WORK EVERY
DAY TO HELP OTHERS IN NEED AND
KNOW THAT WITHOUT HEALTHY
EMPLOYEES HOSPITALS COULD NOT
FULFILL THEIR MISSION OF CARE.
FOR THEIR PATIENTS AND
COMMUNITIES. I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE. THAT THE CODE
RESPONSE HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING. AND WE SUPPORT OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND WE ARE
WORKING. DILIGENTLY TO SECURE
PP ADMITS A GLOBAL SHORTAGE.
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
ADDRESSES. OF THE PRESUMPTION
WORKERS COMP- FOR COVERT
SPECIFIC. CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE
CHAIRS BILL DOES AS WELL AND
GIVEN THE FROM PRESIDENTE
CIRCUMSTANCE RECOGNIZE ON THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT SO I'M
GOING TO DIRECT MY COMMENTS TO
THE REMAINDER OF THE BILL. WHEN
WORK RELATED INJURIES OCCUR AT
HOSPITALS BOTH WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS RELY ON THE EXISTING
WORKERS COMP. SYSTEM WHICH IS A
NO FAULT SYSTEM THE BROAD
NATURE OF THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND PRESUMPTIONS FOR MUSCO
SKELETAL INFECTIOUS DISEASES
INTO THE PRIVATE SECTOR WITH NO
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THIS
MONUMENTAL CHANGE. THERE IS
BEEN FEW IF ANY COMPLAINTS THAT
THE CURRENT PROCESS IS NOT
WORKING FOR AGAIN MUSCO
SKELETAL INJURIES AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASES I'M OUTSIDE
OF KOBE WHICH IS. YOU KNOW
EXTREMELY UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE-
FOR EXAMPLE A MEDIUM SIZED
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
MUSCO SKELETAL INJURIES TOLD
56% OF THEIR CASES FILED
BETWEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. OF THOSE
THIRTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN CASES ONLY 2%
WERE DENIED FOLLOWING
INVESTIGATION. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS
CONSIDERATION OF A PRE EXISTING
CONDITION WHICH IS OTHERWISE
ALLOWED UNDER WORKER'S
COMPENSATION ROLES THIS IS
CALLED APPORTIONMENT. THIS
CREATES A NEW STRICT LIABILITY
STANDARD ELIMINATES ANY ABILITY
TO APPORTION THE CLAIM THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASING THE
COST OF EACH CLAIM. AND WHILE
IT'S DIFFICULT TO- QUALIFY THE
PRESUMPTION BECAUSE OF THIS
PRESUMPTION IT WILL LIKELY LEAD
TO AN INCREASE IN CLAIMS.
APPROXIMATELY 75% OF
CALIFORNIANS HOSPITALS FROM
SMALL RURAL HOSPITALS TO LARGE
COUNTY HOSPITALS ARE SELF
INSURED. ANY INCREASE IN
WORKERS COMPENSATION COSTS WILL
HAVE A DIRECT AND IMMEDIATE
IMPACT ON THE FINANCIAL ABILITY
OF HOSPITALS TO PROTECT ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY CARE. TAKEN
TOGETHER THESE CHANGES WOULD
INCREASE COSTS TO HOSPITALS
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS HAVE LOST
OVER TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
SHORT TERM ALONE DUE TO COVERT
NINETEEN PREPARATION WORK IN
RESPONSE. IT IS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED THAT THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM IS WORKING
CJ ASKS YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU
HAVE USED THE THREE MINUTES OF
TIME. IF WE COULD HAVE THE
UNDERSTAND THE ME TO PART OF
THIS THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TEN
MINUTES OF- OF TIME ALLOTTED
FOR THOSE IN- OPPOSITION TO SB.
EIGHT NINETY THREE WHICH BEGIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
ADDRESS CHARTER HERE ON BEHALF
OF C. SACK ACCESS INSURANCE
AUTHORITY IN THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION. ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. BETTER
INCOME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BORDERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES FOR
SEXUALLY OBSESSED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHICH INTO
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION. SEE NO
ONE OF IT OR ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SEEING NO
ONE THERE THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
NINETY THREE WE WILL BEGIN. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
NINETY THREE. PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONES AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. WE DO
HAVE FIVE PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION
VERY GOOD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES AND CALL THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL
CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINE TO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FRAZIER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS DEALING
GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. AND
NINE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
FILLED VERMAELEN WITH
ACCLAMATION INSURANCE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AND ALLIED
MANAGED CARE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AND ONE MOMENT. NINE
TO FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT THIS
IS TERRY NEILE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO OPPOSED. THANK
NINE TWO FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MADE
MEMBERS MAKE A MOPAR ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AND ONE MOMENT WE
HAD TO MORE IN Q. NINE TO FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
LINE IS OPEN UP TO FORTY SEVEN.
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE ON YOUR END.
ONE MOMENT. WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL LINE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR EMERGING BACK THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINE FROM THE
OPPOSITION Q. COULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE
SURE WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES. THANK
YOU WE DID HAVE ONE MORE LINE
COME TO MIND ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BREAKING IT
CREATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THERE ARE NO FOR
THE LINES IN THE QUEUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MEMBERS. OF THE COMMITTEE.
NAY COMMENTS FROM. THE DOCTRINE.
THANK YOU CENTER CARRIER FOR-
YOUR PRESENTATION AND- BRING
THIS BILL FORD I THINK THE
THING I'M STRUGGLING WITH IS I
KNOW THAT OFTENTIMES YOU KNOW
THERE IS A PRESUMPTIVE-
PRESUMPTION FOR A- GROUP OF
WORKERS- IN PUBLIC SAFETY AND
OFTENTIMES POINTED THE DAD WILL
THEY HAVE THE PRESUMPTION WHY
NOT US. THE SAME TIME I THINK
THERE IS CONCERN THAT- THE WAY
WE STRUCTURED WORKERS
COMPENSATION IS THAT- WE DO
HAVE A PROCESS IN WHICH- PEOPLE
GO THROUGH AND YOU KNOW IT'S A
HOP IN A CONTENTIOUS BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN. LABOR IN
BUSINESS ABOUT THIS BUT THERE'S
GENERALLY GALLON THE AND
THERE'S SOME KIND OF AGREEMENTS
AND TERMS OF POLICY TERMS OF
STRIKING A BALANCE. RATE AND SO
IN SOME WAYS ONE CAN ARGUE AND
YOU CAN POINT TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY FOLKS AND SAY WELL THEY
GOT IT HOW COME WE DON'T BUT- I
THINK THERE'S ALSO AN ARGUMENT
TO SAY WELL. WHAT'S I GUESS
BROKEN IN TERMS OF THE CURRENT
SYSTEM MAC MECHANISM OF BEING
ABLE TO IDENTIFY IN A PORTION-
THINGS BECAUSE THE AYE AYE WILK
KNOWLEDGE DE DE CORPS. ARGUMENT
IS CORRECT ARE THAT. WE HAVE-
NURSES AND OTHER EALTHCARE
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES WHO
ARE BEING EXPOSED POTENTIALLY
TO. DANGERS PATHOGENS NOT ONLY
TO THE NINETEEN BY THE WAY I
MEAN THAT'S A NEW ONE BUT- TO
THE OTHER ONES THAT YOU BROUGHT
UP. SO WILL CERTAINLY NOT
DENYING THAT. THERE ARE BUT TO
HAVE STILL USE THAT PRODUCT USE
THE EXISTING PROCESS TO SAY
WELL. YOU KNOW THIS IS HOW WE
DECIDE OR SHOW THAT THIS WAS
WORK RELATED AND THEREFORE-
YEAH YOU GET COMPENSATION
WORKERS COMPENSATION REGULAR
COVERAGE ALL OF THE BENEFITS
AND SO FORTH. VERSUS SAYING
THAT WELL ACTUALLY YOU DON'T
HAVE TO YOU KNOW WORK WE'RE
GOING TO. CHANGE THE BALANCE
THERE IN TERMS OF THE LEVELS. I
GUESS AN ALLEYWAY ASIAN BECAUSE
IT'S A PRESUMPTION NOW IT'S A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION GOT IT
YOU KNOW THAT- PLAYER CAN
REBUT. SO BIGGEST WHY ARE WE
TRYING TO KNOW WHAT THE WHAT
THE WHY WE TRYING TO CHANGE
THAT BALANCE- AND IT REALLY
THIS IS FOR YOU KNOW AGAIN I'M
NOT SAYING THERE'S THAT NOT
WITHOUT MERIT THAT THIS GROUP
OF WORKERS ARE. PARTICULAR
EXPOSED TO THESE PARTICULAR-
CONDITIONS THAT YOU'VEBROUGHT
UP IN THIS BILL- BUT THERE'S
OTHER WORKERS OUT THERE AS
WELL. BOUNCE PUBLIC SAFETY
WORKERS TO. CONNECT THE SAME
ARGUMENT. AND THAT. YOU KNOW
WE- SHOULD. SHOULD WE BE DOING
IT MORE BROADLY HE- AND HE DOES
THAT AND THAT YEAH WE- WE OFTEN
ARE HERE AT THE ENDS AROUND
HERE IN THE LAST WORKERS COMP
BACK AND FORTH AS WELL- IS THIS
REALLY THE WAITED. TO THIS AND
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE CURRENT
MECHANISM FOR TRYING. TO GET TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION IS. BROKEN
ARE IT'S- TELL. YEAH THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION IF YOU HAVE.
THIS IS THE WAY THAT THAT I SEE
IT AND- THE THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE WE HAVE WE HAVE CREATED
IT. A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE CERTAIN RISKS AND WE
DETERMINED THAT BECAUSE OF
THOSE RISK THEY SHOULD GET A
PRESUMPTION AND THEN WE HAVE
ANOTHER GROUP. THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE KIND OF RISK THAT
THEY UNDERGO THEY'RE EXACTLY
THE SAME WITH WITH SOME
DIFFERENCE THEY'RE NOT OUT ON
THE STREETS RUNNING AROUND BUT
THAT THEY'RE DEALING WITH THE-SAME. INJURIES THE SAME BODY
FLUIDS THE SAME. DISEASES AND
IT'S IT I LIKE AND IT I LIKEN
IT VERY MUCH TO THE SITUATION
IT'S CREATED WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT JOB CLASSIFICATIONS AND
WE'VE WE'VE CREATED A BENEFIT
THAT ONE GROUP GETS AND WHEN
YOU START LOOKING AT THE JOBS
THAT THEY DO. YOU FIND OUT THAT
THEY'RE DOING THE EXACT SAME
JOBS BUT ONE GROUP IS A GROUP
OF WOMEN AND THEY'RE GETTING
PAID TWO THIRDS WHAT THE OTHER
GROUP IT'S DOING THE EXACT SAME
WORK AT THE EXACT SAME. JOB
DUTIES BUT THEY'RE GETTING PAID
MUCH MORE AND SO THIS IS IT
THIS IS A SITUATION OF EQUITY.
AND THE EQUITY SAYS WHY IS IT
THAT THERE'S THAT THAT THE
GROUP THE FIRST RESPONDERS ON
THE SCENE. GET THE BED THAT GET
THAT BENEFIT BUT YOU PASS THE
PIT. OFF GROUP THEN HAS TO
BRIGHTEST ALL IN BY WHAT DO
WITH THE IN. WE ATE OH BY YOUR
DIFFERENT BECAUSE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND DE BECAUSE
YOU'RE YOUR YOUR JOB IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ON THE FRONTLINE MOTHER ALL
ON THE FRONT LINE AND THERE
THEIR RESEARCH. SAME DISEASE
PAGE. THEY INJURED. THE SAME
INDIVIDUAL THAT NEEDS TO BE.
DID AND MOVE. AND TREAT. AND
THE SAME BODILY FLUIDS AND I
AND TO ME IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM
TO MAKE SENSE THAT WE WOULDN'T.
AT LEAST CONSIDER. THAT THE
PRESUMPTION MAKES SENSE FOR ONE
GROUP WHY IT SHOULD NOT MAKE
SENSE FOR THE OTHER GROUP AS
WELL AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE MISSED BECAUSE OF THE
TRUNCATED- TESTIMONY IS
SPECIFIC NURSES TALKING ABOUT.
THEIR EXPERIENCES THEIR
EXPERIENCES WHERE THEIR HR TO
PRESSURES THEM TO USE VACATION
TIME AND THEIR OWN INSURANCE
RATHER THAN GOING THROUGH A
WORKERS COMP SYSTEM. WHERE THE
INTIMIDATION NOT TO FILE A
CLAIM BECAUSE THEY ARE
DEPENDENT ON THE JOB. FOR COULD.
INFORMATION ON HOW. ACCESS WORK
COMPENSATION BENEFITS AT THEIR
PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT AND SO
THESE ARE THESE ARE REAL
STORIES FROM REAL NURSES AND-
AND THE- THE QUESTION BECOMES.
YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE SYSTEM
THAT'S FAIR TO. WILL THEY GET
THEIR BENEFITS THAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO WHICH IS- THE KINDS
OF BENEFITS THAT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO RECOUP. FROM FOR A-
THIS OR IN IN THAT THE EIGHT UP
TO AT WORK AND JUST DIFFERENT
THE FACT THAT IT JUST A FOLLOW
UP THEN RIGHT I GUESS YOU KNOW-
DUE TO MY THE OTHER WORKERS AS
WELL YOU CAN MAKE THE SAME
ARGUMENT FOR. YOU KNOW REALIZE
THAT NO BILL IS PERFECT- TYSON
COMPASS EVERYTHING SO NOT
ASKING THAT. BUT ARE YOU SAYING
THEREFORE WE SHOULD RESTRUCTURE
WORKERS COMP SYSTEM IN A WAY
THAT WE- PEOPLE. THAT EVERYONE
WHO IS DOING ESSENTIALLY SHOULD
GET REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION. BUT
I'M WHAT I'M SAYING TODAY IS
JUST THAT WE TAKE ONE SMALL
LITTLE STEP- MADE IT TO STEPS
THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN BUT I'M
HOPING THAT WE GET UNIVERSAL
HEALTH HEALTH CARE THIS ALL
GOES AWAY BECAUSE THEN WE DON'T
NEED TO WORRY ABOUT A WORKERS
COMP SYSTEM BUT THAT JUST. THAT
JUST YOU KNOW DOWN THE FUTURE
OKAY WELL THE IT AND I'D LIKE
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION TO
LATER BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
A PAN SENATOR JACKSON THANK YOU
I CERTAINLY- SEE THE- GENDER
ASPECT OF THIS- AND BUT I HAVE
VOTED IN THE PAST I DID VOTE TO
GIVE THESE PRESUMPTIONS TO.
SOME OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS.
BECAUSE THE DATA SHOWED THAT
THEY WERE NOT. GET BEING GIVEN-
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS THE
APPROPRIATE RECOGNITION FOR THE
FOR THE FACT THAT THEIR JOBS
DID OFTEN PUT THEM. IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY- WOULD
EXPERIENCE ARE WORK RELATED
INJURY- SO I DO IT SO I DO SEE
THAT VERY DIFFERENTLY- BUT MY
QUESTION IS ARE- BASED UPON THE
OPPOSITION. THAT INDICATED THAT
ALL BUT 2% OF THESE CLAIMS. ARE
ARE GRANTED. I'M AT THE MY
QUESTION IS WHAT WHERE IS THE-
I'M- DOES IT LIKE THAT WHEN
THESE NURSES BEING ON THE FRONT
LINES IN BEING ASKED TO WEAR
GARBAGE BAGS AND HAVE NO MASKS
AND ARE DYING FROM THE THAT
LACK OF CONSIDERATION- AND
PROTECTION- THAT THERE ARE
THOSE CLAIMS ARE GOING TO BE
RECOGNIZED AND HONORED SO AND I
THINK WE ARE FOCUSING MOST OF
US AT THIS POINT ON THE COVE IN
NINETEEN SITUATION BECAUSE
EVERY DAY WE HEAR ABOUT MORE OF
FRONTLINE PEOPLE AND THE NURSES
AND MEDICAL PEOPLE WHO ARE
DYING BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF. A
PROTECTION THAT THEY ARE
GETTING ON THE JOB. SO FOCUSING
EVEN ON THAT OR- WELL NO I TAKE
THAT BACK FOCUSING FOCUSING ON
THE BILL WHICH OF INCLUDED
WHICH ARE ALSO MUSCULAR
SKELETAL PROBLEMS I KNOW YEARS
AGO WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
SENATOR. BABY IS THAT THE TIME
ASSEMBY MEMBER KILL WAS VERY
ACTIVE IN TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROVIDED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR NURSES WHEN THEY TO LIFT
PATIENTS TO HAVE PROTECTIONS
BECAUSE WE WERE SAYING A LOT OF
INJURIES BACK INJURIES AND SO
FORTH. I DID NOT SENSE FROM THE
TESTIMONY PERHAPS YOU CAN
CLARIFY THAT THERE THAT THESE
THE NURSES AND MEDICAL PEOPLE-
THAT YOU'RE SEEKING THIS
PRESUMPTION FOR OR ARE DENIED
THERE ARE CLAIMS. BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF THAT PRESUMPTION.
WELL I YEAR REFERRING TO A
SPECIFIC STATISTIC THAT COMES
FROM ONE LIMITED SOURCE OKAY
AND I WAS TRYING TO THE CAR
FIRING IS AND ALL THE PAPER
THAT I GOT IT MAYBE STEPHANIE
CAN. CAN ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
BUT- BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS IT
WAS A CLASS OF SMALL- AS-
HOSPITALS IT DID NOT INCLUDE
BIG URBAN HOSPITALS IN THE IN
THE EVALUATION BUT I AM. BUT
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO ME
BECAUSE I DO I DO AGREE THAT
THERE IS SOME GENDER. I'M
THINKING OF THESE WERE DOCTORS
AT MOST OF THE MORNING. THE
COVER. BUT IT GOT. HERE THAT
THERE WERE IN FACT THIS PRO SO
PERHAPS STEPHANIE WITH THE
CHAIRS PERMISSION COULD COULD
GET TO HER TO RESPOND TO THAT.
OF COURSE MISS ROBERSON. ARE
YOU STILL ON THE CALL. I MINE
AND I AND I'M WONDERING IF YOU
COULD SHARE IT THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR ONE. TELL
YOU THE STORY OF DOT NURSES ON
THE LINE NOTHING NEWMAN NAY. ON
THE ACTUAL THE NILE WE THOUGHT.
BY NOW- OF THE NURSES. THAT
HIGH OR COPPER OVER COLLUDED
RELATED DON'T AND SECONDLY I
THINK YOU KNOW BUT THERE. I
LIMITED ON THAT THE VERY
BEGINNING YOU KNOW WE ARE
DEALING WITH AN ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH THE NURSES ARE
OVERWHELMING. SURE TO USE THEIR
PPO INSECT. OVERWHELMINGLY
PRESSURED IN AN ENVIRONMENT.
YEAH DEAL WITH I MEAN THIS IS
ME PRESSURE COOKER WE ARE
SAYING IN THE MEDICAL FIELD AND
WHAT THEY WORK ON THAT NURSES
PACKAGES TAKE CARE I JUST HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THAT JUST HAVE TO
PICK UP THE SLACK SO THERE'S
THAT GOLD DATA YOU KNOW IF YOU
WILL THAT YOU WON'T NECESSARILY
BE BECAUSE THE NURSES. ARE BY
AND LARGE. YOU KNOW WE ALL WE
NEED TO BE YOU KNOW DIVERTED.
FROM YOU KNOW FINALLY. FIRST WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE STORY THAT
THAT YOU'LL HEAR AND- AND
PEOPLE THAT LEGISLATION PASSED.
ON MALE COUNTERPARTS WE DON'T
THEY FORCE BACK AND THE DATE
THAT THEY DON'T DESERVE THE
REDUCTIONS THEY ABSOLUTELY DO.
BUT THEY HAVE NOT HAD TO- MEET
THE STANDARDS THAT YOU'RE BEING
OUT OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR
THIS. ARE NOW CAL I'M NOT HAD
THE GOOD THAT THE KEEP FOR THEY
HAVE A WHOLE HOST OF
PRESUMPTION. MEMBERS I WOULD
JUST CAUTION MARK IF IT. TO FOR
A NEW SUBJECT FROM. HI THERE
ARE A LOT DANIEL YOU CAN YOU. A
HANDFUL OF OUR CA CALLED
IMPOSSIBLE UP TO TWENTY. THAT
ARE CURRENTLY BEING COULD NOT
WORK COMP FOR LIKE NOW. YOU
KNOW I DO DOUBT. I DON'T HAVE
TO HEAR THE STORY I SUSPECT
THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE GIVEN THE
FACT THAT. THERE TENDS TO BE
THESE PRESSURES THAT ARE PUT
ON. OF SADLY. THAT THE FEMALE.
OUR WORK THE THAT NECESSARILY
APPLY TO OUR MAIL OR WORK FORCE
AND I CAN IF THERE ARE IN FACT
THOSE SITUATIONS THAT'S REALLY
WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR. MY
CONCERN THOUGH IS WE'RE REALLY
TALKING A COVERT NINETEEN NOW.
THAT THAT THERE WERE SEEN THIS-
SO IF THAT IF THAT WERE THE
ONLY ASPECT OF THIS BILL I AM.
A HUNDRED AND 20% IN- BUT YOU
ALSO TALK ABOUT THE MUSCULAR
SKELETAL PROBLEMS AT SO MY
QUESTION IS ARE THOSE. DO WE
HAVE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT. THAT
THESE NURSES ARE DENIED TO
CLAIMS- WHERE AS OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AREN'T PART IN
THEIR PRIMARILY MAIL. AND THEIR
LEGITIMATE CLAIM SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THERE
ARE IN THESE ALLEGED MIX BEING
FILED BY NURSES THAT THEY ARE
BEING DENIED AND I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT IF THEY WERE. DAD
AT LEGITIMATE CLAIMS OF
MUSCULOSKELETAL PROBLEMS
BECAUSE OF LIFTING PATIENTS AND
WHAT HAVE YOU- THAT THAT WAS A
NON ACCEPTABLE BIAS GENDER BIAS
SO DO WE HAVE. A PERHAPS
STEPHANIE D. CAN YOU. A THAT'S
BUT- PART OF THIS BILL. MS
ROBERTSON. RIGHT SENATOR
SENATOR JACK. THE BILL AND I
pGET THAT LAST PART I I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T CHARGED OF A DEAL WITH
A COVERT NINETEEN IT DEALS WITH
OTHER ISSUES- THE MUSCULAR
SKELETAL PROBLEMS- IT
RESPIRATORY DISEASES MARI. MY
QUESTION IS ARE WE SEEING
DENIALS OF LEGITIMATE CLAIMS
THAT WE DON'T SEE WITH THE
PRESUMPTION THAT THAT OUR OTHER
FIRST RESPONDERS PRIMARILY MAIL
ARE GETTING BY IS THAT A
PROBLEM BECAUSE I DIDN'T HEAR
THAT AS PART OF THE-
PRESENTATION SO I I'D LIKE TO
KNOW WHETHER- I DON'T HAVE ANY
DOUBT ABOUT COLBERT BUT I'M
JUST WONDERING JUST HOW SERIOUS
A PROBLEM THIS IS IN FACT ON
THOSE OTHER ASPECTS THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO INCLUDE IN THIS BILL.
SURE SURE AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND I
DO APOLOGIZE AT THE TOP OF
THAT. THAT THAT THE MONEY THAT
I DEALT WITH A LOT OF TIME I
THOUGHT I FIND MYSELF AT ABOUT
A- FORTY FIVE SO YOU KNOW WE DO
HAVE- AND THEIR FAULT SO. IS ON
THE LINE BY YOUR- SHE HAD A
WORK. COMP CASE THAT WAS THE
NIGHT FORMER SO YEAH THOSE
THOSE THOSE CLAIMS HAVE BEEN
THE NOT. ON MERIT AND OTHER
INFECTIONS BEYOND HOPE FOR THEM
SO WE WANTED TO DEFINITELY IN
ONE MINUTE ON THE STORY AND
AGAIN I WOULD GET I WOULD
CONTINUE TO THE YEAH YOU KNOW
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT WHEN
SB FIVE FORTY TWO WENT THROUGH
THAT CAN MAYBE IT WAS THE
STARTED OUT ON PTSD YOU ALL DID
NOT. REQUIRE CLAIMS DENY ALL ON
ON THAT AND SO YOU KNOW. THIS
IS ABOUT RIGHT IN FACT THIS IS
ABOUT HI HOW THE JOB AND AGAIN
THE ADDED LAYER OF WHAT. THE
BILL. YOU GET HAVE TO SUCK IT
UP YEAH DAY HE THIRTEEN YELLING
THAT TIME WE'VE BEFORE
COMMITTEE. I CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT ACTUALLY PUT IN MY THAT
THANK MISTER OVER OF SHOOT THAT
TO. THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
AS MAY YES ABOUT VERY MUCH. TO
RECOVER YOUR WOULD YOU MY I'M
SORRY VERY BRIEFLY RESTATING
THE AMENDMENT YOU'RE TAKING OF
I'M TRYING TO BALANCE WHAT YOU
SAID WITH THE ANALYSIS WITH TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S NO LONGER ARE
THE MOMENT YOU STATED THEY
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS. THAT
FOR THE OKAY THAT WE'RE NOT.
GOING TO PAY FOR CHINA I
THOUGHT IT WAS ME ALWAYS OKAY
SO LET ME LISTEN. SO THE FIRST
ONE HAD TO DO WITH- THE DEATH
THAT USE OF THE CORONA VIRUS AS
THE- AS THE INFECTIOUS DISEASE
AND- AND THE ALLEGATION WAS THE
WAY THAT THE SENTENCE WAS
WRITTEN HUH. IT COULD BE
INTERPRETED THAT IT INCLUDED
THE COLORADO WHO BOUGHT IT
NEVER INSTALLED IN THAT TO
HAPPEN YOU NARAL THAN JUST TO
CALL THAT NINETEEN. WELL IT
WOULD BE NARROWED- YES YES TO
FIT THE DEFINITION OF THE
STATUTE WHERE WHERE- IT IT'S
OBVIOUSLY BEEN. DETERMINED TO
BE A DISEASE. THAT IT'S NOT THE
FLU IT'S NOT A RECURRING GOT IT
OKAY SO- THAT'S THAT'S NUMBER
ONE AND THAT THE SECOND ONE IS.
TRY TO REMEMBER WHAT THE SECOND
ONE WAS THAT I WAS TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE THERE'S THERE ARE
NUMBER POSSIBILITIES IN TERMS
OF LIMITING THAT THE BILL AND I
WAS WILLING. TO AT LEAST
CONSIDER SUB SOME OF THEM THE
PROBLEM IS WE DIDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NEGOTIATED TO
DEAL WITH THAT. SO FIRST WAS
WAS- WAS THAT IN THE OTHER ONE
WAS. DURING. LOW BLOOD SUGAR.
AND THE REASON I ASK IS BECAUSE
LIKE YOU SAID LOW BLOOD SUGAR I
THOUGHT I HEARD MONTH GILLES
SKELETAL TO THEM THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT THAT BUT
HE SAID HE WAS A MAN IN THAT
OUT BUT YOU'RE NOT. MANY KNOW
THAT WASN'T ONE OF OKAY. WITH
THE A SYMPTOMATIC COVERAGE.
OKAY TO ME WITH THAT IF IT DOES
IF IT INCLUDES THE REAL
INCLUDES IF YOU'RE A
SYMPTOMATIC- AND THEN GET GET
THE- DOT VANIK IT COVERS YOU
KNOW WILL BE RELATED THAT IS
CORRECT IN AND SO INSTEAD OF IT
SAYING IN IN A SYMPTOMATIC- YOU
WOULD IT WOULD REQUIRE THAT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE THE TEST AND THE
TO BE POSITIVE. GOT IT SO FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE. HOW DOES. IN
THIS ASPECT OF YOUR BILL
DIFFERENTIATE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER FROM
THE OTHER BILLS THAT ARE COMING
THROUGH FOCUSING ON COAL BID
HELLO SO THE TWO THINGS THAT IT
DOES IS INCLUDES MUSCO
SKELETAL- AND- AND THE- AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASES RIGHT AND-
THIS WOULD NOT TAKE EFFECT
UNTIL AFTER. JANUARY FIRST OF
NEXT YEAR. I IT'S NOT AN
URGENCY BILL- AND SO IT TO THE
ANTICIPATED THAT THE GOVERNOR
IF THERE'S A RECALL IF THERE'S
A NEED FOR HIM TO CONTINUE HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER HE'LL DO IT
RIGHT. SO HELP ME I'VE GOT A
LETTER FROM MY HOME COUNTY.
THAT FOCUSES ON MUSCULOSKELETAL.
BUT DURING THAT AND- YOU KNOW
RUNNING A LARGE. COUNTY HEALTH
SYSTEM THEY GIVE LOTS OF
STATISTICS AW AND PRICE TAGS
AROUND IF YOUR BILL WERE TO
BECOME LAW WHAT WOULD YOUR
COUNTER TO THAT BE NOT THIS LA
COUNTY BUT ANY COUNTY OR ANY
LARGE HEALTH SYSTEM. I THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE OF ASSUMPTIONS
THAT ARE THAT ARE BUILT INTO
THE LETTERS THAT I RECEIVED IN
THAT IT LOOKED AT ONE IS THAT-
IS THAT IT IS AND- I THINK THAT
THE WORD THEY WERE USING WAS A
CONCLUSIVE PRESUMPTION. THAT
THAT'S NOT ANTICIPATED BY THE
BILL AND THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
POLICE OR FIRE HAVE EITHER-
THAT IS A STANDARD THAT IS
PULLED OUT OF SOMEWHERE AND
STUCK IN FRONT OF A IN FRONT OF
THE LANGUAGE OF THAT WORKERS
COMP IN SO THAT. WOULD I THINK
BE VERY VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T PRESENT ANY TESTIMONY
TO OVERCOME THAT KIND OF THAT
PRESUMPTION AND THAT'S NOT WHAT
IT'S WHAT'S INTENDED. BUT THEN
THEN THEY USE THE LANGUAGE THAT
IS A STRICT LIABILITY- AND THIS
ISN'T STRICT LIABILITY THIS IS
THIS IT THERE'S IT'S A
PRESUMPTION AND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN STRICT LIABILITY IN
PRESUMPTION IS IT STRICTLY BE
THE BILL ANY MEANS HOW YOU PAY
FOR IT NO MATTER WHAT. WHICH IS
WHAT GETS YOU INTO THE
CONCLUSIVE PRESUMPTION AS WELL
SO WORDS BECOME IMPORTANT- THIS
IS NOT A STRICT LIABILITY ISSUE
IT'S EASY TO A PORTION- THERE
THE RISKS. ACCORDING TO YOU
KNOW IF YOU WORK FOR A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT ORGANIZATION- IT'S
DONE ALL THE TIME AND SO- THAT
TO MEET IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE-
A REAL ISSUE BUT BUT LET ME
JUST SAY THAT THAT. YOU KNOW ON
THE ONE HAND IT'S ARGUED. THAT
NURSES ARE ALREADY- HELP YOU
KNOW FIRST LINE HELP HELP
HEALTHCARE WORKERS ARE ALREADY
GETTING ALL OF THE BENEFITS BET
BET. THAT DATE THERE'S NO ONE.
RED IS NOT RECEIVING THE
BENEFITS THAT DIDN'T. GET IT AT
THE WORK. I'M AND THEN ON THE
SAME TOKEN WHEN THEY SAY WELL
IF YOU DO EVER BUT ABOUT
PERCEPTION. THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT
MORE COSTS I WOULD ARGUE THAT-
THAT IS A KNEE JERK REACTION.
TO A CHANGE IN THE SYSTEM AND
I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S TRUE.
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE ALREADY
GETTING. THE BENEFITS THEN HOW
CAN IT GO UP WHEN THEY YOU GET
THE CONCLUSIVE PRESUMPTION WITH
THAT I'M NOT CONCLUSIVE THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION WHAT.
THE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION DOES
IS IT KEEPS YOU OUT OF THAT
WHOLE SYSTEM. OF DOING THE
MEDICAL REVIEW AND IF YOU'VE
EVER TALKED TO A WORKER THAT'S
GONE THROUGH THAT MEDICAL
REVIEW PROCESS WHAT HAPPENS IS
YOUR DOCTOR TAKES A LOOK AT
YOU. EXAMINED YOU DOES A REPORT
SENDS IT INTO WORKERS COMP AND
WORKERS COMP SENDS IT OUT TO AN
OUT OF STATE DOCTOR. WHO JUST
LOOKED AT THE PAPERWORK AND
DETERMINES WHETHER WHAT WHAT
YOUR DOCTOR SAID IS TRUE OR NOT
AND WHETHER. YOU'RE HURTING
LIKE YOU SAY OR NOT AND THAT
COSTS MONEY AND THAT DELAYS THE
SYSTEM AND IT IT- IT'S A IT'S A
BURDEN ON THE SYSTEM IN YES
IT'S USED TO WEED OUT FRAUD.
BUT BUT IN IN THIS KIND OF AN
INSTANCE IF IN FACT THE NURSES
ARE ALREADY GETTING THERE'S
BENEFITS WHAT'S THE ADDITIONAL
COST YOU'RE ACTUALLY SAVING
MONEY BY NOT SENDING IT OUT FOR
THESE. MEDICAL REVIEW SO I
THINK PART OF IT IS JUST A KNEE
JERK REACTION TO A SITUATION
THAT TO CHANGE AND I GET THE
CHANGE MAKES PEOPLE REALLY
NERVOUS IN IN A BUSINESS-
ENVIRONMENT YOU WANT CERTAINTY
BUT- BUT I IT'S THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE- AT. I
FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT THAT
WE'VE SET UP A SYSTEM IN THE
SYSTEM IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE. FOR
GUN AT. I RECOGNIZE A BENEFIT
FOR ONE MORE GROUP OF WORKERS
AND THE AND THE SAME. THE SAME
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE BEING
TRANSFERRED INJURED AND
INFECTIOUS TO ANOTHER GROUP AND
THEY'RE TAKING RESPONSIBILITY
IN ACTUALLY SPENDING A WHOLE
HECK OF A LOT MORE TIME THAN
THE POLICE AND FIREFIGHTERS
THEN IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
TO ME NOT TO. NOT TO DO IT. IF
I MAY WITH CHAIR- BUT I REALLY
JUST LOSE MY QUESTION ON MY OWN
PIECE OF PAPER. AT ONE THING I
WOULD SAY I THINK. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING WITH REGARD TO THE
PROVISION OF PP I JUST THINK
YOU KNOW WE HEARD THIS BILL
LAST YEAR AND WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE ADDITION OF COLD
IT TOO AND I THINK THAT'S
APPROPRIATE IN KEEPING WITH THE
OTHER BILLS AS WELL AS
EXECUTIVE ORDER I JUST. I DON'T
WANT US TO COMBINE THE A MOTION
THAT WE'RE ALL EXPERIENCING
RECOGNIZING THAT NURSES ARE
PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
EVERY DAY WITH THIS- DIFFERENT
YET SIMILAR PUBLIC POLICY
DISCUSSION THIS WILL THIS THE
EIGHT WE LOOK VOTE THIS BILL
OUT TODAY WILL HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH MORE PP COMING INTO
HOSPITALS FOR NURSES I JUST
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT WE
SEPARATE. WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US
FROM THE EMOTION OF WHAT WE'RE
ALL EXPERIENCING I JUST FELT
THE NEED TO SAY THAT- I WAS
STRUCK BY THE NOTION I
APPRECIATE THAT IS ANECDOTAL-
THAT NURSES ARE BEING-
ENCOURAGED TO. NOT FOLLOW KIND
OF CURRENT PROTOCOL WITH REGARD
TO THE EXISTING SYSTEM AND
BEING TOLD TO TAKE THEIR OWN
PERSONAL TIME AND SICK TIME.
AND IF THE CHAIR WOULD ALLOW-
IN THE OF THE- THOSE IN
OPPOSITION COULD COMMENT ON
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S TROUBLING.
PLEASE NO PLEASE GO AHEAD NO
MATTER THANK OR THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION ARE YOU
GOING TO KEEP THE FUN. WE CAN
HEAR YOU OKAY GREAT- SO I MEAN
IT IS THAT A TOTAL SO IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO RESPOND- BUT WHAT I
AM AWARE OF ITS EARLY AND
ANYTHING THAT WAS AGAIN TO THE
COVERT SITUATION. EARLY IN THE
SITUATION THERE WAS A LOT OF.
CHANGING GUIDANCE ON INFECTION
CONTROL AND YOU KNOW I MEAN
FROM THE CDC AND CITY PH AND
CAL OSHA AND THE GOVERNOR. AND
SO- SOME EMPLOYERS MIGHT HAVE.
HAD EMPLOYEES. USE THEIR PAID
TIME OFF EARLY IN THE PROCESS I
THINK IT'S TIME MOVE DONE
FRANKLY MOST HOSPITALS ACTUALLY
MOVED TO A SITUATION WHERE THEY
WERE EITHER GIVING ADDITIONAL
TIME. I'M SORRY COATED-
SPECIFIC RELATED PAID TIME OFF
OF SOMEBODY WAS L. FOR HER IF.
WORKERS COMP CLAIMS ARE FILED
THEY WERE ACCEPTING THEM- AND
THIS IS PARTICULARLY AFTER THE
CHILDREN PLACE ORDER- YOU KNOW
WHERE PEOPLE WERE REALLY.
LEAVING THEIR HOMES TO GO TO
WORK SO IT'S HARD TO RESPOND TO
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T HAVE THE
FACTS ON- I'M NOT GONNA SAY
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN EARLY ON BUT
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT WHERE
THINGS ENDED UP. AND THAT'S NOT
WHERE THEY ARE NOT OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE BOARD THAT'S FIGURE
THAT'S FAIR THANK YOU LAST
QUESTION FOR SAID TO CABALLERO-
MY STAFF RIGHT IT SAYS THAT THE
BILL CREATES- WORKERS COMP.
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY FOR
NURSES AND OTHER HOSPITAL
EMPLOYEES. WHO WHO ARE THE
OTHERS THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK IN THE SAME AND IN
THE SAME SPACE OVER HE CAB I
MEAN IS IT- WELL WE'VE WE'VE AS
WE'VE ASSUME THEY'RE GOING TO
BE THE TAX AND THE- THE-
INDIVIDUALS A PROVIDE EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN THROUGH THE
EMERGENCY ROOMS. UNDER THE BILL
ACTUALLY LIST THE OTHER-
POSITIONS SO THEY DON'T. IT
DOES NOT LIST THOSE POSITIONS.
AND SO WHAT IS THE LANGUAGE IN
THE ACTUAL BILL WHAT DOES IT
SAY FOR NURSES AND IT DOES
AFFECT OTHER HOSPITAL
EMPLOYEES. IS THAT THE LANGUAGE
ISSUES IN THE BILL. THIS GLOB
COPY THE BILL IN FRONT OF ME
MISTER BOWMAN TO. LARGE
CONSULTANT CAN. THE CHAIR
GETTING INBOUND STAFF SENATE
LABOR COMMITTEE IT IT TALKS
ABOUT- EMPLOYEES OF ACUTE THE
HELP OF A HOSPITAL THE PROVIDE
DIRECT PATIENT CARE GOT IT.
OKAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR MITCHELL OTHER
COMMENTS. FOR QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE SENATOR COMPARE WHICH
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL I'M
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THIS BILL AND TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ARE
REALLY APPRECIATED HERE TODAY
AS DIFFICULT AS IT IS TO NOT BE
ABLE TO SEE PEOPLE AND NOT HAVE
OUR WITNESSES HERE- I DO
APPRECIATE IT AND I'M THIS IS
THIS IS- THIS IS NEAR AND DEAR
TO MY HEART- I HAVE NURSES IN
MY FAMILY AND WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THESE- THESE
KINDS OF INJURIES IN THE KIND
OF CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE
JUST GETTING SOMEONE TO PAY
ATTENTION. TO THEM ABOUT THEM
AND SO- I REDUCE SPECTRAL YES
RIGHT YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I DO. I THINK
WE ALL APPRECIATE THAT PASSION
THAT WE'VE HEARD THIS YEAR AND
LAST YEAR OVER THIS- THIS BILL
AND IT. I KNOW IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO YOU YOU AND YOUR
DISTRICT AND YOUR FAMILY.
UNFORTUNATELY IN ON OUR
CONVERSATIONS I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND-
I ATE AT FOR A COUPLE REASONS
ONE WE'VE NOT THE STAFF WHICH
THE NEED FOR THE PRESUMPTIONS
THE DATA IT IS WE JUST CAN'T
SEE IT SUPPORTS THAT. THERE MAY
BE OTHER REASONS THAT PEOPLE
THINK OR ANECDOTALLY WHY THERE
SHOULD BE BUT THE DATA IS WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GO BY TODAY AND
WELL I AGREE WITH THE SPIRIT OF
THE- AMENDMENTS INCLUDING THE
COVERT NINETEEN. OPTIONS I
THINK THAT THEY GO TOO FAR EVEN
IF YOU ADDRESS THE NOVEL
PATHOGENS- ISSUE. YOU KNOW I
JUST I FEEL THAT IT'S- IT'S
DIRECTORS TOO MUCH WITHIN IT IT
DOESN'T GO BECAUSE BEYOND THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND
I BELIEVE A PRESUMPTION NEEDS
TO HAVE A SUNSET. BECAUSE OF
THE CALL OUR REALITY WITH COVE
IN NINETEEN HOPEFULLY IN THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS WILL BE
DIFFERENT. THAN IT IS TODAY.
AND WE NEED A MECHANISM TO BE
ABLE TO REVISIT THAT AND- AS
WELL AS THE PRESUMPTIONS AS THE
REALITY CHANGES AS WE DEAL
WITH. WITH THE- THE PANDEMIC
AND COVERT NINETEEN- AND IT'S
CERTAINLY THE ISSUE OF THE PPVS
IS CRITICAL BUT THAT IS ANOTHER
ISSUE AND- I THINK WE ALL WANT
TO SUPPORT THAT EFFORT TO TRY.
AND GET THAT SO- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON. SB. EIGHT NINETY
THREE THEY'LL- I WAS VERY GOOD
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY-
SENATOR MITCHELL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES
TO VOTE. SENATOR HILL NO.
CENTER HILL NO CENTER MORALE NO.
CENTER MORALE NO SENATOR
JACKSON'S. SENATOR MITCHELL.
SENATOR PAN. THE BILL HAS NO
EYES AND TO KNOWS AND IT FAILS
WHO WOULD BE HAPPY TO GRANT
RECONSIDERATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU YOU. THE THANK BRING
WITH IT SHOULD BE NINE FORTY
THREE. WELCOME SENATOR CHECK. I
FELT THAT. WHEN YOU'RE READY HE
MAY PRESENT TO SB NINE FORTY
THREE THANK OU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON IMPROVING THIS BILL
THROUGH THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
OUTLINING THE ANALYSIS WHICH I
WILL BE ACCEPTING TODAY. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MILLION
RECENTLY ENACTED TEMPORARILY
PROGRAMS TO HELP EMPLOYEES
WEATHER THE STORM CREATED BY
COVERT NINETEEN. THESE ARE MUCH
NEEDED PROGRAMS FAMILIES ARE
STRUGGLING ESPECIALLY PARENTS.
WITH ALL SCHOOLS CLOSED PARENTS
ARE SCRAMBLING TO WORK AND CARE
FOR THE CHILDREN. NEW FEDERAL
PROGRAMS PROVIDE LEE FOR THOSE
PARENTS CARING FOR THE CHILDREN
WHEN DISPLACED FROM SCHOOL
DURING THE CRISES HOWEVER THERE
ARE GAPS IN THE PROGRAM THAT
LEAVES SOME FAMILIES BEHIND.
FEWER THAN HALF OF WORKERS ARE
COVERED BY THE FEDERAL LEAVE
PROGRAM. SO FOR EXAMPLE
CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT QUALIFY
INCLUDE PARENTS WHO WORK FOR IT
FOR AN EMPLOYER WITH FIVE
HUNDRED PLUS EMPLOYEES. SOME
PARENTS WORK FOR EMPLOYER WITH
FEWER THAN FIFTY EMPLOYEES AND
ANY PARENT WITH CHILDREN
DISPLACED FROM SCHOOL LONGER
THAN THREE MONTHS WE ARE IN A
CRISIS AND CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
STEP UP AND FILL THESE GAPS. SB
NINE FOUR THREE ONE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA PARENTS HAVE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE OPPORTUNITIES WHEN
THEIR CHILD IS THIS PLACE FROM
SCHOOL DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN.
THIS BILL CARRIES A SUPPORTER
TEACHERS AND PARENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR CHIANG AND- I KNOW WE
HAVE- THREE MINUTES FOR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF WITH
YOUR WITNESSES AND I KNOW
KATHLEEN. FAYE IS ON THE LINE
IS YOUR WITNESS IN SUPPORT SO-
PLEASE- OF HELLO KATHLEEN FOR A-
TO TESTIFY SHE- THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE FORTY
THREE AUTHORED BY SENATOR
CHIANG. SB NINE FORTY THREE
PROVIDES CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR
FAMILIES DURING THIS
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH PARENTS ARE BEING
CHALLENGED TO PROVIDE FOR THE
CARE AND EDUCATION OF THEIR
CHILDREN. DURING SCHOOL
CLOSURES WHILE FACING THE TRY
TO FINANCIAL SECURITY FOR DOING
SO. FEDERAL MEASURES MAY HELP
THAT ACCORDING TO OUR AREA WILL
BE JUST AS MANY CALIFORNIANS
BEHIND. SAFETY NET IS SOMETIMES
NEEDED TO CATCH THEIR SYSTEM
WHEN MY FATHER IN THIS CASE
THERE WAS A STUMBLE THE
REQUESTED. BY A VIRUS UNDER THE
SAME CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH WE
ALL NOW FIND OURSELVES. SHE
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES WITH
THEIR HARD WORKING PARENTS NEED
THE PROTECTION HAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES TO GET THEM THROUGH
THIS DIFFICULT TIME. WE CAN
PRESERVE THE LONG TERM
STABILITY OF OUR STATE FUTURE.
SURE SURE EXHALATION TURN ON
ALL THAT YOU ADD TO THAT
PARENTS UNEXPECTED ROLLER CLONE
SCHOOLERS. AT A TIME WHEN
THEY'RE STARTING TO HOLD ON TO
THEIR JOBS ANY SENSE. AND IN
HARM'S IMPAIR FAMILY STABILITY.
WE NOW GET. MENTAL HEALTH IS
EXPECTED TO TAKE A BIG HIT AS A
RESULT OF THIS CRISIS SHE
COMBINED ALL OF THIS AND YOU
UNDERSTAND THE CRITICAL NEED TO
HELP FAMILIES TO REDUCE THE
KIND OF PANDEMIC RELATED STRESS
AT THIS BILL ADDRESSES. SHOULD
MAKE NO MISTAKE CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE IS TIED TO HOW WELL
TODAY'S CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
CAN WEATHER THE CURRENT CRISIS.
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA SUPPORT SB
NINE FORTY THREE THANKS SENATOR
CHAIN FOR EDUCATION
LEGISLATION. AND THE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF
ITS PASSAGE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER A THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. ARE THERE ANY
PUBLIC THE IS THERE ANY ONE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE FORTY THREE. SHEEN NO
ONE WELL- IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FORTY THREE. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FORTY THREE WE WILL THEN
BEGIN. THANK YOU ANDLADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FORTY THREE. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO TO BE CUED UP.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF. SB NINE FORTY THREE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE LINE SEVENTY
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR NAME
SENATORS FROM BOTH SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT.
PHONE NINE FORTY THREE WEWANT
TO JOIN THE PTA AND THINKING
SENATOR CHIANG FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH WILL GIVE MORE
FAMILIES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SOUTHERN HOME WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AND I. WILL HAVE LONG
TERM SOCIETAL BENEFIT THE
DECISION TO HOME HELP BUTTON
THE CURTAIN RODS AND PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH CARING ADULTS WHO
CAN HELP THEM ENGAGE WITH
INSTRUCTION BEING PROVIDED BY
THEIR TEACHER DURING THE THIRD
OF QUITE LEARNING. AND BLANKS
FAMILIES TOGETHER FOR MOST MOST
SUPPORT. IN THE MIDST OF DRAMA.
EIGHT WORK THAT WENT INTO
CRAFTING THE THOUGHT OF A MAN
OKAY. THE BILL IS A IT. REASONS
WHY WORKERS. FAMILY LEAVE. ANY
SUPPORT THAT THE BENEFIT. OF
PAID FAMILY PROGRAM A WORLD.
OVERALL FAMILY HELP YOU PEOPLE
IN THE WORKFORCE THE WORKERS
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO
QUIT. TAKE CARE OF. THEIR
FAMILY. HELLO SO LEAVE. OKAY
WITH OUR FORM. IN A COMMON
AROUND THE WORLD. FIND OUT HOW.
WITH THE PRIMARY CARETAKER ALSO
STRENGTHENED BY BONTA HOPING
CHILDREN BUILT. ON THE STATE
AND THEY- WHICH LOVED HIM EVEN
IF THE LEARN OKAY SELF
AWARENESS TRUST. AND I THINK WE
HEARD YOUR AYE BOTH. THANK YOU.
MINE TO SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. I'M SORRY
LINE TO SIXTY SEVEN HAS DROPPED
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
FAVOR OF IT SB NINE FORTY THREE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ON THE PHONE. THERE ARE
NO LINES INTO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU LISTA IF YOU COULD-
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES ONE MORE
TIME- MODERATOR I WOULD
APPRECIATED. AND ONCE AGAIN ON
THE PHONE IF YOU WERE IN FAVOR
OF SB NINE FORTY THREE. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO COULD BE CUED
UP. THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WE
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TWO OR THREE. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
NUYS AS BE NINE FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY BE THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FORTY
THREE WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
AND THOSE THAT AREN'T
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OF SB
pTHEN ZERO TO BE CUED UP AT THIS
TIME. SB JUST A BRIEF MOMENT
THANK YOU.
AND WHILE WE'RE
WAITING ANYBODY ELSE THAT IS IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DID NOT
GET A RESPONSE FROM MINE A TWO
SEVENTY VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU IT. DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YES
SENATOR MITCHELL. YOUR FIRST OF
ALL I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL I
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD I WOULD. I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DID ACKNOWLEDGE THE
YEARS OF WORK AROUND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE THAT OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAVE
BROUGHT FORWARD SENATOR JACKSON
HERE. A FORMER SENATOR- SHE
LOOK KEWL AND I WOULD AGUE
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS CALL THE CRISIS-
ANY FAMILY. EXPERIENCING A
SERIOUS ILLNESS- AWE AND HAVING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY MANAGE
TAKING CARE OF A SICK. PARTNER
OR SPOUSE OR CHILD- BEAT
COLBERT ARE OR OR OTHERWISE-
CERTAINLY IN MY HUMBLE OPINION
HAVE DESERVED WHICH IS WHY I
HAVE ALWAYS SUPPORTED PAID
FAMILY LEAVE. AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT FOR AND
I HOPE. PERHAPS A MORE MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE EVEN DURING
THIS TIME OF CALL THAT COULD
FIND THEMSELVES TO UNDERSTAND
THE VALUE OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
I KNOW IT'S NOT BEEN SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN SUPPORTED
UNIVERSALLY FOR MANY YEARS- SO
PERHAPS WITH YOUR BILL- CENTER
CHIANG AND THE CURRENT CRISIS
WE'RE EXPERIENCING. MORE PEOPLE
WILL BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF Y. AID FAMILY LEAVE
IS APPROPRIATE. JUST WANT TO
ADD ON WE ALL KNOW THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY TOUGH TIME FOR
FAMILIES STRUGGLING TO BALANCE
WORK. AND FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES AND TEACH
THEIR CHILDREN. ARE AMONG THE
OTHER. DUTIES THAT THEY HAVE
DURING THIS. VERY VERY
CHALLENGING AND FRANKLY SCARY
TIME FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE AND I
AM ALSO DELIGHTED. TO HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES NOW THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE JOIN US THIS IS
BEEN. A BATTLE I HAVE. ENGAGED
IN FOR MANY MANY YEARS- TO TRY
TO READ IT'S HAVE PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT- THIS IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY HAVING
PAID FAMILY LEAVE SO WE CAN
CARE FOR OUR FAMILIES- FOR
PARENTS AND GRAND CHILDREN WHEN
THAT ARISES. BUT YOU KNOW THAT
WAGE REPLACEMENT WITHOUT JOB
PROTECTION BEHIND IT CREATES.
CHALLENGES WERE A WORKER COULD
LITERALLY BE FIRED FOR USING
THE BENEFITS SO. WITH THIS
WOULD- WOULD DEFINITELY I THINK
WE HAVE TO ADD THAT OTHER
ELEMENT AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MY COLLEAGUES ON. THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE ALSO WILL-
SUPPORT UNIVERSAL JOB PROTECT
PROTECTION. A PARTICULARLY IS-
WAS PROPOSED ACTUALLY TODAY BY
THE GOVERNOR AND HIS MAY REVISE
SO- I DO SHARE. AN APPRECIATION
THAT. THAT THIS BILL IS NOW
COMING FORWARD- IT IS LONG
OVERDUE I'M SO SORRY THAT IT
TOOK THIS CRISIS TO GET IT ON
THE FRONT BURNER AND TO GET.
OTHER SUPPORT HOPEFULLY OF A BI
PARTISAN. FOR THIS ISSUE SO
THANK YOU SENATOR SURE THAT
CONCERN AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL. IN BUT YOU
CENTER TRANSFERRING THE BILL
FOR I WANT TO THE FIRST
KNOWLEDGE LEAVE OF THE WHEN HIS
**** AND MOVING HELPING ME
BASICALLY LEADING THE IN THIS
POLICY AS A FATHER I WANNA SAY
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING I THINK
UNIVERSE AND AGAIN THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A VERY POLICY FOR
FAMILY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MUCH AS AN PAN OTHER COMMON
SURE QUESTIONS. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE SENATOR. YES I REALLY
A COMMENTS FROM MY SKIN
COLLEAGUES AND I ALSO A- IF NOT
THAT THIS HAS BEEN. A LONG
COMING. AND BLOCKED WORK FROM
THE WHEN CAUCUS AND I JUST
WANNA. YOU KNOW. I'M ON TO BE
TO. THIS. THANK YOU VERY FOR I
VOTE IN AYE AYE IT'S A DISTRO
WONDERFUL BUILDING. MEASURE IN
I. IT'LL PROVIDE TO TREMENDOUS
FOR LOW OF FAN WHO WISH FOR THE
CARE THAT. FOR THE CHILDREN AND
ADDS AT THIS. THERE'S BEEN NO
QUESTION ABOUT THE NEED. AND
RECORD. OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT. FOR AND I. YOU YOU AND
YOUR STAFF. WITH FUTURE. TO
COME TO. A AGREEMENT ON THE
AMEND THAT IT SOME OF THE AND
CAN. WITH X. LAW. WITH A YOU
VERY MUCH. TO HAVE A WE HAD
HAVE A- FROM SENATOR MAY. AND
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL'S THE
BOTH IS TO PAY. AS AMENDED TO.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AFTER. MEMBERS PLEASE STERN
MARKER. AND TO THE- CENTER HILL
HI HILL I CENTER MORALE. SAN
MORALE HI SAN JACKSON HI ENERGY
HI SENATOR MITCH HI THERE
MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN. CENTER
PAYER HI. FIVE VOTE THE BILL IS
OUT CONGRATULATIONS AND YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WARNER TO SB NINE SEVEN THREE
SO JACK. YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL TO GET RIGHT THERE WOULD
YOU LIKE ME HAVE A THIS THAT
WAY RIGHT. SEEING THIS BILL A
COUPLE TIMES BEFORE- IT SEEKS
TO CLOSE THE PAY GAP. LET ME
SAY UP FRONT THAT I BELIEVE
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR WAGE
EQUALITY. AS WOMEN BEAR THE
SIGNIFICANT BURDEN OF JOB LOSS
IN UNPAID CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES- DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. THIS EASURE IS A
BILL TO FIGHT PAY
DISCRIMINATION WITH DATA WITH
INFORMATION. BECAUSE IT CUT
WHEN IT COMES TO PAY EQUITY FOR
WOMEN AND MINORITIES WE CAN'T
FIX WHAT WE CAN'T SEE. AND WE
CAN'T FIX WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS OF A HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES OR MORE TO SUBMIT A
PAY DATA REPORT ANNUALLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. OUTLINING THE
COMPENSATION AND HOURS WORKED
OF EMPLOYEES BY GENDER RACE
ETHNICITY AND JOB CATEGORY IT
WILL ALSO STRENGTHEN
ENFORCEMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR PAY ACT. BY ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING TO ALSO ENFORCE
THAT ACT IN COORDINATION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT. OF THE
PRIMARY GOALS OF SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE OR TWO FULL.
FIRST TO ENCOURAGE EMPLOYERS TO
ANALYZE THEIR OWN PAY HIRING
AND PROMOTION PRACTICES AND
ALLOW FOR SELF CORRECTION.
EXCUSE ME PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO JOB SEGREGATION IN
OTHER WORDS TO TAKE THE DATA
AND LOOK IN THE MIRROR TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE ARE
POLICIES THEY'RE HIRING AND
PROMOTIONAL POLICIES ARE
DISCRIMINATORY NOT NECESSARILY
INTENTIONALLY SOUL BUT CHURCH
THE REALITIES OF WHAT GOES ON
IN THE WORKPLACE. AND THE BILL
WILL ALSO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
TOGETHER IMPORTANT DATA THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO SEE PATTERNS OF
WAGE DISPARITIES IN IF THEY
NOTICED THOSE DEVIATIONS OR OUT
LIARS TO INVESTIGATE FURTHER.
THE INFORMATION WILL ALSO BE
AVAILABLE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT IF
THEY REQUESTED. THIS BILL IS
CLOSELY MODELED AFTER EFFORTS
THAT WERE STARTED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL- BUT HAVE SADLY A
BEEN HALTED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION MAKING IT MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THE
CALIFORNIA PURSUE ITS OWN PATH
FOR PAY DATA COLLECTION. TO
COMBAT GENDER AND RACE BASED
DISCRIMINATION. AND IN CASE YOU
MIGHT BE IN DOUBT ABOUT THE
VALUE WERE IMPACT OF THIS DATA
I WILL POINT YOU TO THE CASE OF
INTEL WHICH LATE LAST YEAR
VOLUNTARILY RELEASED THIS DATA
PUBLICLY. THE NUMBERS TRUE
HEADLINE TO IMPROVE PROMPTED
SOUL SEARCHING IN THE COMPANY
AND CALLS FOR CHANGE. THE DATA
REVEALED THAT FORTY ONE OF
FIFTY TWO TOP EXECUTIVES MAKING
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR WERE
MEN. AND THIRTY SEVEN OF THOSE
TOP EXECUTIVES WERE WHITE. AN
ANALYSIS BY BLOOMBERG NEWS
WHICH FIRST REPORTED THE DATA
FOUND ONE IN FOUR WHITE MEN AT
INTEL WERE IN TOP SALARY BANDS.
WHILE LESS THAN 10% OF BLACK
EMPLOYEES WERE TOP EARNERS. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO- BASED
UPON SOME OF THE MISINFORMATION
OUT THERE TO KNOW WHAT THIS
BILL IS NOT. THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT PUBLIC EXPOSURE OF FOR
SHAMING. THIS MEASURE WILL NOT
EXPOSE INFORMATION THAT IS
INDIVIDUALLY IDENTIFIABLE BY
BUSINESSES NOR WILL IT IT
EXPOSED EMPLOYEES PRIVATE
FINANCIAL INFORMATION TO THE
PUBLIC. I'VE EVEN TAKEN THE
UNUSUAL STEP OF PROHIBITING A
PUBLIC RECORD ACT DISCLOSURE.
THE LIMITING A PUBLIC
AVAILABILITY OF THE REPORT. IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT OCCURS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WITH THE EO ONE
FORM WHERE THEY'VE HAD NO
ISSUES WHATSOEVER WITH UNTOWARD
DISCLOSURE OF THIS DATA IN THE
FIFTY PLUS YEARS. SINCE THAT
FORM HAS BEEN REQUIRED SO THIS
DATA WHAT IT WILL DO IS PROVIDE
A BIRD'S-EYE VIEW ON PAY
DISPARITIES AN OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION. BUT NOT IN A
GRANULAR SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL
WAY THE INFORMATION IN THIS
REPORT IS NOT ALSO INTENDED TO
WIN THAT CONSTITUTE DIRECT
EVIDENCE OF A VIOLATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA. FAIR PAY ACT WE ARE
NOT GOING TO TAKE JOE WHO IS IN
JOB A AND COMPARE JOE TO. JANE
WHO IS IN JOB BE WHAT THIS DOES
IS IT GOES TO THE TOP LINES TO
THE BANDS OF EMPLOYMENT. IN A
COMPANY AND BY WHAT IT WILL DO.
IS IT WILL IDENTIFY. EXACTLY
WHAT. CRITERIA AND
CLASSIFICATIONS THERE ARE IN A
COMPANY AND HOPEFULLY WITH THAT
MIRROR BEING PUT IN THE FACE OF
THE EMPLOYER THE EMPLOYER WILL
RECOGNIZE. WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ARE IN FACT DISCRIMINATING AND
I WOULD SUBMIT THAT PROBABLY
MOST OF IT IS IMPLICIT BIAS NOT
INTENTIONAL BUT BIASED NONE THE
LESS THAT AFFECTS JOB
DISCRIMINATION. BY HAVE JESSICA
STAND WITH EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WHO WILL JOIN US
REMOTELY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND I BELIEVE- WE
ASKED- JENNIFER TO BE OUR ONE
SPOKESPERSON SO THAT SHE CAN
SPEAK FOR THREE MINUTES ON THIS
BILL. BURGER THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON YES- JESSICA'S TENDER
IS- ON THE LINE AND- WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO HER TESTIMONY.
THREE MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHEN NUMBER MY NAME IS
JESSICA STANDARD AND I'M SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR WORKPLACE JUSTICE
THE PUBLIC POLICY AT THE RIGHT
ADVOCATES WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORED SB NINE SEVEN THREE.
WE NEED TO ENSURE EQUAL PAYMENT
NOW MORE CLEAR APPARENT THAN
EVER DURING THIS CURRENT HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC CRISIS. WHICH IS
EXPOSED THE LASTING HARM OF
UNEQUAL PAY ON WOMEN AND
PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF COLOR.
WOMEN AND WORKERS OF COLOR MAKE
A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
FRONTLINE ESSENTIAL WORKERS AN
EXISTING INEQUALITIES SUCH AS
PAY INEQUITY ARE BEING REVEALED
AND EXACERBATED AT THIS TIME. A
DATA COLLECTION AS CONTEMPLATED
UNDER SB NINE SEVEN THREE WILL
HELP TO UNCOVER P.
DISCRIMINATION WHICH IS A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE OVERALL
GENERATE THE WAGE GAP. AND IT
COLLECTIVELY COST CALIFORNIA
WOMEN OVER SEVENTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR. IT
ALSO PROMOTES EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF OUR STATE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION AND EQUAL PAY
LAWS AS WELL VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE BY EMPLOYERS WITH
THE LAW. I WANT TO KNOW THE
EXTENT STUDY AN ANALYSIS THAT
WENT INTO THE FEDERAL PD
REPORTING RULE ON WHICH TO BEAT
BILL GATES. YOUR GEN FIVE YEARS
OF EVALUATION INCLUDING TWO
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIODS
CONSULTATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND EXPERTS AND A PILOT STUDY
TO IDENTIFY THE MOST EFFECTIVE
FORM OF DATA. AND THE LEAST
BURDENSOME METHOD OF COLLECTION
FOR EMPLOYERS YEAH THE EO ONE
FORM THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE TO
SUBMIT INFORMATION ON. ONE
OBSTACLE TO EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE EQUAL PAY
PROTECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA IS
THAT PEOPLE PAY IS OFTEN HIDDEN
FROM SIGHT. AND IT CAN BE THE
RESULT OF UNCONSCIOUS BIASES AS
WELL AS HISTORICAL INEQUITIES.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS EMPLOYERS
THEMSELVES ESPECIALLY IN LARGER
COMPANIES MAY NOT EVEN BE AWARE
OF GENDER OR RACIAL PAID IT'S
VERY BIG THIS WITH. OUR COMPANY.
PROCESS AND COLLECTING DATA
WILL HELP EMPLOYERS. AND PEOPLE
SENATOR JACK THEN. IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL WAY DISPARITIES AND
PROMPT THEM TO INVESTIGATE
FURTHER TO DETERMINE WHETHER
EMPLOYEES WERE PERFORMING
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR WORK ARE
IN FACT BEING PT COOLEY WHICH
THEY MAY BE- AND IF NOT MAKE
CHANGES ARE WHERE WE'VE SEEN
THAT HAPPEN PUBLICLY. FOR
INSTANCE GOING TO KEEP THE BILL
COURSE. AWARE OF ANY OCT
CORRECTED ME QUESTION TO
INCREASE STRUCTURE. I MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE RIVER GENDER
AND RACIAL WAGE GAP IS THE
PHENOMENON OF OCCUPATIONAL
SEGREGATION. WHERE BY WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY CONCENTRATED
IN LOWER PAYING JOB. BOTH
WITHIN COMPANIES AS WELL AS
ACROSS INDUSTRIES AND ONE
CONTRIBUTOR TO THAT IS
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS SO AS YOU
HEARD A LOT OF EMPLOYERS MIGHT
NOT EVEN BE AWARE OF THESE
TRENDS. OFFICE IN COLLECTING
OUR OWN KEY DATA WILL HELP THEM
IDENTIFY PATTERNS AND
POTENTIALLY CHANGE THEIR
RECRUITMENT HIRING AND
PROMOTION PRACTICES TO ENSURE.
EQUAL REPRESENTATION AT ALL LET
ME DOUBLE DROP THEIR COMPANY
AND WE SEE MANY BUSINESSES
VOLUNTARILY DO THAT. HE DID A
QUOTE HIM ALSO PROMOTE
EFFICIENT USE OF LIMITED
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES BY OUR
STATE ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BY
ALLOWINGTHEM TO IDENTIFY
PATTERNS BASED ON RACE GENDER
ETHNICITY WITHIN A COMPANY OR
ACROSS INDUSTRIES. WHICH WILL
THEN HELP THEM TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT AL LIARS DETERMINE IF
THERE ARE ANY VIOLATIONS OF OUR
EQUAL PAY FOR ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS. THE SECOND
COMPONENT OF THIS BILL ALLOWING
THAT YES EACH ONE FOURTH EQUAL
PAY ACT IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING
THERE IS ADEQUATE ENFORCEMENT
OF THIS IMPORTANT LAW. WORKERS
WHO EXPERIENCE DISCRIMINATION
BASED ON GENDER RACE OR
ETHNICITY I HAVE TO CANCEL
CLAIMS UNDER BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA FAIR PAY ACT. AS
WELL AS THE PARENT WHEN HOUSING
ACT THE HOUSE IS WITHIN ALREADY
IMPORT BUT AT THE AT THE AGE.
THIRTY IN ROOM TWO HUNDRED
EXTRAS AND EVEN RESPOND TO A
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINT BY
BILL UNDER BOTH BOND WILL
ENSURE MORE EFFICIENT USE OF
RESOURCES THANK YOU MISTER
UNDER YOU READY. THREE THE
GOVERNMENT ENFORCEMENT. EVEN
WOULD URGE ARE I AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU MISTER
UNDER APPRECIATE THAT. RE MUCH
KNOWLEDGE WITH ANY PUBLIC. HERE
IN ROOM FOR TWO THREE IS OR
ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVENTY
THREE. SEEING NO ONE- IS FOR
ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC FROM THE
PUBLIC. WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE SEVENTY THREE SHEEN
NO ONE. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WARNING TO TESTIFY BE
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE SEVEN THREE. AND WE
ASK THAT YOU GIVE YOUR NAME
AND- AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. THANK YOU AND
MAY LINE TWO SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MICHAEL YOUNG CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE TO SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE OTHER WITH THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY.
LINE ONE SIXTEEN A LINE OF
THIRTY. RELIGIOSITY W. AFTER
THEY'D COME APART THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHECK IT
TURN ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PART. THANK YOU. NINE TO EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI JANNA
GARY FROM LEGAL AID AT WORK IN
PART. THANK YOU. MINE TO
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS MERRY GO YOSHI
HARLOT THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THE
CELL THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE A. ONE
MOMENT EVAN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI EVAN MEN CAN LOOKS FOR
PROGRESS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MINE TO EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KEVIN ENESCO FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MINE TO
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MILEY THE GAL REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT.
FIND ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MARGARET
DIRECTLY I REPRESENT A STRONGER
CALIFORNIA AND THEY COULD NOT
WORK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CELL THANK YOU. AND ONE MORE
MOMENT. ONLINE TO EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LIE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS WERE NAY
BY ARTUR WITH AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THEY'RE NOT FOR THEIR LINES IN
THE QUEUE YOUR MODERATOR COULD
YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN JUST TO BE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
SUPPORT WITNESSES ON MY FEET.
NINE SEVENTY THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO VOTE
IN SUPPORT OF MINE SB EIGHT
NINE SEVEN EIGHT THREE. PRESS
ONE ZERO TO BE CUED UP. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR AND HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION. LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. AND YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS BUT HAVING
COME OUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
UNFORTUNATELY I RESPECTFULLY
POSTED THIS BILL ONCE AGAIN-
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OBVIOUSLY
DOES NOT SUPPORT- GENDER OR ANY
OTHER PAY INEQUITY IN FACT-
CHAMBER WAS PROUD TO WORK WITH
SENATOR JACKSON ON HER LANDMARK
BILL FROM A T. FEW YEARS AGO SB
THREE FIFTY EIGHT WE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED THAT BILL. UP TO
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S EQUAL
PAY ACT- WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL WE'VE DISCUSSED AND
PREVIOUSLY OVER THE YEARS I'M
NOT GOING TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME OUR CONCERN HAS TO DO
PRIMARILY WITH THE FACT. THAT
WE BELIEVE- THIS REPORTING OF
INFORMATION TO ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY CREATES A AN IMPRESSION.
OF UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION WHEN
NINE MAY IN FACT EXIST EXIST
THERE ARE. MANY LEGITIMATE
REASONS TO HAVE DIFFERENCES IN
PAY- BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT
INDIVIDUALS EVEN INDIVIDUALS
WITH SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
POSITIONS BASED ON EDUCATION
AND EXPERIENCE- WE THINK. WE
ARE CONCERNED PRESIDING THAT
INFORMATION TO AN ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY LEAVES THE IMPRESSION
WITH THAT THERE'S
DISCRIMINATION WHEN. IT MAY NOT
IN FACT EXIST I DO WANT TO
COMMENT VERY BRIEFLY ON WHAT'S
NEW IN THIS BILL WHICH IS THE
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. TO
ENFORCE THE EQUAL PAY ACT- WE
SPOKE INTO THE AUTHORS OFFICE
ABOUT OUR CONCERNS IN THIS
REGARD. ANYTIME YOU HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES AND
FORCING THE STAIN BODY OF LAW
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT.
A FUSION DIFFERING
INTERPRETATIONS. WE APPRECIATE
THE LANGUAGE SENATOR PUT IN THE
BILL TO SAY THAT ONLY ONE
AGENCY WILL INVESTIGATE THE
SAME SET OF FACTS. I WERE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TALKING TO THE
SENATOR AND HER STAFF ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS- BUT THAT'S OUR
CONCERN WHEN YOU HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES AND
FORCING THE SAME LAW. WE RAISE
THIS ISSUE IN RECENT YEARS-
WITH DIFFERENT PROPOSALS TO
ALLOW THE LABOR COMMISSIONER TO
IT FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT LAW-
IN ADDITION TO DTH AND WE EVERY
SIMILAR CONCERNS WE HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES AND
FORCING THE SAME BODY OF LAW
THAT IT CREATES CONFUSION. AND
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATIONS SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR- ON THOSE CONCERNS
WITH THE ENFORCEMENT PIECE-
BUT- UNFORTUNATELY WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY. ANYONE ELSE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB. NINE
SEVENTY THREE SEE NO ONE- ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
NINE SEVENTY THREE. SEEING NO
ONE THERE THANK YOU. AND NOW WE
WILL GO TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE THEN WE WILL
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF THE SB NINE SEVENTY THREE.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO HAVE THE LINE
OF. ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MIND IS AN
AFTERNOON YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLE
RIGHT CALIFORNIA MANY FACTORS
CAN TECHNOLOGIES SENSATION ALSO
BECAUSE FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI WOULD YOU FEEL IF THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND TO THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
THE USE OF THE CALIFORNIA WE
GET THE PRODUCERS REPRESENTING
THE PROCESSING ACROSS THE STATE
IN OPPOSITION THREE EIGHT EIGHT
THANK YOU SH THANK YOU. ONE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS BILL MCMILLAN WITH
ACCLAMATION INSURANCE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AND ALLIED
MANAGED CARE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE OF FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE NINE ONE OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ONE LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THE WEAKENED STATED
BY MISTER REDDICK THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MATTHEW OUTLOOK
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE TO OUR RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO THE- THANK YOU. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NOW ANYWAY THAT'S WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN Q.
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE
SURE WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
HAVE ANY. COMMON TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVENTY
THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU TO ALL THE
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE WILL NOWBRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
SENATOR PENN. THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK A CENTER JACKSON
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL BACK
AGAIN AND I WAS PROUD TO VOTE
FOR IT BEFORE- DIED TODAY I DO
I JUST ACKNOWLEDGED- THE
OPPOSITION'S TESTIMONY ABOUT
DEAL ENFORCEMENT I'M SURE SAID
JACKSON WORK ON THAT BUT- I DID
FIND A LITTLE STRANGE TO SAY
THAT. REPORTING THIS DATA WHICH
TO SLOW WOULD REQUIRE EVERY
EMPLOYER. WOULD THEN TRIGGER
SOMETHING IN RELATION TO THE
AGENCY RATE RECOGNIZING ISN'T
IT AND FOR SOME AGENCY BUT YET
ACTUALLY- SINCE EVERYONE'S
REQUIRED TO REPORT A I I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE STIGMA IS FOR
REPORTING TO START WITH. SINCE
IT IS SOMETHING THAT- WOULD BE
HELPFUL BUT WITH THAT- I AM
COURAGE AUTHORED CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION WHICH
I KNOW SHE WILL- AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO MOVE TO BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
SIR YES. CENTER TOMORROW MY
SHARE. THANK SENATOR. YEAH I'M
NOT GONNA BE ABLE SUPPORT THIS
TODAY BECAUSE I AM CONCERNED DO
STUDENT. THE CHALLENGING
ECONOMIC TIMES THAT WE HAVE.
HERE THIS IS ANOTHER LAYER OF
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY- FOR
BUSINESSES. IN AND I JUST THINK
IT'S GOING TO OPEN UP A WHOLE
LOT OF- UNJUST LAWSUITS AND-
IT'S WERE PYLON. MANY
DIFFICULTIES AND MORE
REGULATORY BURDENS UPON OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH ARE
ALREADY. IF NOT LEAVE IN THE
STATE- MANY DOORS HAVE CLOTHES
AND WILL CONTINUE TO CLOSE THIS
IS AN INAPPROPRIATE- BILL BUT
MORE SO I THINK THE TIMING ON
THIS IS REALLY BAD SO NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR
MORRELL SENATOR JACKSON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU IN
RESPONSE TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
ASPECT THIS IS FOR COMPANIES OF
A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES ARE MORE-
THEY HAVE TO FILL OUT AND HAVE
BEEN FOR THE LAST FIFTY YEARS
IN THE YEAR ONE FORM. THIS JUST
ADDS ANOTHER. ASPECT TO IT TAT
THAT ASK COMPANIES TO LOOK IN
THE MIRROR AND SEE WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'RE VIOLATING THE LAW
BY DISCRIMINATING- AND- IT
DOESN'T A SANCTION THEM- IF
THEY DISCOVER THAT IN FACT
THERE ARE THERE ARE. HUGE
DISPARITIES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED THE HOPE IS THAT THEY
WILL ADDRESS THEM AND- THAT IS
THE INTENT OF THIS. LEGISLATION
I HAVE CERTAINLY. WORKED WITH
THE- THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
OPPOSITION AND I THINK WE'VE
GOT A- A YOU KNOW I'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE INFORMATION
CONFIDENTIAL FOR EXAMPLE- THERE
ARE I THINK- YOU KNOW GOOD
REASONS. TO ASSIST THESE
COMPANIES IN COMPLYING WITH
WHAT IS ALREADY THE LAW AND IS
MENTIONED. I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY TIMES I HAVE TO SAY IT.
THIS IS THE THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT LEVEL WE'RE PUTTING IT
INTO BANDS THIS IS NOT WHAT
THEY MAY SAY DE AGGREGATING
INFORMATION WE'RE NOT GOING TO
COMPARE IT. JODY CHAIN IN A
BAND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
TO SEE WHETHER THESE BANDS THE
HIGHER ECHELONS THE LOWER
ECHELONS. DO IN FACT
DISCRIMINATE. ON THE BASIS OF
GENDER RACE AND ETHNICITY- SO
WITH THAT- THERE ARE- EIGHT YOU
KNOW I THINK THE CONCERNS ARE.
INACCURATE ARM AND I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TALK FURTHER
AND TO CLARIFY WHY I BELIEVE
HAVING BOTH AGENCIES IS NOT TO
PLEA COULD HAVE- THAT THAT THEY
ARE THE GOAL IS TO HAVE THEM
WORK. SEAMLESSLY TOGETHER AND
IF WE NEED TO. TWEAK THE
LEGISLATION TO ARTICULATE THAT
I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO DO THAT
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK THE
RIFLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE ON THIS
ISSUE I MEAN TO GET TO THE- THE
ISSUE IN THE COMMITMENT OF
ENSURING EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL
WORK IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THE NEW
HAVE I KNOW FOR MANY YEARS AND
IT WILL MAKE IT MUCH EASIER TO
IDENTIFY THAT GENDER BASED. HEY
DISCREPANCIES THAT WE'VE SEEN
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR PAN- THE MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PLEASE TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONES TO VOTE.
SENATOR HILL HI. UNDER HILL HI
CENTER MOREAU WHO CENTER MORALE
NO CENTER JACKSON HI INNER
JACKSON HI CENTER MITCHELL HI
CENTER MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN
ALL RIGHT. UNDER PAN HI THAT
HAS FOR US IN ONE OF THE BILL
IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO. SENATOR MORE LUXURY SB
NINE NINETY AND JUST AS A TIME
CHECK WE- COMMENCEMENT. WE'VE A
WORK THROUGH FOR BILLS AND WE
HAVE NINE LEFT. CENTER MORE
LIKE WELCOME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT. CENTER BILL SB NINE
NINETY I THINK YOU'RE
CONVENIENCE OLOGY AND CHANGES
AND WATCHING EVERYONE WITH.
FACE MASKS AND EYE GLASSES I AM
GIVING THEM FOGGED UP AND ARE
BOUNCING AROUND BY TAKE ONE-
ONE OR THE OTHER OFF YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND. COLLEAGUES A SB
NINE NINETY IS A SIMPLE BILL.
IT WOULD SUSPEND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB FIVE UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO SO. YOU'VE ALREADY HAD A
PRESENTATION ON TO THIS BILL
EARLIER SAUL TRIED KEEP THIS
BRIEF. WHY SHOULD WE DELAY AB
FIVE. THE DYNAMICS DECISION BY
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
WAS. IN MY OPINION- NOT GOOD
INCOME TAX POLICY OF THE BOAT
BRILLO DECISION WAS
SATISFACTORY. ADOPTING THE
DECISION IN PART AND NOT IN THE
HOLE. WAS ALSO BAD INCOME TAX
POLICY CARVE OUTS SHOWED
PARTIALITY. AB FIVE PENALTY
PROVISIONS FOR CERTIFIED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTANTS ENROLLED AGENTS AND
CORPORATE TAX ATTORNEYS. ARE
TOO ONEROUS CIVIL PENALTIES OF
500-021-5000 DOLLARS PER
VIOLATION IN ADDITION TO OTHER
PENALTIES HAS GOTTEN THE
PROFESSIONAL TAX PREPARATION
INDUSTRY A FLUTTER. INDUSTRIES
NOT CARVED OUT REFLECTED A FORM
OF ARBITRARINESS SUPPORT
FAVORITISM TO THOSE SELECTED.
MANY INNOCENT AND LAW ABIDING
CALIFORNIA FREELANCERS WHO
ANGLER RECEIVED FORMS TEN
NINETY NINE AM I HAVE SEE. LOS
THEIR CONTRACTS ONE PUBLISHER
IN MY DISTRICT WHO. PAYS BASED
ON THE AMOUNT OF BOOKS THAT ARE
SOLD WAS TOLD THAT AUTHORS NOW
WERE EMPLOYEES AND HAD TO BE
COMPENSATED DIFFERENTLY AND
SUBSEQUENTLY THEY'VE LEFT MY
DISTRICT AND MOVED TO THE STATE
OF ARIZONA. INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WERE IMPACTED
FINANCIALLY EVEN BEFORE THE
CORONA VIRUS DEPRESSION CAME ON.
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION LIKE A
HEART ATTACK. DURING THE
LOCKDOWN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WERE PREVENTED FROM
PERFORMING THEIR CUSTOMARY
SERVICES WHILE SHELTERING IN
PLACE. IN THEIR HOMES WHERE
MANY HAVE BEEN WORKING
TRADITIONALLY FOR DECADES. AB
FIVE SAID THAT GIG ECONOMY
PARTICIPANTS WERE NOT WELCOME
TO THE STATE. WHERE MAYBE TO
GET GET KHANOM EVEN STARTED.
AND THE CORONAVIRUS DEPRESSION
HAS CLEARLY SHOWN THAT CERTAIN
PLATFORMS ARE NOT SUITED FOR AN
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER RELATIONSHIP.
WHEN UBER AND LIFT- CAME ABOUT
THE THEY WERE THEY WERE
BASICALLY THEY ARE BASICALLY
MATCHMAKERS PAIRING UP
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD TIME AND A
CERTIFIED SAFE VEHICLE WITH
OTHERS NEEDING TO RUN AN ERRAND
OR MEET UP WITH SOMEONE AT AN
EVENT. AND BEING PAID A MODEST
FEE. THEY PROVIDED AN OUTCOME
BUT NEVER UNDER THE CONTROL OF
AN EMPLOYER. BUT THE MESSAGES
BEEN RECEIVED AS REFERRED THIS
WEEK. THERE'S A PERCEPTION AND
IT BECOMES REALITY AND IT
APPEARS TO MANY THAT SACRAMENTO
IS ANTI BUSINESS ANTI
ENTREPRENEUR ANTI PART TIME. IN
THAT WERE ATTACKING RESIDENTS
WHO WERE TRYING TO EARN A
LITTLE EXTRA INCOME IN ORDER TO
MAKE ENDS MEET PAY THE RENT OR
HAVE ENOUGH FUNDS TO TAKE A
VACATION. AND I KNOW WE'VE ALL
RECEIVED PLENTY OF PHONE CALLS
AND LETTERS AND EMAILS. ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. BUT THE
MESSAGE CAME AT THE WRONG TIME
CALIFORNIANS IT NEEDS SOME
RELIEF. CONSEQUENTLY LET'S HOLD
OFF ON IMPLEMENTING AB FIVE
UNTIL EVERYONE GETS THROUGH
THIS COVERT NINETEEN EPISODE
AND THE RESULTING DEPRESSION.
CENTER JACKSON SAID IT REALLY
WELL LET'S TRY TO FIND THE
SWEET SPOT. LET'S SHOW THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT WE
HEARD THERE PLEASE AND
EMPATHIZE WITH THEIR PLIGHT.
AND IN THE INTERIM LET'S
PERFORM SOME BETTER SCHOLARSHIP
ON HOW TO DETERMINE. WHO IS A
COMMON LAMPLEY. AND WHO IS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. THE
STANDARD SHOULD APPLY TO ALL AS
IT HAS FOR DECADES UNDER THE
INTRO REVENUE SERVICES RULES
AND SCRUTINY. THERE IS A
CRITERIA ME I WRESTLE MAKE SURE
YOU'RE AN EMPLOYEE IF YOU ARE
AN EMPLOYEE BECAUSE THEY WANT
THE FIGHT TO WITH HELD. ME WITH
THE PAYROLL TAXES JUST AS MUCH
AS THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD DOES.
LET'S PUT THE CPA'S IN THE
EMERALD AGENTS IN THE TAX
ATTORNEYS TO THE TASK. WAS
ASKED BY DEL WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA TAX PUBLISHER- THAT
THE- THIRTY YEARS AGO I WENT TO
THEIR ANNUAL CONFERENCE ON.
CALIFORNIA INCOME TAX LET'S PUT
THEM TO THE TASK LET'S FIX THIS
BLOODY BE FIVE. AND PUT. IT ON
THE PAUSE BUTTON. AND MAKE IT
FAIR AND EQUITABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IT'S THEIR WORK
PRODUCT THAT GENERATES THE
INCOME THAT PAYS ARE. ROLL
CHECKS WE SHOULD BE MORE
SENSITIVE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
SO COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON SB NINE
NINETY. THANK YOU SENATOR MORE
LOCK. IS THERE ANYONE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB NINE
NINETY I NOTICED THAT THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED. IS THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF FORTY TWO OR THREE
BEING THAT- BRIEF SIR. THE
CHURCH MUCH APPRECIATED. IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY TWO ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINETY SEE
NO ONE THERE. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY
BE THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
NINE NINETY WE WILL BEGIN. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
SB NINE NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. IF YOU COULD.
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SUPPORT. SB NINE NINETY IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB
NINE NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORTERS AND NOW WE
WILL FOLLOW THE SAME ROCESS
FOR. TO HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION TO LET'S BEGIN WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE ANYONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION. SHEEN AND
HEARING NO ONE MOVING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE NINETY. THANK YOU SEE NO
ONE THERE IS WELL WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES. I'M SORRY.
SO NOW MOVES TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AS BEING NINE
NINETY MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE NINETY WE
WILL BEGIN. YES IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE NINETY.
WE DO HAVE A THE LINE OF NUMBER
ONE FORTY NINE ONE IS OPEN.
MAYBE RELY ON ME. HI MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION- WE'RE CLOSE SB NINE
NINETY THE ABC TESTING DYNAMICS
AND EIGHTY FIVE PROVIDE A WORK
PROTECTIONS FOR MILLIONS OF
WORKERS THAT- PREVIOUSLY HAD NO
ACTED UPON BY MINIMUM WAGE
WORKERS COMPENSATION
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
OTHER SOCIAL PROGRAMS AND WORK
PROTECTION HE CALLED THE
NINETEEN CRIED. HAS EXPOSED THE
NEED FOR AN HOUR LINE'S GOING
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS TIMES
NEED WORKERS CANNOT WE TWO
YEARS BEFORE THEY ACCESS OR
BEFORE THEY CAN GET ACCESS.
PROTECTION THE CRITTER PROBE
INITIALLY HAVE TO. CALIFORNIA
THE CAR CAN'T TWO YEARS LOCAL
RECORD COVER EMPLOYER TAX
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM COMPANIES.
ADDITIONAL UNITS CLASS BY
WORKERS IT'S NOT A GOOD
EMPLOYERS THAT PETER CARE
SHARE- BUT ARE FORCED TO
COMPETE ON A FAIR PLAYING FIELD
AND IT'S NOT FAIR TO CALIBRATE
TAXPAYERS. ADDITIONALLY THE
STATUE LIMITATION. IN YOUR
EIGHTY FIVE AND DYNAMIC REPEAL
AT HOLES IN SB NINE NINETY
FURTHER HURTING VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS AT A TIME
THEY CAN BE DEPORTED FOR THESE
REASONS WERE GONNA CALL ME
FIRST. WHAT. THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
MOTOR THANK YOU IN LINE TO
NINETY TWO NINE ZERO ZERO ONE
IS OPEN. SANDRA BARRERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. THE
LOCATION OF HOPE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO NINE
FIVE. AB ALIGN THE MUTE. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENT A GREATER CALIFORNIA
LIVERY ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S SIX THOUSAND
LIMOUSINE OPERATORS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU TO COOK. LINE ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
FIVE ONE. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE AND THE UNITED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO SEVEN
SEVEN. MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE.
LINE TWO SEVENTY SEVEN. WE DO
HAVE LINE TO NINETY THREE LINE
TWO NINE THREE THE LINE IS OPEN.
AT THE DEFENDER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE SEVEN SIX. RICHARD MEMBERS
TRISTEN BROWN OF CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE TWO
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU RENE
PARTNER WITH THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA ALSO OPPOSE THANK
YOU. LINE TWO EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JACKSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. IN LINE
ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL IF YOU AT
THE W. ACTORS DATE COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. OKAY ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE SOMEONE ELSE.
SHIP. LIKE MODERATE TO HAVE
ANOTHER CALL NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS WHAT
IS YOUR YEAH YEAH YEAH WITH THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. AT OUR LAST ONE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
THE LNE ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. YES IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. BUT WE DO HAVE THE
LINE TO SEVENTY SEVEN ONE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT.
WE'LL COME BACK TO ONE
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN LINE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE
WILL HEADLINE TO NINETY SEVEN
WANTED OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JACKIE TURN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER TRADE THE CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
CUED UP. COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'VE COVERED ALL OF
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. THAT'S ONE ZERO. IN
NO ONE HAS TO LOOK AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHEN I
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS VICE CHAIR MORAL. THIS
TIME I'D LIKE. THIS TIME I'D
LIKE TO BELIEVE VERY GOOD FOR I
WILL RECOGNIZE YOU AT THE
PROPER TIME ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR THOUGHTS OF SENATE YES.
THANK YOU- CENTER MORE LIKE FOR
YOUR BILL- GREATLY APPRECIATE
THAT BECAUSE- YEAH I JUST LIKE
TO KNOW FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
TRYING TO GET- TEMPERATURE
READINGS FROM DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE. BUT COULD YOU
JUST SHARE BRIEFLY HOW UC THIS-BILL- NEGATIVELY. AFFECTING
OUR- ORANGE COUNTY ECONOMIC
IMPACT TO IT. WELL I DON'T KNOW
CENTER MORALE OF MANY PHONE
CALLS AND- COMMUNICATIONS YOU
RECEIVE BUT AFTER SESSION MAYBE
FIVE WAS CERTAINLY. A HIGH UP
THE LAST PROBABLY AT THE
HIGHEST IN A CONTINUES TO GET-
LOTS OF MEDIA ATTENTION AND-
BLOOD TO LETTERS TO THE EDITOR
IN FACT THE LOCAL PAPER THE
ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER THE-
IMPACT ENDORSED SB NINE NINETY
AS- A SOLUTION TO TRY AND- FIX
THIS IMBALANCE WE'VE WE'VE TOLD
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT. IN THEIR
LEGAL JUSTIFIABLE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACT RELATIONSHIPS- WERE
WERE NO LONGER AT THIS THIS
BILL CAST A WIDE NET AND CAUGHT
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN IT YOU KNOW
ALLOWING FREELANCE WRITERS
WANTED TO THIRTY FIVE ARTICLES-
IN A YEAR THAT CERTAINLY- WIPED
OUT A LOT OF. FREELANCERS AND
SO THE UNITED LIKE PARK TELL
STORIES FOR A LONG TIME BUT ALL
ALL JUST UP THERE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MERLE- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE HAPPY TO ADD WILL.
MISTER THANK YOU FOR HEARING
THE BILL I REALLY APPRECIATED
IT HAS BEEN- A MAJOR SOURCE OF
COMMUNICATIONS WITH MY DISTRICT
OFFICE AND SO. WE TRIED TO
REACT BUT- I TRIED I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR NOT JUST CALL
ME UP AND SAY AND FORGET IT.
IT'S OUR PRESHEAF THAT. THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ME IRAQ
SHOULD GO AFTER THE ABUSERS. WE
WERE VERY CAREFUL WHEN I
PRACTICE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
PAMELA BOYS WERE COMMON LAW
PLEASE AND IF YOU WERE GONNA GO
THE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR OUT
YOU HAD BETTER BE ABLE TO MEET
ALL THE FACTORS- SO THAT MY
CLIENTS WITH DOES NOT. HAVE AN
INTERESTING LETTER TO EXPLAIN
WHY THEY HAD TO PAY THREE YEARS
OF BACK PHICHIT TAXES BUT HAD
TO PAY BOTH THE EMPLOYEE AND
THE EMPLOYER PORTION AT 50%
TIMES THE AMOUNT PAID. THAT
COULD BE A PRETTY SIZEABLE.
BILL FOR A BUSINESS TO HAVE TO
TAKE ON. AND WHO WE SHOULD GO
AFTER THE VIOLATORS LIKE
DYNAMAX DYNAMICS WAS.
AGGRESSIVE TO THE MAX AND SO. I
REMEMBER UPSET THAT A COMPANY
WOULD GO AS FAR AS THEY DID IN
TRYING TO RECLASSIFY EMPLOYEES
TO INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. AND
MAYBE WE OUGHT TO FIND MORE
FUNDING SAID A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET TO
ENFORCE AB FIVE MEMBER ID GIVE
THAT MONEY THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. AND DEAL WITH THE
PERPETRATORS BETTER NOT PLAYING
BY THE RULES IN AND MAKING IT
UNFAIR FOR THOSE THAT ARE SO
WITH THAT I. MATURED A BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD. SUSPEND AB FIVE
FOR A TELL TELL JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TAKE A
HARDER LOOK ON WHAT'S FAIR FOR
EVERYBODY. THAT WERE THAT THAT
IT'S- HORIZONTAL NOT VERTICAL
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE INDEPENDENT. OR WHETHER
THERE ARE COMMON MOM PLAY IT
SHOULDN'T BE WHETHER YOU- WORK-
FOR TRAVEL AGENTS OR WHETHER
YOU DON'T. THAT'S BAD LAW AND
SO THEREFORE- I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON SENATE
BILL NINE NINETY THANK YOU
SENATOR MORE LUCK IN AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL- HERE LIKE YOU AND YOUR CO
AUTHORS- I WANT TO REVISIT AB
FIVE. THEY COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION THAT REALLY WORKS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND LIKE YOU I'M
VERY CONCERNED THAT THE CURRENT
VERSION OF LAW CREATES. MANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
NEED- I THINK IMMEDIATE REFORM
AND THAT'S WHY. UNFORTUNATELY I
WILL NOT. SUPPORTING THE BILL
OF THESE I THINK WE CAN DO SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
NECESSARY IMMEDIATELY AND TAKE
CARE OF THAT TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS OR- LOOKING TO THE
LEADERSHIP THIS IS THE
LEGISLATURE FOR LEADERSHIP AND
I THINK WE NEED TO RESPOND NOW
WITH MEANINGFUL REFORMS. AND I
DON'T THINK SO SPENDING AB FIVE
WHAT WILL GET US THERE SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT I HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK. TOGETHER ON
SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS AS WE GO
FORWARD TO IMPROVE AB FIVE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BRINGING FORWARD
SENATOR MORE LUCK AND WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FROM. SENATOR
MOREAU. OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS OF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTERS
PLEASE TURN YOUR MIKE ON TO
VOTE CENTER HELL NO. AND HILL
NO CENTER MORALE HI AND- MORALE
HI CENTER JACKSON NO. AND
JACKSON NO CENTER MITCHELL NOW.
THAT ARE MITCHELL KNOWN CENTER
PAN OUT. UNDER PAN NO. THANK
YOU THAT THE BILL HAS ONE NINE
FOUR KNOWS THAT THERE'S NOT A
PASSED OUT OF THE COMMITTEE BUT
WE WILL- GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION WITHOUT
OBJECTION THANK YOU MUCH CARE
THANK YOU POLITICS THANK YOU
MISTER. SENATOR MONEY NICE TO
USE IT IN THERE SB ELEVEN OO TO
PLEASE. COME FORWARD. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. HERE I
GO YOU JUST- CAN GO FROM THERE.
IN THE YOU MAY PRESENT AS BE
ELEVEN OH TWO AND THANK YOU FOR
A AGAIN YOUR PATIENCE TODAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
GOOD EVENING. LAST YEAR MORE
THAN TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
FOREIGN FARMWORKERS WERE
IMPORTED BY ROUGHLY ONE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA GROWERS AND FARM
LABOR CONTRACTORS UNDER THE AGE
TO A FEDERAL VISA PROGRAM. THIS
NUMBER HAS BEEN INCREASING
ANNUALLY. FOR THOSE OF YOU
UNFAMILIAR WITH H. TO A PROGRAM
IT HAS MANY OF THE SAME
PROVISIONS AND PROBLEMS AT THE
INFAMOUS FOR SERRA PROGRAM HAD.
WHICH WAS TERMINATED BECAUSE OF
SYSTEMIC LABOR HOUSING IN WAGE
ABUSES. THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION THE FEDERAL
MINISTRATION HAS MADE AN
EXCEPTION. TO ITS STRICT BORDER
CLOSURE POLICY. FOR H. TO A
WORKERS RECOGNIZING THAT THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS NOW
DURING THE COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS. H. TO A FARM WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA- ARE LARGELY
RECRUITED IN MEXICO ARE TIED TO
A SINGLE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYER
WHO MUST PROVIDE THEM WITH
HOUSING MEALS AND
TRANSPORTATION TO WORK SITES.
MANY H. TO A WORKERS HAVE NEVER
BEEN TO CALIFORNIA BEFORE AND
ARE BELIEVED TO NEITHER SPEAK
NOR READ ENGLISH. IF THEY'RE
FIRED FOR ANY REASON THEY'RE
SUBJECT TO IMMEDIATE
DEPORTATION WHICH IS A POWERFUL
POWERFUL DISINCENTIVE TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT ANY ABUSIVE
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS THEY MAY
BE SUBJECTED TO. THE
COMMITTEE'S BEEN PROVIDED
EVIDENCE OF CURRENT ABUSES IN
THIS PROGRAM. MANY OF THESE
ABUSES ARE ALSO VIOLATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA LOS WHICH EACH TO A
FARMWORKERS GENERALLY KNOW
NOTHING ABOUT. BECAUSE NEITHER
THE US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR NOR
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WHO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM REQUIRE WORKERS TO BE
TOLD OF THE SUBSTANTIAL BODY OF
CALIFORNIA LAWS THAT PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS GREATER THAN THE
FEDERAL H. TO A PROGRAM. SB
ELEVEN- TO FILL SAID
INFORMATION GAP BY REQUIRING
EACH TO EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE
EACH TO A FARMWORKERS ON THEIR
FIRST DAY OF WORK WITH A SHORT
COMPREHENSIVE WRITTEN SUMMARY
OF KEY LABOR HOUSING HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND OTHER CALIFORNIA
LAWS IN SPANISH AND IF
REQUESTED IN ENGLISH. THIS
WOULD INCLUDE NOTICE OF ANY
EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS INCLUDED
INCLUDING COVERT NINETEEN WILD
FIRE DANGER OR OTHER POTENTIAL
HEALTH RISKS. THE BILL DIRECTS
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER TO
DEVELOP A TEMPLATE CONTAINING
THIS SUMMARY INTO PROVIDED ON
THE WEBSITE FOR H. TO EMPLOYERS
TO USED TO COMPLY WITH THESE
NEW DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS.
RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE ADDED A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE DISCLOSURE
INCLUDE INFORMATION ABOUT
CURRENT STATE OR FEDERAL
DISASTER OR EMERGENCY
DECLARATIONS AND THAT AGE TO A
WORKERS ARE PROTECTED FROM
REALIATION FOR RAISING
QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE
DECLARATIONS REQUIREMENTS OR
RECOMMENDATIONS. SB ELEVEN- TO
CREATE A SAFER LEGALLY
COMPLIANT WORKPLACE FOR H. TO A
FARMWORKERS AND REDUCES ANY
INCENTIVE UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS MAY HAVE TO HIRE
WORKERS WHOM THEY CAN UNDER
PAYING IN MYSTERY BECAUSE THE
WORKERS DO NOT UNDERSTAND THEIR
RIGHTS OR HOW DO ENFORCEMENT.
TODAY MISTER CHAIR I HAVE WITH
ME- REMOTELY TO WITNESSES MARK
SCHACHT INSTANT THE ARISE BOTH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE TESTIMONY OF MARK
SHOPS FIRST AND THEN FOLLOWED
BY CYNTHIA RICE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MINE AND- I THINK THAT-
WE WILL MOVE NOW TO TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT- SO MARK SHOT IF YOU
ARE- YOU JUST CALLED IN I
UNDERSTAND AND SO YOU WILL
BEGIN. TO TESTIMONY PLEASE
PLEASE PRETTY. YEAH THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES FOR THE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. OF THAT SINCE YOU'RE
RIGHT WHY ARE GONNA DIVIDED IN
HALF- SB ELEVEN OH TWO
ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM OF TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF FOREIGN
CONTRACT FARMWORKERS ENTERING
CALIFORNIA UNDER FEDERAL JOB
ORDERS THAT OFTEN INCLUDE TERMS
AND CONDITIONS THAT ARE LEGAL
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW. WE KNOW
STATE AGENCY CHARGED WITH
PROVIDING BALL BALL WORKERS BUT
A COMPREHENSIVE SUMMARY OF THE
WHITE. ACTIONS UNDER STATE LAW
THIS BILL HAS BEEN DRAFTED WITH
THAT I'D TO PROVIDING EACH TO A
FARMWORKERS WITH USEFUL
INFORMATION THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
THE LAW REQUIRES THE BECAUSE-
THIS GOES SEVEN WRITING. FOR
EXAMPLE NO LAW REQUIRES STATES
TO A FARMWORKERS TO BE
INFORMED. THAT IF THEY'RE
INJURED ON THE JOB THEY MUST BE
GIVEN A WORKERS COMP CLAIMS
FORM WITHIN ONE DAY. FOR THEIR
AFFAIR REASONABLY SUSPECTED TO
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED PESTICIDES
THEY MUST BE GIVEN PROPER
APPLICATION TO A MEDICAL
FACILITY. OR THAT EVERY WORK
SITE. EVERY WORK SITE THEY
SHALL BE PROVIDED WITH TOILET
FACILITIES HAND WASHING
FACILITIES. AND COOL OF A WATER.
I'M THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
RICH WILL CRITIC DISCO. THAT
HAVE ELEVEN OH TWO. COULD BE
MADE TO EACH TO A FARMWORKERS.
NO OTHER LAW REQUIRES WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BACK AND
WE'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SHOT REVIEWED- MISS RICE. CINDY
RICE ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I
THINK SHE'S ON ANOTHER LINE.
SHE IS THERE SHE IS HELLO YES
PLEASE PROCEED MISS RICE. HELLO
YES HELLO CAN YOU HEAR IT I
THANK WE CAN HEAR YOU I CAN'T
HEAR YOU AND WE HEAR YOU SO
PLEASE BEGIN. WHAT QUALITY THAT
THEY CAN'T BUT I CAN'T THAT
THAT BY SPEAKING ABOUT HOLD HIM
MISTER YEAH RIGHT SELLS ME THAT
SHE- HERE- ARE YOU AT THIS
POINT. WILL WE HEAR HER. WE CAN
HEAR HER ISSUE IF YOU CAN START
SPEAKING WE WILL HEAR HER
TESTIMONY. OKAY I AM SPEAKING
NOW CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE HEAR
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APOLOGIZE GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS DERIVED NINE THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL GOING TO. PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES HELLO KITTY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THE FINANCE ON
PROVIDING LEGAL ASSISTANT THE
FINAL INCLUDING AGE TO OUR
WORKERS. MAY THIRTY ONE
CALIFORNIA IS INCREASING AND
HAD. ACCELERATED BECAUSE OF
NINETEEN. MANY IF NOT MOST OF
THE AGE TO A LOT OF US WHO ARE
COMING HERE YOU CAN TELL FROM
THE VERY FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA. GENERALLY AGE TO A
WIRELESS COME TO OUR OFFICE
BECAUSE THEY WERE TERMINATED
EARLY WHICH IS REALLY WHICH IS
APPARENT. FROM THE CONTRACT.
HOWEVER NEARLY EVERY CASE THAT
IS. ONE OF SEVERAL VIOLATIONS.
MOST OF WHICH THEY HAD NO
KNOWLEDGE OF ABOUT. AND ARE YOU
A CALIFORNIA LAW. TYPICALLY
THESE INCLUDE ON COM. HYNDE AND
WAITING THE BILL THE BEGIN WORK
I SPENT ON IN CONTROLLED. OKAY
TO PAY ALL THE TIME DELYLAH
MAILING. DEDUCTION THE COOL AND
SAFETY GEAR THE LACK OF SHADE
WATER IN LINE COMPLIANT WITH
OTHER HEALTH THANK YOU
CONNECTIONS AND HELPFUL
DOWNTURN ARE RAMPANT. THE
WORKERS WHO ARE COMING. ANDHOME THEY ILL OR A- AND ARE NOT
GETTING THE CARE USE QUICKLY
ONE CLAIM LONGER COMP. MY
EXPLAINS THE RIGHT. HI BOB
HUNTER AND EVEN OF DOLLARS OF
ON THE TURN OF THEIR CON AND
OFTEN DON'T EVEN KNOW IT. WE
COVERED MONEY FOR IF WE'RE
GOING FOR ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
BILL PROTECT AGE TO A WORKPLACE
BY ENSURING THAT THEY KNOW
THEIR RIGHTS. AND ALSO PROTECT
THE BURGLAR MIGHT HESITATE TO
DEMAND THEIR RIGHTS BECAUSE
THEY FEAR THEY WILL BE REQUIRED
FOR GOING. DON'T NOW- AND
THEREFORE CANNOT MAKE THOSE
FINANCE. I YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
IS RIGHT AND WE DID HEAR YOU
VERY WELL- SO NOW WE WILL BEGIN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IS THERE
ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY. SEEING AND
HEARING NO ONE WE WILL MOVE TO
ROOM FOUR AT TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE THERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN- TO. SEE NO ONE THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
ELEVEN OH TWO THEN WE WILL
BEGIN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF SB ELEVEN ALL TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO
NOW AND WOULD LIKE THE- THEM TO
GIVE THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
THANK YOU IN LINE TO SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE'RE BACK YOU CAN
BALLOT NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE OH ONE ONE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE ZERO ONE
AB ONE THE MUTE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RESPONSE
TO THE CLOSURE OF ANY AMERICAN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SEVENTY SIX THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE SEVEN
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
CHRISTIAN BROWNTO THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE TWO SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT. LINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD SEVENTY SIX. HI
THIS IS KAREN I'M FREE FROM
WORK STATE AND WE SUPPORTER AT
ELEVEN JAIL THANK YOU. LINE TWO
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD JOB ON
THE OUT THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
INTO COURT THANK YOU. THREE
ZERO FOUR YOUR. COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE HUNDRED
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AT THE TURN ON BEHALF OF
THE CREEK NUMBER TWENTY THAT
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR THE TESTIMONY. LINE ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL YOUNG
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME NO ONE ELSE IS Q.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
THE LINE ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR SB ELEVEN
ON TO. YES IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF SB ELEVEN ALL TO.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. SIX ONE
ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE THE ONE
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE ALIGNED
ON MUTE LINE TWO NINE THREE THE
LINE IS OPEN. I AM NOT HAVE
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO MORE IN Q. GOOD
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS TO HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS OUR PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ARE ON THE
PHONE OKAY VERY GOOD. AND WOULD
YOU HAVE NAMES FOR THEM OR.
GROWERS AS WELL ALL RIGHT WELL
WE WILL- THEN GO TO YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES WHO ARE ON
THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN OH TWO YOU WILL HAVE A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES. PLEASE
BEGIN. I DON'T I DON'T HAVE THE
NAMES DOWN HERE. MATTHEW ALLEN
ARE YOU THERE. MATTHEW ALAN.
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. COULD IT
POSSIBLY CALLED IN ON THE OTHER
LINE. THROUGH IS THE CHURCH
WHAT WE WILL GO TO THE REGULAR
A. WE WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES
TESTIFYING VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE AND WE CAN COME BACK IF
HE APPEARS IN THE BACK AND NOT
IN THAT CONFERENCE CALLS A
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP IDIVIDUALS WAITED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN OH TWO WE WILL BEGIN. IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB ELEVEN OH TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE THROUGH
THEIR OWN NOW. WE DO HAVE THE
LINE OF ONE ZERO FIVE THE LINES
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THIS IS BRIAN LITTLE
OF CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION- RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING YOUR OPPOSITION TO
SB ELEVEN OH TWO. THIS BILL IN
A TWO IS NOT NECESSARY BECAUSE
THE DISCLOSURES THAT REQUIRES A
LARGE WE ALREADY COVERED BY
OTHER CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES
THE SAME DISCLOSURES TO OTHER
OUR CULTURAL WORKERS. AS WELL
AS H. TO A PROGRAM LIKE
ELECTIONS REQUIRE THE
DISCLOSURE OF THE THINGS THAT
IS BELOW THE TWO WOULD REQUIRE
TWO. EIGHT H. TO A WORKERS WHEN
THEY COME IN THE COUNTRY ON THE
FIRST DY OF WORK- THERE ALSO
ARE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
WITH US BELOW THE NO TWO FOR
EXAMPLE. OF THE DISCLOSURE THAT
IT WOULD HAVE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER CLEAN UP WHAT FOR
AND REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO.
DISCLOSED WITH RESPECT TO THE
COMPATIBILITY OF TRANSPORTATION
TIME IF WE MISS STATE LAW THE
MOTION ALL TRANSPORTATION KILEY
COMPATIBLE IS NOT ACCURATE-
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COURT
CASES THAT ARE AND HAVE BEEN
PENDING IN RECENT YEARS. AND
THAT THE ISSUE IS- IS COMPLEX
SAY THE VERY LEAST. AND THEN
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
EMPLOYERS DISCLOSE BUT LAW
INCORRECTLY TO WORKERS WILL BE.
OF NO PARTICULAR USED ANYMORE.
OKAY WE CAN ARE WE WOULD
RESPECTFUL REQUEST OPPOSITION
TO THE- ELEVEN A TWO. OKAY YOU
FOR THE ARE. BY. THERE ARE
THERE ANY OTHER. YOUR
MICROPHONE CHEN. MAKE YOUR
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS. YES WE DO HAVE FROM
THE LINE OF A ONE SIX NINE OKAY
THE- IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
WITHOUT ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAYBE ALIGN THEM YOU.
ONE OF THE THINGS. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON MATTHEW WHILE
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
COLLEGE EYES FOR- THE PHONE
ISSUES- THIS EVENING WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT TODAY- WE REMAIN
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB
ELEVEN OH TWO BECAUSE IT
LARGELY REQUIRES CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS TO FURNISH A
DUPLICATE DUPLICATE AT SCHOOL
YOUR TWO WEEKS TO EMPLOYEES.
REGARDING EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW THE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT
PROPOSED BY THE BILL IS
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE TWO
EMPLOYEES ARE ALREADY AFFORDED
THE SAME RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS
UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL LAW AND
DOMESTIC. AT WILL EAT. FAST
EIGHT EMPLOY ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE THEM FROM I WITHIN EACH
CLICK ON ITSELF. OR BY OTHER
NOTIFICATION. UNDER CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW. THEY ARE DEPORTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT EMPLOYERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A TO
EMPLOYEES WITH THEIR BRITAIN
TOPIC AT EACH DELAY. A CONTRACT
BY THE FIRST DAY OF WORK IN
THEIR NATIVE LANGUAGE THAT'S
CURRENT LAW AND THAT INCLUDES
THINGS LIKE RATE OF PAY. OVER
TIME. PATIENT ARE ALSO
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NEED FOR
THE EMPLOYER TO PROVIDE HOUSING
FREE OF CHARGE AND WHEN THEY
CANNOT COMMUTE HOME ON A DAILY
BASIS. BUT ALTERNATE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE NEW PROVISION THAT
WAS RECENTLY ADDED TO THE BILL
THAT WOULD REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE THE EMPLOYEES WITH
ADDITIONAL SPECIFIED
INFORMATION DURING OUR STATE.
OR FEDERAL EMERGENCY- WE OF
COURSE PRIOR TO EMPLOYEE HEALTH
AND SAFETY. AND TO THAT END WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TO ENSURE
THOSE BEST PRACTICES AND SAFETY
MECHANISMS FRONT TIRE
WORKFORCE. HOWEVER WE ARE.
CONCERNED THAT AN EMPLOYER
INADVERTENTLY LEAVING SOMETHING
OUT OF THIS NEWLY PROPOSED
NOTIFICATION WILL CREATE
POTENTIAL LIABILITY. IT IS FOR
THESE REASONS AMONG OTHERS THAT
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE. DEATH
THANK YOU THANK YOU DROUGHT ONE.
AND WE DO HAVE LINE TO NINETY
EIGHT NINE TWO NINE EIGHT. ONE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD EVENING- CHURN MEMBERS ARE
THIS IS BY COMO OR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLIND
YOUR GROWERS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED. I WANT TO
JUST MAKE THE COMMITTEE AWARE
THAT WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS. YOU
COULD POTENTIALLY BE GOING BACK
TO OLD ALL DECLARATIONS YOU'RE
STILL IN FACT PRINCES LOTS OF
TWO FIRES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN. MANY OF THOSE
STONE FFECT PROPRIETY OF
REASONS AND WHICH STOPPED IT
JUST DOES NECESSARY ARE
PROVIDES NO SERVICES WHATSOEVER
TO EMPLOYEES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YEAH NO ABOUT YOU'VE
EXCEEDED THE TIME THE THREE
MINUTES ON OPPOSITION SO. NEXT
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS
TIME THERE IS NO ONE ELSE Q.
THANK YOU MODERATE OR CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE ME. THE KID WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
ONE MORE TIME. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB ONE ONE
ZERO TWO. ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO.
IN THERE YOU KNOW WANTING TO AT
THE MOMENT THANK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR APPRECIATE
THAT AND- DO WE WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS AND I WANT TO THANK THE
OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT
WITNESSES FOR THAT- OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE- MEDIA SENATOR
PAM. THANK YOU SIR MINING- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD THE
OPPOSITION HAS MADE MENTION
ABOUT DUPLICATION- BUT ALSO THE
SAME TIME CONCERNED THAT
LIABILITY BECAUSE ONE MIGHT
LEAVE SOMETHING OUT FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE YOU
CAN CLARIFY- A DOCUMENT THAT
MEETS ALL THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS BILL WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
BE DEVELOPED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSION OR- THAT THEN COULD
BE THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYER WOULD HAVE MET ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS. BILL IN
TERMS OF THE DISCLOSURES THAT
NEED TO BE MADE IS THAT CORRECT
ARE DRIED IT IS CORRECT AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
INCLUDING THAT ONE SO GOING TO
THE BACK END- NO PENALTIES THE
CREW THERE'S A RIGHT TO GET IT
RIGHT- IF THERE'S A FAILURE TO
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
NOTIFICATIONS IT DOESN'T
IMMEDIATELY RESULT IN A FINE
AND IF AFTER THIRTY DAYS IT
HASN'T BEEN CURED. THEN NO
MATTER HOW MANY WORKERS ARE
AFFECTED THE FIRST FINE IS ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IT'S NOMINAL
BUT LET ME ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
OF DUPLICATION BECAUSE THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE OPPOSITION
STRONGEST ARGUMENT AND THAT'S
WHERE WE DON'T SEE EYE TO EYE
ON THIS FEDERAL LAW FOR EXAMPLE
SAYS. IN H. TO A GUEST WORKER
CANNOT HAVE GUESTS AT WHERE
THEY'RE BEING HOUSED CALIFORNIA
LAUNDER CALIFORNIA TENANT LAW.
EXPLICITLY IN BY COURT DECISION
RECOGNIZES THE RIGHT OF THE
FARM WORKER TO HAVE GUESTS INTO
THEIR HOME EVEN IF THE
PROPERTIES OWNED BY BY A GROWER
THEY ARE THE TENANT. THEY'RE
PROTECTED BY CALIFORNIA LAW
THAT'S ONE AREA. WHERE WE HAVE
A DISTINCTION WITH FEDERAL LAW
THE FEDERAL EACH TO ANY
WARNINGS TALK ABOUT THE RIGHT
TO OVERTIME PAY. CALIFORNIA
REQUIRES NOT JUST YOU'RE
ENTITLED TO OVERTIME PAY BUT
HOW THAT WOULD WORK HOW WOULD
BE CALCULATED AFTER EIGHT AND A
HALF HOURS AND WHAT THAT RATE
WOULD BE. AFTER A FORTY HOUR
WEEK OF TIME AND A HALF.
SPECIFYING THE RATE THEY ALSO
TAKE EXCEPTION TO THE ISSUE ON
THE DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY.
THAT SOMETHING I THINK WE CAN
CERTAINLY WORK OUT THE INTENT.
IS TO GIVE A GUEST WORKER
NOTICE OF ANY DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY THAT IS REAL AND
PRESENT IN COULD AFFECT THEIR
HEALTH AND SAFETY. CODE
NINETEEN BEING A PRIME EXAMPLE.
WILD FIRES BURNING IN AN AREA
WHERE THERE'S AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTION COULD AFFECT AIR
QUALITY- PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONS- A LEAVE THAT ONE
OFF THE TABLE BECAUSE THAT
WOULDN'T BE A DECLARATION OF A
STATE OF EMERGENCY BUT- FIRES
COVERT NINETEEN. SO WE'VE HAD
THIS GROUP OF WORKERS DECLARED
ESSENTIAL. AND I WILL SAY MANY
GROWERS HAVE TAKEN
EXTRAORDINARY STEPS TO PROVIDE
P. P. IAN DISTANCING ETCETERA
IT CAME A LITTLE LATE IN MY
VIEW AND NOW IN OUR DISTRICT.
THAT I REPRESENT 80% OF ALL
COVERT NINETEEN POSITIVE TESTS
ARE IN TWO ZIP CODES IN
SALINAS. POPULATED PRIMARILY BY
FARMWORKERS SO. IT'S A HUGE
PROBLEM AND IF YOU'RE BEING
ASKED TO WORK IN A RISKY
ENVIRONMENT YOU SHOULD
MINIMALLY HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
MADE AWARE OF THAT AND MAKE A
CHOICE FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
IF YOU WANT TO ASSUME THAT
RISK. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IT GOES BEYOND FEDERAL
PROTECTIONS BUT WE WOULD ALLOW.
THE DELIVERY OF THAT NOTICE TO
BE BLENDED IN OTHER WORDS IT
COULD BE A SINGLE DOCUMENT.
OKAY SO THAT'S A EXTREMELY
HELPFUL I THAT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'LL BE WORKING AT THE
OPPOSITION TO CLARIFY SOME OF
THESE ISSUES LIKE EMERGENCIES-AND SO FORTH- BUTTON IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT I THINK WORKERS KNOW
WHAT THE RATES ARE AND THAT
THEY'RE DISCLOSED TO THEM. UP
FRONT- SO THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH AND I'D BE HAPPY TO PLEASE
ENTER PAN I DO WANT TO GO BACK
SLIGHTLY BECAUSE WE DID GO FROM
THE TESTIMONY AND STAY IN
OPPOSITION. TO THAN TO THE
PHONE AND DID NOT ADDRESS ANY
TESTIMONY PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT
WERE IN THIS ROOM OR IN TWENTY
FORTY SHOWS OR ANYONE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN TO. GIVE ALL AGES MISTER
CHAIR BENEFIT COME AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION JUST VERY BRIEFLY
WANTED TO POINT OUT THIS BILL
ALSO REQUIRES EVERY EMPLOYER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO THE
WAGE THEFT PREVENTION ACT TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE NOTICE
REGARDING THAT NATURAL
EMERGENCIES AND WE DON'T THINK
THAT'S NECESSARILY NECESSARY
FOR EVERY EMPLOYER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DO THAT IF THE
CONCERN IS ABOUT EACH TO A
WORKERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE WISHING TO SPEAK.
TO THIS ITEM- MOVING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN
OH TWO IN TWENTY FORTY SEEN NO
ONE READ IT BACK NOW FOR THE
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM. THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR PAN-
SENATOR MONEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- I THINK THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR NEAR STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS- AND AGAIN
THIS IS. PROTECTING THE RIGHTS
OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO IN
SOME SECTORS ARE CONSIDERED
ESSENTIAL BUT EXPENDABLE WE
THANK THEY'RE ESSENTIAL AND
SHOULD BE PUT. THIS IS A MINOR
STEP OF. SHARED RESPONSIBILITY
I URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR MINE AND APPRECIATE
YOUR WORKING WITH OUR STAFF AND
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ON THE AMENDMENTS- IN THIS
REPORT. BILL IS. NEEDED AND
IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE. AND THAT
THE NEEDED INFORMATION WITHOUT
BEING A IT'S NOT A MAJOR BURDEN
TO EMPLOYERS I DON'T BELIEVE IN
AND IT CAN BE ADDED TO EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS. THAT ANY
CHALLENGER PROBLEMS WITH THANK
YOU. FOR THAT AND THANK YOU FOR
SPONSORS AS WELL IN THAT SO WE
HAD TO HAVE A MOTION FROM OF
THE CENTRE PAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS PLEASE TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE IN ORDER TO
VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR HILL HI.
SENATOR HILL HI SENATOR MOREAU
NO. SENATOR MORALE NO SENATOR
JACKSON HI. SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR MITCHELL HI. SENATOR
MITCHELL HI SENATOR PAN. UNDER
PAN HI THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES
IT IS OUT THANK YOU SENATOR
MONEY. VERY MUCH AND I'M SORRY
BUT WE CAN'T GO OUT OF ORDER
TODAY. FOR THE BILL I APOLOGIZE
I DID CHECK WHILE YOU WERE
STANDING THERE ARE HOPING THAT
IT WOULD BE A DIFFERENT OUTCOME
BUT BECAUSE OF THE WITNESSES IN
THE TIMING AND THE TELEPHONES
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE I
UNDERSTAND. AND TO QUOTE.
SOMEONE WHO I WON'T NAME I'LL
BE BACK. MOVING THE HOW DO
SENATE BILL ELEVEN OH THREE
SENATOR HER TADO WELCOME. WE'VE
HEARD THAT BEFORE HAVE. WELCOME
SENATOR DAUGHTER IT'S NICE TO
SEE YOU THEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TODAY YOU MAY PRESENT BILL-
THIS BE ELEVEN OH THREE. WELL
GOOD EVENING AT THANK YOU AND-
I YOU KNOW I REALLY WANT TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS REFLECTED
ON PAGE FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS. A
MANY OF YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES THAT PEOPLE
OF MY SENATE-DISTRICT HAVE
FACED OVER THE YEARS. AND MANY
OF YOU ALSO KNOW ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES THAT PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FIFTEEN DUE TO COORDINATE. TO
DISCOVER NINETEEN INDUCED
DEPRESSION. IF THERE IS ONE
THING BUT I HATE POVERTY IS IT.
I HAVE LIVED THROUGH IT AND WE
HAVE WITNESSED IT WAY TOO OFTEN.
I HAVE WITNESSED HELP QUICKLY
FAMILY CAN GO FROM. THE MIDDLE
CLASS TO BEING HOMELESS. MY
FAMILY LIKE MANY OTHERS CAME TO
THIS GREAT NATION AND THIS
GREAT STATE SEARCHING FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM. THE MAN THE
AMERICAN DREAM OR MORE
SPECIFICALLY WHAT I LIKE TO
REFER TO AS THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM. NEEDS TO BE AVAILABLE TO
ALL WALKS OF LIFE. IT SHOULD
NOT DISCRIMINATE DISCRIMINATE
IN ANYWAY. AND I AM HERE TODAY
TO INTRODUCE A BILL WITH THE
FRAMEWORK THAT ONCE HELPED MY
FAMILY MOVE OUT OF POVERTY AND
I KNOW THAT IT WILL DO THE
SAME. FOR ALL THOSE THAT NEED
AND DESIRE IT. SB ELEVEN ZERO
THREE. IS A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CHANCELLOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO SUPPORT LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS COMPLETE WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE BOARD TO
DEVELOP ADDITIONAL EMPLOYMENT
PARTNERSHIPS TO ADDRESS
DISPLACEMENT OF WORKERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY INCLUDING
FARMWORKERS. DISCONNECTED YOUTH
AND YOUTH AT RISK OF
DISCONNECTION FROM EMPLOYMENT.
DURING THIS TIME IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE PRO ACTIVELY ADDRESS
UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. WITH
REAL UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR WORKFORCE
INCLUSIVITY OF ALL. WE LEARNED
FROM OUR LAST RECESSION THAT
MULTIPLE COMMUNITIES ARE THE
FIRST TO BECOME UNEMPLOYED. FOR
EXAMPLE YOUNG ADULTS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY ECONOMICALLY
IMPACTED BY THE GREAT RECESSION
DUETO THEIR LACK OF WORK
EXPERIENCE AND LOWER LEVEL OF
SKILL ATTAINMENT. AND IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AUTOMATION
CONTINUES TO DISPLACE KEY
WORKFORCE POPULATIONS LIKE
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS ALSO HAVE A
PROVEN IMPACT ON IMPROVING
UPWARD MOBILITY AND ALSO
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY WHEN
THEY BECOME ADULTS. IN NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE LIFTING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCED UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
REPORTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
THAT THEIR PRIORITY
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO FUND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS. TO COMPLETE
HIGH SKILL AND OCCASIONAL JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS. HOWEVER
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE ROLE
CENTRAL VALLEY. MANY
PARTICIPANTS ARE NOT ABLE TO
COMPLETE THE JOB TRAINING
PROGRAM DUE TO A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE TRANSPORTATION OR
DUE TO A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
CHILD CARE. THIS BILL AROSE
FROM CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD
WITH SINGLE MOTHERS AND
FAMILIES FROM ACROSS THE STATE
STRUGGLING TO PURCHASE BASIC
NEEDS LIKE BABY FORMULA. FOR
THEIR INFANT CHILDREN. A CHILD
A STORY THAT IS TOO FAMILIAR IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. OR FROM A
CONVERSATION THAT I HD
RECENTLY AT THE BEGINNING OF
YEAR WITH FARMWORKERS ON THE
BERRY YEARS WITHIN OUR OWN
SYSTEM TO KEEP THEM FROM UPWARD
MOBILITY OPPORTUNITIES. AND I
HAVE THREE WITNESSES TODAY
JOINING US REMOTELY BETTER CARE
TO ALSO TESTIFY. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE CONWAY COLLIS WITH THE
GRACE INSTITUTE AND ALL MY A
FARM WORKER- FROM MY HOME TOWN
OF THE CITY OF SINGER. THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR CHILDREN I
THINK WE HAVE- CON WE CALL THIS
IS THE ONLY PERSON ON THE LINE
AT THIS POINT OKAY. BUT WE WILL
WAIT AND WE WILL ALLOW THREE
MINUTES FOR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT FROM YOUR WITNESSES.
SELECT A COLLEGE FOR YOU THERE
THANK. I AM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
PROVEN IMPACT BUT BUT THE PLAIN
FACT IS. PEOPLE CAN ONLY
COMPLETE AND WHEN THEY GOT
RELIABLE ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
TO TRANSPORTATION STABLE
HOUSING THAT THAT'S BOTH
OBVIOUS BUT IT'S ALSO BACKED UP
BY VERY COMPELLING DATA. THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT THE LACK OF
THIS BASIC SUPPORT IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF LOW INCOME
PARTICIPANTS IN TRAINING
PROGRAMS DROPPING OUT IT'S NOT
A LACK OF COMMITMENT OF ABILITY
IT'S A LACK OF VERY BASIC
SUPPORT. THE NEED FOR THIS
LEGISLATION WAS BROUGHT TO THE
STATE CHILD AND FAMILY POVERTY
TASK FORCE WHICH I CO CHAIRED.
BY THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD IT WAS PRESENTED AS THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT MEASURE
THAT WE COULD TAKE TO INCREASE
GRADUATION RATES OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA'S. IT HELPS ENSURE
THE DISCONNECTED. ADDITIONAL
AID YOU MARGINALIZE WORKERS
LIKE FARMWORKERS ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND BOTTOM LINE. SB ELEVEN
OH THREE HELPS TO PROVIDE A
PATHWAY TO LIVING WAGE JOBS IT
PROVIDES A ROUTE OUT OF POVERTY
FOR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND
IT'S A CRUCIAL PART. OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR ACOSTA. A NEW. NO WE HAVE
ALSO. HERNAN ON THE CALL I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY WOULD GET
ALME IS THERE AS WELL. THANK
YOU A LOT IS WILL BE JOINING ME
AND SHE WOULD FALL OFF OF HER
TESTIMONY I'M NOT CAN YOU
PLEASE. FOLLOW WHEN I STARTED.
GOOD ACTORS. WHEN I LOG.
REMEMBER THE COMMITTEE LEVEL
AND THEY THEN THAT'LL- THAT
MEANS THE ONLY THE CAT IN
O'CLOCK AMONG. NUMBER EIGHT THE
ANIMAL IN IT'S A BIT OF A
HUNDRED DAMP ANYTHING FOR.
JOINT STUDY UP A LOT FOR YANDLE
NOT THE BOY THAT IT IS A WANTED
THAT OKAY. BUT. IN OCTOBER AND-
THE SENATE BUT I LAUGH AND A
I THINK THERE. WHAT NOW PLAYING
YEAH DON'T KNOW THIS MIGHT FROM
THE FIVE ON PLANE NEED FOR.
WHAT I DON'T PRODUCT FROM. WHAT
IS IT EVEN IN THAT I THE BUT
THEN I SELECT ANOTHER WHAT I
ONLINE I COULD ACTUALLY YEAH.
THE MAN AND I BATTERY ON THE
ONE FROM A BALLOT. BUT I NAY
CANNOT ACT. IT'LL I WANT THEIR
HAVE BEEN MA'AM ALL NOT CREDIT
ON THE NOT BUT IT. THE END OF.
THE BLANKS YEAH. EXACTLY YEAH A
MONTH BY ACT. YEAH. A HOT WATER
ON IT. WHERE THIRTY LATE WAIT
ON THE RIGHT I DO THAT A LOT
THE FOR THE HOLIDAY PUMP I YES
WE DO THAT A FUNNY THAT IT BUT
I THINK WHAT I THE BILL HAS A
LEADER. SO PLEASE A PRETTY WITH
THE TRANSLATION. INTERPRET.
OKAY IT'S ON- THANK YOU A LOT
FOR SHARING YOUR TESTIMONY I
MEAN THE LINE ON THIS PROJECT
MONEY OF GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU CENTER HILL AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE. I
RECALL IT TODAY. MY NAME IS A
LOT MORE ANAL AND I AM A FORMER
COMPLAIN OR CALIFORNIA I AM
SUPPORTING AT. ELEVEN OO THREE
BECAUSE MANY OF US. HAVE WANTED
TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL BUT THE
LACK OF RESOURCES AND CHILD
CARE. MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT.
ALSO MANY FARMWORKERS LIVE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES WERE
TRANSPORTATION. EDUCATION
ESPECIALLY WHEN TAKING CLASSES
IN THE EVENING. IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO TAKE MY GLASSES
WHEN. YOU DON'T HAVE A
TRANSPORTATION ORDER RESOURCES.
RIGHT NOW I AM ENROLLED IN
ENGLISH LEARNING CLASS. WEEKLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND IT HAS
BEEN. DIFFICULT FOR THE REASONS
MENTIONED BUT I HOPE TO ONE DAY
IN ON A SPECIALIZED TRAINING
QUALIFICATION CAREER TRAP MORE
OPPORTUNITIES AND LIKE. IN MY
CASE I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
COURSES TO BECOMING MACHINE
OPERATOR. AND I KNOW THAT MANY-OF MY COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE TO
ENROLL IN OTHER. PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING AS WELL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A BETTER
FUTURE AND HELPING TO GET TO
THE LEVEL CHILD ALREADY IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE YOU WORKING
MINORITY BUT. IT'S ON ITS WORK
FORCE. ELEVEN OH THREE WILL
HELP FARMER DEVELOP THEIR
SKILLS ABILITY TO IMPROVE
QUALITY OF. AND THAT OF THAT.
THANK YOU FOR. ME TODAY. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BAR OF
ON THE- WE- AT. ELEVEN OF THE-
THANK YOU FOR MUCH AND- WILL
ALLOW OF TWENTY SECONDS FIRST
AREA IF SHE'S WITH. THE YES
HELLO YES HELLO WOULD YOU I
WILL GIVE YOU TO THIRD TWENTY
SECONDS PLEASE. OKAY HELLO MY
NAME IS JUST THE LAST FOUR
YEARS- TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OLD
AND I'M CURRENTLY AN ALL WHITE
THE YOUNG LADY HERE I AM WITH
YOU TODAY TO SHOW MY SUPPORT
FOR THE AT B. ONE ONE ZERO
THREE AND I'M I. BEGAN BOB.
WELL THE PROGRAM I EIGHT UTC
AND PC THREE THREE YEARS AGO-
LA TPC FINANCIAL THE GROUP
CALLED ON MY- PERFORMANCE MY
FINANCIAL AID WAS DELAYED
DURING THE- SEMESTER BECAUSE I
COULD ONLY WORK PART TIME. I
PER YOU MADE. IT THIS COST ME
TO TRANSFER THE PCT
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN I TOOK
CLASSES AWAY FROM FINISHED MY
SIGNIFICANT I STOPPED GOING
BECAUSE. OF THE TO OUR- I THANK
YOU VERY. THANK YOU FOR TESTING
TODAY. VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC. TESTIMONY HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE OF THREE.
SEEING NO ONE WE WILL NOW GO
TO- ROOM TWENTY FORTY WITH
ANYONE THERE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN OH THREE C. IN NO ONE
THERE- THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVES
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORANGE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
OH THREE WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB. ELEVEN OH THREE. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CAN WE ASK THAT YOU GIVE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE. AT
FIRST COMIC COMES FROM THE LINE
OF- TWO SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SECOND BALLOTS NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SPORT
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT QUESTION-
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE OF
TWO NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF THE NUMBER HAVE LEGAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. EVERY TO SEPARATE MOMENT.
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE OF THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I. I'M SORRY COULD YOU
REPEAT THAT WE COULDN'T HEAR IT.
NATALIE KNOCKED ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION FOR.
I NEXT LINE COMES FROM EVAN
MIND TWENTY SEVEN. WHAT'S
PLACES HER PROGRESS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ARE THE NEXT
LINE IS NINE THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KEVIN AND GO
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WATER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
SO QUITE AND ALL DAY CONSORTIUM
AND STATE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA GOLD EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING GONNA COLIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. WE'RE
GOOD MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE ONCE AGAIN JUST
TO BE SURE THAT WE FOUND WHEN
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON SB ELEVEN OH THREE.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YU'RE IN SUPPORT OF LINE
I'M SORRY SB ELEVEN OH THREE.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME LEVEL THREE IS I THINK
THAT. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE ANYONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN OH
THREE SEEN NO ONE ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SB
ELEVEN OH THREE. SECOND NO ONE
THERE WISHING TO SPEAK- THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE TELECONFERENCE ERVAS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION. TO SB
ELEVEN OH THREE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN OH
THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE REQUESTED YOU
TO SIT STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIESAND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK ENOUGH. OF SB
ELEVEN ON THREE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE SUPPORT THE WITNESSES AND
ANYONE WHO WAS IN UP IN
OPPOSITION ONE OF BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE AREAS SENATOR
JACKSON'S ASIDE FOR A FIRST ONE
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS AND
ALWAYS LIKE TO HEAR FROM MY-
GOOD FRIEND CONWAY COLLEGE WHO
IS CLEARLY COMMITTED TO. GRETA
KIDDING POVERTY AND ALL THE
GOOD WORK THAT THAT THEY DO AND
I'M GLAD TO WORKING WITH THEM.
MY QUESTION THOUGH IS THIS
CALLS FOR A BELIEVE OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS- AS- DO I HAVE
THAT RIGHT OR WRONG. ON WHAT
THE- IT HAS A FINANCIAL ASPECT
TO IT IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN. AND
IF IT DOESN'T THEN THE QUESTION
IS WHERE IS THIS MONEY GOING TO
COME FROM TO DO THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE JUST HEARD THE
GOVERNOR TODAY TALK ABOUT.
ACTUALLY TAKING MONEY OUT OF
THE- WORKFORCE THE PROGRAM SO
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
WELL YOU KNOW MY THOUGHT THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION EIGHT AT
THERE IS SOME MONEY TIED TO
THIS PROGRAM AND- MY
UNDERSTANDING AT IN. IN THE MAY
REVISED THERE IS SOME MONEY FOR
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS-
DEAD DEAD DEAD APPEAR A NOW WE
HAVEN'T FULLY ANALYZED FEET BE
THE MAY REVISED- JUST YET BUT
I'D IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THERE IS SOME MONEY. IN THERE
FOR WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS.
I MAY BE WRONG PLEASE DON'T
QUOTE ME ON THAT YES IT DOES
SAY THE BILL IT SAYS THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE BOARD UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THAT PURPOSE.
TO MAKE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN GRANTS AVAILABLE TO
CONSORTIUM BAUBLE BAR SO- AGAIN
I'M JUST WONDERING HOW YOU'RE
FACTORING IN OUR CURRENT FISCAL
MASS TO. TO WHAT IS A GREAT
IDEA. YOU'RE HOPING TO BE ABLE
TO KIND OF CALL SOME FUNDS FROM
THE- WHY YOU KNOW I THINK THAT-
WE WILL MAKE A PUSH IN THE
BUDGET TO TRY TO PUT SOME FUNDS
TOWARDS US I THINK IT'S AN
INVESTMENT THAT IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED ESPECIALLY WITH. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE BEAN AT AT
THE NUMBER THAT IT IS THE
PERCENTAGE THAT IT IS AND ALSO
KNOWING THAT IT'S GOING TO
COULD POTENTIALLY GOING TO
GROW- AND WE I THINK THAT IF WE
REALLY ARE WORKING AT GETTING
PEOPLE BACK INTO WORK- WE NEED
TO MAKE AN INVESTMENT TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. BUY PROPECIA
THE EFFORT. TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK IS INTERJECTION AND THE
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS COME
INSURANCE SEEN NONE- SENATOR
HER DAUGHTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. AS I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I MEAN THIS IS A
WONDERFUL BILL AND IT'S JUST A-
I APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING IT.
FORWARD TODAY IN AND TO US
BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S A- IT'S A
NEED THAT'S GOING TO GROW AS WE
TRY TO RECOVER FROM CO IN
NINETEEN THERE'S O QUESTION
ABOUT IT I. AGREE WITH SENATOR
JACKSON'S THE CHALLENGE WILL
BE. THE FUNDING AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO WORK WITH A
WONDERFUL BUDGET CHAIR AND- THE
GOVERNOR TO COME TO A SOLUTION
TO THAT- AS WE MOVE FORWARD SO.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
JACKSON THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO
VOTE CENTER HILL HI. AND HILL.
HI CENTER MORALE. NO CENTER
MOREAU. NO CENTER JACKSON. I
ENTERED JACKSON. HI CENTER
MITCHELL. ALL RIGHT. THEN
MITCHELL. HI CENTER PAN HI. AND
PM HI THE BILL HAS FOR VOTE IT
IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS SENATOR.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE. HILL. I WILL
PRESENT THE BILL IN A- THANK
YOU SENATOR HILL. THESE SO THAT
PRESENT TO YOUR BILL SB ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE SAKE OF BREVITY I WILL
NOT BEGIN WITH A LONG
DISCUSSION OF COVERT NINETEEN
WE HAVE ALL LIVED IT AND ARE
CONTINUING TO LIVE IT. A REAL
WILL REITERATE A POINT FROM THE
ANALYSIS IN THE PAST IN THE
PAST THREE MONTHS MORE
AMERICANS HAVE DIED OF COVERT
NINETEEN THE DIED DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR AT WAR THAT LASTED
TWENTY YEARS WELL MUCH MEDIA
ATTENTION HAS BEEN ON THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES OF THIS
PANDEMIC THE SCALE OF HUMAN
SUFFERING IS UNPRECEDENTED. IT
REALLY DIFFICULT TO OVERSTATE.
THIS IS WHY I TEAMED UP WITH
THE- ASSEMBLY- MY ASSEMBLY
COUNTERPART ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM
DALY. TO AUTHOR A WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTION ON
COVERT NINETEEN THIS BILL WILL
EXTEND. THE CLOVER NINETEEN
REBUTTABLE CONSERVE PRESUMPTION
TO BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR WORKERS. WITHOUT
QUESTION THIS PRESUMPTION WILL
BE THE LARGEST AND MOST
EXPANSIVE PRESUMPTION IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YES WE NEED TO BE
SENSITIVE TO THE COST BORNE BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY MEDICAL CARE
TO OUR FRONTLINE WORKERS WHO
NEED IT MOST. THIS BILL IS VERY
MUCH A WORK IN PROGRESS. WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO HAMMER
OUT THE TECHNICAL ISSUES. AND
THAT THAT WILL INCLUDE WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNOR. AND
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS TO
CODIFY HIS RECENT EXECUTIVE
ORDER ONE BRIEF NOTE ON THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER IT WAS. AN
ENORMOUS STEP FORWARD. BUT IS
STILL JUST A STEP. THE ECO WHAT
ONLY BE IN PLACE UNTIL EARLY
JULY. AND COVERT NINETEEN WILL
BE WITH US MUCH BEYOND THAT
DATE. THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS. ME
TO WORK WITH TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
CREATE A PRESUMPTION THAT WILL
BE IN A LAW. AND SHEEP OUR
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC FOR THE REST OF THIS
YEAR. AND BEYOND. THEREFORE
NOTING THE URGENCY OF THE
MOMENT ON THE SCALE OF THE WORK
WE NEED TO ACCOMPLISH THAT AND
I WILL BE ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER KAY
THANK YOU CENTER HELL. I WILL
NOW MOVE TO- WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT- WOULD
ANY SPONSORED WITNESSES ANSWER
HELLO. NO NO OKAY. RIGHT SO
WILL THEN MOVE TO- WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT TO HEAR ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. OTHER WITNESS A
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
ST NINE ALEX MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ORDER ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. AND ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY. OKAY YES WE ARE
NOT HAVING AN IMAGE OF ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE A
CONFIRMATION THAT THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. OKAY
WHAT WE WILL DO IS WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR ROOM TWENTY FORTY
LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR- LINE- WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM. BUT
WE NOBODY THERE THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY OKAY SO WE
HAVE CONFIRMED THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY- WILL NOW
THEN MOVED O MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WANES TEST FIVE YOU TO
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY
NINE- PLEASE. OPEN THE LINES.
HERE AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND I WOULD ASK YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOUR POSITION THANK YOU. AND
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND IT'LL BE JUST A BRIEF
MOMENT. THANK. PINE TREE TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU NINE
THREE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NOW. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
OUR OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
BILL IS WITH CONCERNS BUT-
FORGETTING THEN THE CONCERNS
JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE INTENT OF THE BILL I
THINK WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE AS THE
AUTHORS THAT SOME SORT OF
REBUTTAL PRESUMPTION MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE. BUT WE DO HAVE
SOME PECIFIC CONCERNS WITH
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL ITSELF
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE
QUESTION OF A REBUTTABLE
WORKING THE CONCLUSIVE
PRESUMPTION. I DO BELIEVE THAT
A CONCLUSIVE PRESUMPTION WOULD
MAKE MORE SENSE TO HELP REDUCE
COSTS IN A WORKERS COMP SYSTEM
AND HELP SPEED UP MEDICAL
TREATMENT AND ACCESS TO AND
THEN THEY BENEFITS FOR WORKERS
WE- SHE WORKERS REALLY
STRUGGLING A WORKERS COMP
SYSTEM TO GET COVERED FOR-
OCCUPATIONAL DISEASE CLAIMS
THAT WE THINK GOING TO A
CONCLUSIVE PRESUMPTION WOULD
HELP DEAL WITH A LOT OF THOSE
DELAYS AND COST. AND ALSO JUST
WANTED TO RAISE THE ISSUE OF
THE DEFINITION OF CRITICAL
WORKER AS IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW
SPECIFICALLY THE PHRASING IT
ONLY APPLIES TO WORKERS
EMPLOYED TO COMBAT THE SPREAD
OF. NINETEEN I THINK THAT COULD
CREATE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AROUND WHO THIS ACTUALLY
APPLIES TO AND WE'VE HAD GREAT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE ON WAYS TO IMPROVE THAT
LOOK FOR THE KEEPING OF
CONVERSATIONS GOING- SO WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
BUT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
INTENT. TOTALLY AGREE THAT SOME
SORT OF A PRESUMPTION
BACKSTOPS. OKAY THANK YOU ALL
TAKE THAT'S A TWEENER COMMENT
ARE THERE OTHER PEOPLE OF
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY FURTHER. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY NINE. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR COMMON.
THANK. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE ARE
GOING TO THE COMMON THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR WE WILL THEN MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- THERE. WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION HERE
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. NOW
ARE YOU A TWEENER TO. OKAY ONCE
YOU GET WHILE WE TAKE THE
CLEANERS NOW THEN OKAY THANK
YOU I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST MY NAME'S JASON SMELTER
SHOW YOUR ENTRY SCHMELZER
LAYING IN HERE TODAY- ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION ON
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND SEE
SEC ACCESS INSURANCE AUTHORITY-
NOTING THAT THE BILL IS A WORK
IN PROGRESS I'M NOT GONNA SPEAK
TO THE ACTUAL CONTENTS OF THE
BILL RATHER I'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT A COUPLE OF BROAD
PRINCIPLES. OTHER WERE
CONTAINED IN THE LETTER THAT WE
SENT TO THE COMMITTEE AND WE
SENT A SIMILAR LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR AT FIRST I WOULD JUST
OBSERVE BROADLY- THAT THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM IS
A SYSTEM JUST LIKE ANY OTHER-
WHETHER WE'RE DEALING WITH MEDI
CAL OR TAX- TAX INCENTIVES
THERE'S ALWAYS A LINE RIGHT
THERE'S ALWAYS A LINE- BECAUSE
THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO
SERVICE VERY SPECIFIC PURPOSE
AND IN THIS. INSTANCE THE
SPECIFIC PURPOSE IS WORKPLACE
INJURIES AND ILLNESSES OKAY
SOON WERE HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT A PRESUMPTION OR WERE
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT
CHANGING KIND OF THE
EVIDENTIARY STANDARD FOR HOW
YOU ACCESS THAT SYSTEM WHAT
YOU'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT IS
WHAT FILTER YOU ARE YOU USING
TO EITHER ALLOW PEOPLE IN OR
KEEP THEM OUT AND IT'S JUST
THAT IT'S THAT SIMPLE SO AGAIN
WE WOULD WE WOULD BE VERY HARD
ON. THIS THE FILTERS SHOULD
KEEP OUT THE NON WORK RELATED
INJURIES SO ON A COUPLE OF
SPECIFIC ISSUES CONCLUSIVE
VERSES REBUTTABLE PASSED OF
PRESUMPTIONS A CONCLUSIVE
PRESUMPTION WOULD SAY
ESSENTIALLY ON EVEN IF I HAD
INFORMATION THAT DEMONSTRATED
WITH ABSOLUTE CLARITY THAT
YOU'RE COVERED NINETEEN FACTION
WAS NOT CONTRACTED IN THE
WORKPLACE BUT RATHER IT WAS
CONTRACTED SOMEWHERE ELSE THERE
IS EVIDENCE TO PROVE THAT. I
COULD NOT BRING THAT FORWARD AS
AN EMPLOYER TO REBUT YOUR
PRESUMPTION AND MOVE THAT
INFECTION OUT OF THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM MAYBE INTO
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM- THAT I
PROVIDE OR OR SOME OTHER SYSTEM
WE THINK THAT IS A FUNDAMENTAL
VIOLATION OF A HUNDRED YEARS OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION LAW- IT
NOT ONLY IN THE STATE BUT IN
THIS COUNTRY- IT WOULD BE A
GROSS VIOLATION OF WHAT THE
SYSTEM IS INTENDED TO DO- SO WE
OBVIOUSLY WOULD NOT. SUPPORT
THAT. WHAT MAKES A CLAY IS IN
AND- QUESTION SO DOESN'T
EXPOSURE OR A PERCEIVED
EXPOSURE- TO MAKE A CLAIM- WE
WOULD SUBMIT THAT IT DOES NOT-
DO YOU SHOULD HAVE TO HAVE A
POSITIVE TEST OR A PHYSICIAN'S
DIAGNOSIS- SIMILAR TO SOMETHING
THAT WAS IN THE AT THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER- BUT SOME LINE
THERE. A MERE EXPOSURE CAN BE
DEALT WITH THROUGH THE PAID
SICK LEAVE BENEFITS THAT WERE
PROVIDED ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
IN THE STATE LEVEL- AND SOME
OTHER THINGS SO WITH THAT
SHOULDN'T CONSTITUTE A CLAIM-
THERE'S BEEN CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT- EXTENDING STATUTORY
BENEFITS THERE ARE OTHER
MEASURES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
THAT DON'T STICK WITH THE
MEDICAL CARE INDEMNITY BENEFITS
AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
PROVIDED BY THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM BUT THEY
TRY TO EXPAND IT TO HOUSING AND
LIVING EXPENSES AND EVERY.
OTHER THINGS I WE OBVIOUSLY
WOULD NOT TO SUPPORT AT SUPPORT
THAT. ON THE SCOPE OF WORKERS-
EIGHT. OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
QUESTION MOVING FORWARD BEYOND
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ABOUT WHO
SHOULD BE COVERED BY A
PRESUMPTION AGAIN I WILL GO
BACK- TO THE TO THE ISSUE AT
HAND. THERE NEEDS TO BE A
FILTER THEIR OF THE SYSTEM IS
TO WORK PROPERLY. SO WHATEVER
IT IS IF WE'RE CREATING A
PRESUMPTION THE- THE WORKER
SHOULD HAVE A HIGHER EXPOSURE
IN THE WORKPLACE NAY DO OUTSIDE
I WOULD MAKE ONE NOTE AT YOUR
TIMES AND THEN I WILL AND I
WILL GO. IF YOU NEEDED THAT
WRAP UP OKAY. IT'S MY TIME TO
WRAP UP. THANK YOU GET. OKAY
THANK YOU YOU GET A YEAR THREE
MINUTES THERE. OKAY SO THAT
SERVICE WE ARE TOO. CLEANERS I
DID GIVE US REALLY LIBERAL TO
TIME SO- A WOULD ASK THAT ARE
YOU HERE FOR CLEANER OR- OKAY-
I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO. THE DIRTY
TO MAKE IN YOUR REMARKS I'LL BE
I'LL BE BRIEF. OKAY A VERY
BRIEF PLEASE THANK YOU FOR THAT
AT FIFTY ITS DITTO FOR OF
SOMEONE THAT SAID BEFORE THAT
BE HELPFUL OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK FOR JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS OF THIRTY THREE WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MISTER
SMELTER WE APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL NATURE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS TAKEN BOTH IN
DIALOGUE TODAY AND PREVIOUS
CONVERSATIONS WE LOOK FOR TO
REMAINING. ENGAGED ON THAT
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
HAS BEEN ACTIVE DURING THIS
COVETED. AND CRISIS AND THAT WE
ARE IN FACT EXCEPTING CLAIMS
CODE OR OTHERWISE WE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTENT
DIALOGUE. THANK YOU. TEST
WIENER. OKAY CHAIR SENATORS
BETTER BECOME AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH CHAIR WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY. THANK
OKAY THANK YOU- SERVE IN THIS
INTERESTING PLACER OKAY SO IS
THERE ANY OTHER. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE AND FORTY TWO
OR THREE. EIGHTY NINE OKAY ARE
THERE ANY I UNDERSTAND THAT
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. OKAY SO
WE HAVE OKAY WE HAVE AN IMAGE
THERE'S NO TWEETERS OR
OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
TELEPHONE LINE- SO- YEAH AND I
WILL TAKE TESTIMONY FROM PEOPLE
WHO ARE EITHER CLEANERS OR- IN
OPPOSITION. STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THEN YOUR
POSITION WHICH IS THINKING
ABOUT IT OR- OPPOSE AT THIS
POINT TIME SO MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. THANK
YOU AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OR AT TWENTY BILL SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE OF THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRISTY
BELMONT SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS TODAY. YOU KNOW
FAR BETTER COMMITMENT TO
PROTECT LIFE AND PROPERTY
INCLUDING RESPONDED TO LEVEL
ONE CALLED NOT JUST RESPONSE
THE FIRES POLITICALLY AND ALL
HAZARDS BUT ALSO HELP MERCHANT
NAMED. EVEN DURING THE PUBLIC
OPEN VERSION- THAT IS I'D NOT
REALLY TAKING TESTIMONY THIS
PLAN WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY IF
YOU WANNA MAKE A ONE LINER
THOUGH AND EXTEND. OUT YOUR
POSITION THAT THE GREAT. MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
INDULGE THE ELDEST. WHAT THE
LABOR FEDERATION MY COLLEAGUE
SAID. WE CAN WE OFFER SOME
SUGGESTIONS WE APPRECIATE THAT
WELL INTO THE MEASURE WE
RECOMMEND THAT. SINCE THE BILL
HAS A- BLANK SUNSET WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS ELECTION SHOULD EXIST
AS LONG AS IT'S COMMUNICABLE
VIRUS IS WITH US. AND THEN ALSO
ON THE LIMITATIONS ON THE
DETERMINATION FOR WHEN AN
INJURY BECOME A COMPENSABLE.
BELIEVE ONCE THE WORKER
DIAGNOSED WITH COPD NINETEEN
THE PRODUCTION SHOULD APPLY AND
APPEARED COMPATIBILITY. SHOULD
BEGIN. SHE THE COORDINATION OF
THE ATTEMPT TO COORDINATE
FEDERAL AVAILABLE BENEFIT THE
WE DON'T THINK THE PRISON.
SHOULD BE DELAYED UNTIL. OR
SOME ARBITRARY NUMBER OF DAYS.
INDICATES WHAT THE SIGNIFICANT
LOTS OF TIME SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE CHAIRMAN.
AND THE COMMITTEE AND OTHERS ON
THIS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE TO SPEAK OF THE
MOMENT CUSHION. THANK YOU- ALL
RIGHT AND I WOULD ALSO JUST
WANNA MAKE NOTE THAT- PEOPLE
ARE ALSO FREE TO COMMUNICATE
DIRECTLY WITH US THROUGH THE
WEBSITE OR DIRECTLY WITH THE-
STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR. WITH MORE SPECIFIC
DETAIL SO I APPRECIATE THAT
OKAY IT'S OR OTHER ARE THERE
OTHER PEOPLE ON THE LINE. YES
MINE THREE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THANK YOU. HI THIS IS
THE ONLY CABINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION- CALLING IN THE
CONCERNS POSITION I'D LIKE TO
APPLY MY COMMENTS WITHOUT A BIT
YOUR SIR. AND WHICH IS NOT A
MINUTE THIRTY SPOKE THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU. LINE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
WOULD YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO WITH SOME CONCERN THEN I
LINE- WE ALIGN OUR CONCERN WITH
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH COULD
YOU SHARE NUMBERS IF YOU CAN
CALL RIGHT CALLING FROM THE
CONCRETE ACKERMAN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE CLEANER AND
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
MADE BY MISTER SMITH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS FILLED
VERMAELEN WITH ACCLAMATION
INSURANCE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
AND ALLIED MANAGED CARE WE TOO
ARE A TWEENER AND PLEDGED TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. PINE TREE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU'RE SURE MEMBERS YOUR
MEMBERS- WITH THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR AND WHAT
A LIE AND I'M OUR COMMENTS
WHICH ARE MISTER SMALL DURING
THOSE BORDERS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS A- GOOD
EVENING TERM MEMBERS THIS IS
STEPHANIE MORE WELL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FUELED
INCONVENIENT ALLIANCE AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LICENSE TO SECURITY AGENCIES
CARDS AND A TICKET. I WE ARE A
TWEENER AND- WE YOU ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF CONCERN LAID OUT BY
MR SHELTER. THANK YOU. MINE
THREE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
WE ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THOSE BEFORE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE THREE TWENTY EIGHT
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH I THIS WOULD
BE MICROBES IN. REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION MIDDLE LINE OF
COMICS THAT MR SCHMELZER WORKS
THANKS. THANK YOU MODERATELY
TWENTY HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ON
THE LINE STILL IN A COUPLE. WE
HAVE TWO LEFT OKAY ALL RIGHT
PLEASE CONTINUE. NINE THREE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JACKSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND WE ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS AND ALIGN OUR
COMMENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. THANK YOU.
THE OTHER COLOR REMOVED HIMSELF
FROM Q. OKAY KENTUCKY JUST
CHECK ONE MORE TIME TO BE SURE
THAT WE ARE NOT MISSING ANYONE.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OR R. TWEENER ON
SB BILL LEVIN FIFTY NINE. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE
MINE TO THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON OR
GOOD EVENING ACTUALLY AT THIS
IS TO USE OF THE CALIFORNIA
THEY GET THE PRODUCERS OCT OFF
WHICH WIENER AND- LINE COMMENT-
WENT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF WORKERS COMPENSATION THANK
YOU FOR TO WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE VERY. OUR INDUSTRY THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. RIGHT THANK YOU
THREE MUCH OF THE SPRING THE
SPEC TO A MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MANY MEMBERS. THE
BETTER THE OKAY- SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- ACTUALLY
I DO HAVE A BRIEF ONE CENTER
HELLO- APPRECIATE YOU KNOW-
WHAT YOU'RE YOU AND- SOME
MEMBER DALY BELIEVES THAT
YOU'RE GOING AUTHOR AT AND
TRYING TO DRESS THIS ISSUES
SPECIALLY IN RESPECT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S- EXECUTIVE ORDER I
GUESS ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
THOUGH IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
HEARD FROM THE VARIOUS CLEANERS
AND THE DIFFERENT SHADES OF
POSITIONS PEOPLE TAKEN BUT WE
ALSO HEARD PREVIOUSLY HEARD
UNTIL- AS WELL- FROM THE NURSES
ASSOCIATION ABOUT. THEIR
SITUATION I EIGHT CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE COLD IT IS A YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT IS AN HONOR MIND BUT
SOME OF THE OTHER DISEASES THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP THAT THE NURSES
BROUGHT UP- FRANKLY THERE'S A
POSITION ARE EQUALLY DANGEROUS
TO JUST NOT WIDESPREAD-
CONTINUE MAYBE SPEAK TO WHERE
YOU SEE THE BILL GOING AND YOUR
CONVERSATIONS I REALIZED THAT
IT- AND IN TERMS OF WHY WHY DO
WE JUST FOR CODED. SO WE I MEAN
WE'RE DO IT FOR COLD IN THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
IN THE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE
COVERT IS THE- THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE FACED WITH TODAY AND
THERE. AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE WORKERS THAT THIS
PRESSURE THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
BEFORE THE THAT THEY ARE.
PROTECTED I MEAN THAT IS THE
ESSENTIAL ROLE OF THIS AND
TRYING TO FOLLOW ON THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
WHICH I THINK WAS PRETTY FAIRLY
COMPREHENSIVE. IN THOSE
PROTECTIONS AND SO THE REAL THE
REAL GOAL FOR US IS TO TRY TO.
TO MOVE THAT AND HOW DO AS
ESTABLISH A CERTAIN TIMELINE
PERHAPS- WITH THE SUNSET.
BECAUSE THIS PROBABLY WON'T BE
WITH US FOR EVER IT MAY EVEN BE
NO DIFFERENT THAN A COLD AT
SOME POINT IN TIME HOPEFULLY OR
THE FLU. BUT INTO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IS DONE
DELICATELY AND DONE IN A WAY
THAT- PROTECTS THE WORKER- BUT
ALSO DOESN'T BANKRUPT THE
SYSTEM AS WELL. RIGHT THANK
YOU. YES CENTER MITCHELL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST TO
CLARIFY DOES YOUR BILL CODIFY
EVERY ELEMENT OF THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER NO ITS IT WE'RE NOT THERE
YET IN TERMS OF THE DISCUSSION
IT IS THAT'S WERE THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND WITH ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS IT WE HEARD THE
TWEETERS AND THOSE OPPOSED- WE
WANT TO HAVE A CONVERSATION TO
SEE WHERE WE CAN FIND THE RIGHT
FIT IN THE RIGHT SPOT. TO
CONTINUE HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER
CERTAINLY PROVIDES A PROTECTION
TODAY BUT AS WE KNOW TERM IT
SUNSETS IN A COUPLE MONTHS AND
WE NEED SOMETHING TO GO BEYOND
THAT SO THAT'S THE GOAL NETWORK
PLANETA BUT DID IT WILL NOT CUT
OFF I IS HIS ORDER AS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SENIOR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
SEEING NONE THIS WAS THEIR
MOTION. MILLION OKAY IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR JACKSON'S-
SIX. THE MOTION IS. SORRY
WHAT'S THE MOTION ON SIMILAR.
ISSUES OF CORPORATION IF OKAY
SO THIS IS. THE PAST TWO AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR JACKSON'S
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN
ORDER TO VOTE- CENTER HILL HI
CENTER HILL BY CENTER MOREAU.
CENTER JACKSON HI SENATE
JACKSON BY CENTER MITCHELL HI-
MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN. IT WILL
WILL HOLD THE ASSEMBLED THE
BILL ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
NUMBER- AND I THINK THAT SO
MANY PASSES ON TO GET THE EXAM
OR HEALTH OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND- WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
SENATOR DORADO WITH S. B. AT.
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE SENATOR
RAZA WELCOME. AND THANKS FOR
YOUR. HERE I'M DYING PATIENTS
TODAY ON ENDING PATIENTS IS FOR.
GOOD. WHAT YOUR TULARE. FOR
MARCH. YOU CAN DO THAT YEAH
SURE GO AHEAD A FIVE LICENSOR
DORADO- SECRETARY COMPLETELY WE
PLEASE- REOPEN THE ROLE ON- SB
ELEVEN FIFTY NINE FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MOREAU NO WAY OUT. NO
WONDER NO I MEAN NO NO. THANKS
FOR. I'M SORRY. NO SENATOR
MORALE NO SENATOR PAN. ALRIGHT
SO THAT BILLS OUT THREE ONE.
SENATOR ALSO WELCOME AGAIN
THANK YOU YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
YOUR BILL SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
SO GOOD TO SEE EVERYONE HERE
GOOD EVENING- AS CONSIGUEN
AFTERNOON BUT IT'S GOOD EVENING
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. IS
GOING TO MAKE HELP TO MAKE SURE
THAT PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE ACCURATE
AND TIMELY BARGAINING UNIT
INFORMATION TO WHICH THEY ARE
ALREADY ENTITLED TO BY LAW. BUT
SO THAT THEY MAY FULFILL THE
LEGAL REPRESENTATIONAL DUTIES
AND MEET THE NEW NEEDS OF THE
BARGAINING UNIT STAFF AS A
WHOLE THREE YEARS GONE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AB ONE ONE NINE WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW. IT GRANTED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
ACCESS TO NEW HIRE CONTACT
INFORMATION WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
OF THEIR HIRE DATE AS SPECIFIC
BARGAINING UNIT THAT AT EVERY
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS.
DESPITE THIS MANY PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS STILL CHOOSE TO
IGNORE THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OR SEND INACCURATE
BROUGHT OF DATE INFORMATION IN
FACT SIXTY EMPLOYERS FAIL TO
EVEN RESPOND TO THEIR
BARGAINING AGENT WITH NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS REASON SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
ESTABLISHES SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES WITH PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE EMPLOYER TO
CURE THE PROBLEM AND RESPOND.
WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
MAKING SURE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS AT
HERE TO EXISTING LAW. THE
NUMBER WE ALL RELY AND NEED
ACCURATE AND TIMELY INFORMATION
WHETHER THE STATE IS FACING
WILDFIRES MASS SHOOTINGS-
PANDEMIC VIRUSES. PUBLIC
SERVANTS ARE EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE. THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
REPRESENTATIVE HAS A MORAL AND
A LEGAL DUTY TO WATCH OUT FOR
THE WELFARE OF THESE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WHO IN TURN WATCH OUT
FOR THE PUBLIC'S WELLBEING.
SHORTAGES FOR EXAMPLE AND PP
HAVE LEFT MANY FRONTLINE
WORKERS EXPOSED WHILE SERVING
THE PUBLIC THE UNIONS HAVE
FOUND THEMSELVES PROCURING PP
TO KEEP THE EMPLOYEES AND THE
PUBLIC SAFE WHERE PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS LACK THOSE RESOURCES
BUT TO DETERMINE PP NEEDS
UNIONS HAVE. MUST HAVE ACCURATE
UP TO DATE CONTACT INFORMATION
AND WORK SITE LOCATIONS A
BARGAINING UNIT MET- MEMBERS
THIS CRISIS IS SHOWN- AND IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER FOR
THE REPRESENTATIVES TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE. BUT
WITH THOSE A WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN FOR THESE REASONS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING AS BE LIMóN SEVENTY
THREE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE- THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND MISTER CHAIR MY
WITNESSES TODAY WILL BE.
SOMETHING ABOUT I DON'T RURAL
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND MICHAEL YOUNG
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF LABOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR WITNESSES-
CENTER- BUT ARIO PLEASE. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CENTER PEROT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND IT
SHOULD BE FOR ONE SECOND I DID
WANT TO JUST. OUTLINED OF SAID
EARLIER THAT WE HAVE THREE
MINUTES FOR THE SPORT WITNESSES
AND THREE MINUTES FOR THE
OPPOSITION TO BE FAIR SO YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES TOTAL.
PLEASE RECEIVING ALE. ACCENT I
SENATOR DRAWS IS SAID TO THE
POOL OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
OF COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING
LAW. MOST OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE REPRESENT. ARE
ALREADY IN COMPLIANCE FOR
EXAMPLE OUT OF SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY SCHOOL DISTRICT. ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DID NOT
SUBMIT THE LIST. DO YOU IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR. DURING
THE PANDEMIC MINIBUS FRONTLINE
WORKERS. INCLUDING THOSE IN
FOOD SERVICE HAVE NOT RECEIVED
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
COMBINED CLEARS. WE NEED THE
INFORMATION REQUIRED BY AB ONE
ONE NINE TWO. WHICH ABOUT
MEMBERS. STILL NEED PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT IN ORDER
TO SAFELY SERVE THE PUBLIC. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYES
OUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THREE
ON A CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG. MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION-
WENT TO CO SPONSORS BATES BE
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE- WHEN AB
ONE NINETEEN WITH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN OUTLINE KEY MEMBER
INFORMATION THAT PUBLIC
EMPLOYER IS REQUIRED TO SHARE
WITH THE CORRECT TIMELINE FOR
WHEN THEY FOR ME SHE NEEDED TO
BE SHARED I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT LET'S
BE. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
DOESN'T CREATE A NEW
APPLICATION ON PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
WERE AT CHANGING THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE REQUIRE
WE'RE NOT CHANGING THE TIMELINE
THAT WHICH THAT DATA MUST BE
PROVIDED WITH EVERYTHING THAT
EMPLOYER THEY REFUSE TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW THAT'S BEEN ON THE
BOOKS FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS AND
AFTER BEING NOTICED AND NOT
COMPLIANT AND THAT THE CLIENT
SECURITY. ISSUE DURING THE NEW
VEHICLES. CAN THEY BASED ON
COUNTIES FOR PILING THE LAW. I
MET. AT AT THE AT THE CORE
DESPITE THE THAT MOST EMPLOYERS
ARE COMPLYING WITH THE LAW.
THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES- COUNTY
EMPLOYERS SCHOOL DISTRICT
ANYTHING YOU SEE EMPLOYERS THAT
HAVE JUST REFUSED TO COMPLY.
IT'S BEEN AND- I'VE NEVER
COMPLY SO THERE'S A CLEAR NEED
FOR THIS LAW. AND WE URGE AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER FOR THE
TESTIMONY FROM YOUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES WILL NOW BEGIN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. TO ARE THERE ANY-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE SEEN NO ONE WILL MOVE TO.
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
SUPPORTING ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. SEE NO ONE ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY
BE THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE THE MIND OF. THREE ZERO
NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MR
TURKEY MANY MEMBERS MICHELLE
CAPTURE THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION ALL PHONE
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE DO WANT TO
MENTION THAT YOU IF YOU WOULD
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL THAT WOULD BE. WONDERFUL
AND WE HAVE TEN MINUTES OF
SUPPORT. ALLOCATED PLEASE
PROCEED. NINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BROWN BUT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE AND
BEFORE. NINE ONE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TRISTEN BROWN AT THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MY TO THE ONE
NEAR LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND THE
UNITED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS CHRISTINE ABOUT HIM
OKAY AND TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS U. D. W. ACT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MINE TO NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BECAUSE THEN
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE COURT
THAT THE KID IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MINE TO THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS THAT CAN
BE HAVE YOU A W. LOCAL TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND THREE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
THREE TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE. MINE THREE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE YOUR MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO BE SURE WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL OF THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE NINE THREE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
APOLOGIES RESEARCHER AND
MEMBERS. OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IT
HERE FROM ANY OPPOSITION. LET'S
BEGIN WITH PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES. OF
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND CENTER-
I PROMISE NOT TO TAKE THREE
MINUTES- FIRST OF IT MAYBE THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING TO SAY IS
WE DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE
SENATOR- AT ALL WITH RESPECT TO
THE FACT THAT PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
BE COMPLYING WITH LONG
PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION TO
THEIR UNIONS- I THINK OUR ISSUE
RIGHT NOW IS- WELL IT WAS IT
WAS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS TO BE
THE AUTHOR INDICATED THERE
WASN'T A CURRENT READY WE
BELIEVE THAT A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
UNION COULD SIMPLY FILE SUIT
AND ASK THE JUDGE TO ORDER
COMPLIANCE- WITH THE STATE LAW-
AND THAT WOULD BE RELATIVELY
SIMPLE TO ACHIEVE I'D BE
CURIOUS OF THE SIXTY- YOU KNOW
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS WERE COMPELLED
BY LAW- IT THAT WERE MENTIONED
AT IN. EARLY IN THE FINALLY I
JUST. THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
IS- OBVIOUSLY WERE IN A VERY
UNIQUE SITUATION RIGHT NOW AS
WE SAW TODAY THE MAY REVISE
WE'RE GOING TO SEE. REVISED
BUDGETS FOR PUBLIC ENTITIES ALL
OVER THE STATE AND I GUESS WERE
HAVING A VERY HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING WHY WE WOULD TAKE
PUBLIC DOLLARS. AWAY FROM
PUBLIC BENEFIT- DURING THIS
TIME OVER WHAT IS LARGELY A
PAPERWORK HERE- BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH FOLKS ON HOW
TO RESOLVE THIS PROBLEM BUT
PULLING MONEY AWAY FROM PUBLIC
BENEFIT RIGHT NOW. DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE A VERY GOOD IDEA TO US AND
FOR THAT REASON WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. HE'S I'M SURE
THE COUPLE ACTUALLY GET UP I AM
I MISSED IT A KEY PLEASE OF WHO
REPRESENTING OC SEX THAT'S
INSURANCE THIRTY THANK YOU
ENGLISH OR THIRTY ALL THE TO
THAT THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE C. NO ONE. IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWO TWENTY FORTY.
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. SEE NO ONE THERE THANK
YOU WILL MOVE NOW TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY BE THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE WE WILL
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IN PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME. AFFILIATION AND YOUR
SUPPORT- YOUR POSITION.
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION. THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS IN Q. WOULD YOU
PLEASE ASK ONE MORE TIME. FOR
ANYBODY WISHING TO COMMENT ON
IN OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN Q. THANK YOU
TO ALL OF SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE WANNA BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
DO ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS SENATOR JACKSON'S. UP
WHILE IBM. HAD IT SHARE SOME
CONCERN ABOUT USING PUBLIC
DOLLARS. I DO KNOW THAT THIS
BILL DOES PROVIDE FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE. AND I
THINK THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
IN THIS SITUATION IF INDEED
IT'S INADVERTENT IT'LL BE
RESOLVED IF IT IS AN
INADVERTENT SOMEONE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO THE
TAXPAYERS WHY THAT MONEY IS
BEING SPENT- TO COMPLY WERE IS
A SANCTION A PENALTY FOR NOT
COMPLYING WITH THE LAW SO. I
THINK IT'S A VERY REASONABLE.
APPROACH TO A PROBLEM THAT-
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE NO TEETH AND
THE YOU KNOW I THINK WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED A SORT OF A- A
BEING SHINED ON A BY AGENCIES
CENTER FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
BUT IT'S JUST NOT APPROPRIATE
AND IT'S KIND OF CONTRARY TO
THE LAW. SO I THINK- THIS MAKES
SENSE I THINK IT'S A GOOD
BALANCE AND I'M HAPPY TO- MOVES
ABILITY PREPARATORY. THANK YOU.
THE COMMENTS OR DISCUSSIONS
SENATOR OTHER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. OUR THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. Q. I'VE HAVE A
NUMBER OF COMMENTS I WANTED TO
MAKE IT TO GIVE THIS A LOT OF
THOUGHT BECAUSE WE'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS AND I APPRECIATE
THAT SENATOR ALSO AND I HAVE.
IS CONCERNED WITH THE BILL- YOU
KNOW WE HAD SOME AMENDMENTS
THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS. BUT
OTHER AMENDMENTS WERE TALKED
ABOUT AND- OFFERED- FLASH
NIGHTER YESTERDAY. THE INDEED
IN THOSE DID NOT RESOLVE THE
ISSUES UNFORTUNATELY SO I WILL
HAVE TO BE VOTING NO ON THE
BILL TODAY I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL THAT CREATES A RIGHT TO
ATTORNEYS FEES FOR UNIONS TO
BRING PER ACTIONS AGAINST
CALIFORNIA CITIES COUNTIES AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS INCREASE
MONETARY PENALTIES FOR THOSE
PUBLIC AGENCIES BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAND OVER EMPLOYEE
CONTACT AT A TO THE UNION
QUICKLY ENOUGH. REPUBLICAN
LAWYERS AND PARTNERS ARE
BUCKLING UNDER THE SOCIAL
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES OF THE CODE
NINETEEN CRISIS THE REVENUES
ATTACKED. THE COST OF INCREASED
SUBSTANTIALLY AND SO HAS THE
WORKLOAD. MEANWHILE WHETHER
EMPLOYEES ARE STRUGGLING TO
ADAPT TO WORKING FROM HOME OR
WITH UNFAMILIAR TECHNOLOGY
SEPARATED FROM THEIR COLLEAGUES
THEIR OFFICES IN THEIR NORMAL
RESOURCES ALL WATCH WHILE
TRYING TO CONFRONT THE
CHALLENGES OF THIS PANDEMIC I
FIND IT PUZZLING. THAT WE WOULD
TAKE THIS MOMENT. TO MAKE THEM
MORE VULNERABLE TO FURTHER
REVENUE LOSSES AND FRANKLY
LITIGIOUS TIMES SUCKS TICKET
OUR UNION FRIENDS INFORMATION.
THAT THEY COULD GET THROUGH
THEIR OWN EFFORTS AND MOSTLY DO
GET FROM MOST PUBLIC EMPLOYERS.
I DON'T ASSURE GOOD THIS THIS
THIS BILL IS CREATING A PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACTOR PAGO FOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT DISPUTES. AND
THAT IS GOING TO LEAD TO
GREATER PURPOSE CHARGE WHEN WE
KNOW THAT PURPLE ALREADY LIKELY
SEE INCREASED WORKLOAD FROM THE
SERVICES OF THE SEVERE
DISRUPTIONS THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE ACROSS OUR PUBLIC SECTOR.
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES PERPETUAL
ATTORNEYS FEES TO UNIONS WHO
WIN BUT NOT THE PUBLIC AGENCIES
OR WHEN. SUBJECT PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO UNSPECIFIED
MONETARY PENALTIES PROVIDE
REALLY SHORT TIMELINE FOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS TO RESPOND
BEFORE GETTING DRAGGED PER.
GIVES THESE PER CHARGES AN
EXPEDITED PROCESS WHICH TEND IS
GOING AGAINST OTHER POTENTIAL
UNIONS THAT MAYBE APPLYING FOR
PER. CONDITIONS OR A TIME.
GIVES THE ILLUSION OF A CURE
PERIOD BUT GIVES THE UNION AN
UNSUPERVISED VETO OVER THAT
CURE. THE MEMBERS- PROS
PROPOSED MILDLY BUT GOING
SUBSTANTIALLY MAKE A CHANGE FOR
THAT SAID IT TO THAT BECAUSE OF
PURGATORY FEES WILL BE AWARDED.
NOW TO THE PREVAILING PARTY
UNION OR EMPLOYER BUT ONLY ON
APPEAL- SO I'VE BEEN AND THEN
THERE'S ADDED SOMETHING CALLED
ENFORCEMENT EXPENSE TO THE
AMOUNT THAT THE PUBLIC AGENCY
HAS TO PAY. IF IT LOSES ON
APPEAL. I'M NOT EVEN SURE WHAT
THAT ENTAILS NOR WHAT CAN'T
QUALIFY UNDER THAT RUBRIC THIS
BILL REALLY CREATES A FORMER
PUB TYPICAL PUBLIC AGENCIES. NO
LONGER HAVE MEANINGFUL APPEAL
RIGHTS FOR THESE REASONS I
CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL AND I
THINK IT NEEDS SOME SOME WORK.
IF IT WERE TO COME BACK AND IN
SOME FORM OR ANOTHER SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT- SENATOR
DRAWS BUT- WE DO HAVE A-
BELIEVEA MOTION FROM THE
SENATOR JACKSON. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS PLEASE TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO
VOTE. THE MOTION IS DO THEY
HAVE TO. IT SHOULD DIE I KNOW
WHETHER WE SHOULD AFFORD THE
SENATOR ENOUGH AND SHE CLOSED
AN OPPORTUNE RESPOND TO THIS
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
SENATOR ROGER I'M SORRY I'VE
THAT WAS. MORE BY A STATEMENT
OF MY POSITION SURE A AND. OF
COURSE YOU HAVE ABSOLUTELY LIKE
USER DRUGS I APOLOGIZE IF I
DIDN'T DO THAT I SHOULD OF
OTHERS THE STEADY MORE MY
POSITION OF THE BILL THAT
EVERYONE HAS BEEN SEEN IN THE
ANALYSIS OF IT OUTLINES WHAT I
JUST SAID. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR HILL ON THE CENTER PAN
I LOOK WE THERE ARE CERTAIN
ISSUES- IN TERMS OF THE
AMENDMENT THAT WE PROPOSE THAT
WE WOULD CONTINUE TO WORK. WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS ON. WHETHER
IT'S YOU KNOW CAPPING PENALTIES
OR WHETHER IT'S THAT THE
PENALTIES CAN GO INTO THE PROBE
GENERAL FUND THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF WAYS THAT WE COULD- WE COULD
CLARIFY THOSE THOSE ISSUES- BUT
WE JUST- IF IT'S GOING TO
WEAKEN EXISTING LAW THEN WE'RE
GOING BACKWARDS AND WE DON'T
WANT TO GO BACKWARDS YOU KNOW.
US A NEW STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
I MEAN THEY'RE ALL THERE WERE
THINGS THAT JUST. DON'T MAKE IT
PALATABLE AND- AND YOU KNOW
REALLY DESTROY THE INTENT OF
THE BILL SO- AGAIN THERE ARE
SEVERAL THINGS THAT EXAMPLES I
JUST GAVE YOU THAT WE WOULD
CONTINUE WE COULD CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
WITH YOURSELF- AND- IT JUST.
YOU KNOW JUST CAN BE THE SORTS
OF THINGS THAT WOULD DESTROY
THE WHOLE UP PURPOSE OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS
OF WE DO HAVE A MOTION ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CENTERS PLEASE TURNER
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO VOTE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR HILL NEW.
SENATOR HILL NO CENTER MOREAU
NO. CENTER TOMORROW NO SENATOR
JACKSON HI SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR MITCHELL HI CENTER
MITCHELL HI SENATOR PAN. I.
SENATOR PAN AYE AYE CENTER PAN
HI WHO HAS THREE VOTES IT IS UP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU WILL CONTINUE WITH YOUR
NEXT BILL CENTER DRAWS OF.
YOU'RE LUCKY TODAY THEY'RE BOTH
IN ORDER. SHE'S GOT ANOTHER ONE
IN WHICH IS THE EXCEPT FOR THE
THIRD ONE. THE. YES TO A FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE THANK YOU. I KNOW.
SO THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT- SB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COLLEAGUES THE CAL
OSHA OTHERWISE KNOWN GOD
CALIFORNIA'S OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH ACT EXCLUDES
DOMESTIC HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES THIS BILL
SIMPLY ELIMINATES THAT
EXCLUSION. THERE ARE MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOMESTIC
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA AND MORE
THAN TWO MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
DEPEND ON THEM. TO CARE FOR
THEIR HOMES SENIORS AND
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES.
THESE DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE
PRIMARILY- WOMEN OF COLOR THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE ECONOMY
AND THE ABILITY OF CALIFORNIANS
TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY THEY
DESERVE CONSIDERATION FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES JUST
LIKE ANY OTHER WORKING MAN OR
WOMAN- WE CANNOT WE SHOULD NOT
EXCLUDE GROUPS OF WORKERS FROM
HEALTH AND SAFETY. NOT DURING
THIS PANDEMIC NOT DURING WHILE
FAR IS NOT DURING NOT IN EVERY
DAY THAT PUTS THEIR HEALTH THE
WELL BEING AND THEIR FAMILIES
ON THE LINE- DOMESTIC WORKERS
HEALTH AND SAFETY HAVE BEEN PUT
AT SEVERE RISK. DURING THE
RECENT DISTRAUGHT DISASTERS
THAT OBSTRUCT CALIFORNIA- THERE
ON THE FRONT LINES DURING THE
PANDEMIC- THEY REMAIN
VULNERABLE AND WITHOUT
PROTECTIONS DURING THE
WILDFIRES DOMESTIC WORKERS AND
OTHER HOUSEHOLD WORKERS WERE
ASKED TO STAY BEHIND TO FIGHT
BUYERS TO GUARD HOMES OUR PETS
AND- WORK IN SMOKY CONDITIONS
AND CLEAN UP TOXIC ASH- THEY
WERE. FURTHER PUT AT RISK WHEN
EMPLOYERS FAILED TO TELL THEM
THAT THE HOMES THEY WORK IN
WONDER MANDATORY IN BACK
EVACUATION. AT THE GROWING
FREQUENCY AND INTENSITY OF
WILDFIRES AND OTHER NATURAL
DESIRES DISASTERS REQUIRES THAT
LEGISLATORS TAKE AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION TO PROTECT THEM WELL
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THESE
PRIMARILY WOMEN WORKERS. OF MY
TWO WITNESSES A SUPPORT TODAY
ARE MEGAN ORTIZ FROM THE
INSTITUTO THAT THE GUY SIMPLE
BLOOD AT THE UPS GROUND. AND
ALAN GET LEON CARE GIVER AND
MEMBER LEADER OF THE FILIPINO
WORKER CENTER MISSING CHEN
COMMITTEE MEMBER ROSA MISS
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO AND I
BELIEVE- THEY'RE BOTH ON THE
LINE. TO MS ARTISTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN. CAN YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES TOTAL DURING.
THERE'S THREE MINUTES TIME OF
FOR THE TOTAL SUPPORT IT
TESTIMONY TO YES WE HEAR YOU.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD EVENING I'M AS CENTER THAT
ALSO SAID ON MAKE IT OR DO YOU
THINK THAT YOU HAVE DIRECTOR OF
THE INSTITUTE OF POPULAR
EDUCATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOU THAT WERE
ACTUALLY THE LARGEST WORKERS
CENTER IN THE STATE BUT FIVE
LOCATIONS. SERVING AND
ADVOCATING WITH THOUSANDS OF
DAY LABOR THAN DOMESTIC WORKER
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC DOMESTIC WORKERS
CONTINUED TO CARE FOR OUR LOVED
ONES AND OUR WHOLE. ARE FROM
LINE AND IT'S WORKERS. THEY
KEEP THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS MOST
VULNERABLE TO THE ELEMENTS. AND
THEIR HOMES AND OUT OF OVER
BURDENS INSTITUTION.
UNFORTUNATELY DOMESTIC WORKERS
HAVE FACED A SHAMEFUL. OF
EXCLUSION FROM BASIC LABOR
PROTECTION. ADD IN THE ONGOING
CULTURE THAT THE VALUE CARE
WORK. AS PRIMARILY IMMIGRANT
WOMEN- WAIT FOR. DURING THIS
HEALTH THERE WORKING WITHOUT
ANY RIGHT TO BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTECTIONS BECAUSE
THEY'RE EXCLUDED FOR CAL OSHA
AND THESE RATES ARE A MATTER OF
LIFE AND DEATH. BUT HE SAID NOT
A HOUSEKEEPER HAS BEEN EXPOSED
TWICE THE COLBERT NINETEEN AT
WORK AND RIGHT NOW SHE'S IN
QUARANTINE WITH HER FAMILY HER
SON AND ROOMMATE ALSO BOTH
TESTED POSITIVE. AS WE APPROACH
WILD FIRES THE THAT THE DANGERS
THE MASTIC WORK DAY LABOR BASED
WITHOUT CAL OSHA PROTECTIONS
ARE EVEN MORE MAGNIFIED. A LOT
HAS FLORA AND HIS WIFE BOTH
WORKED IN THE SAME HOME IN
MALIBU DURING THE WILL BE FIRE
HE WAS HOSPITALIZED WITH A
HEART CONDITION BALK EXPOSURE
AND HIS WIFE HAS JOINT DAMAGED
BECAUSE OF REPETITIVE MOTION.
OUR ORGANIZATION THAT THEIR
EMPLOYER SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
IS REALLY JUST ABOUT BASIC
PROTECTIONS BRICK INDUSTRY THAT
NOW MORE THAN EVER DESPERATELY
NEED STANDARDS AND GUIDANCE.
PEOPLE WHO HIRE HOUSEHOLD
WORKERS ALREADY CLASSIFIED AS
EMPLOYERS AND THEY ALREADY HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH LABOR LAWS TO
STATE AND LOCAL REGION OUR A
LOT. THROUGH CAL OSHA AND CLOUT
LAWYERS WOULD RECEIVE THE
GUIDANCE AND WHAT THEY NEED AND
HOW TO CREATE SAFE WORKPLACES
WITHIN THEIR WHOLE. A DOMESTIC
WORKER WE HAVE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT THE HAZARDS
THAT EXIST AND THE RIGHT TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES WITHOUT FEAR
OF RETALIATION. FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS SPELL I
pWHY HELLO TO ALL MANY ALITALIA
I AM SURE GIVE A LEADER OF THE
PEOPLE WORKING. IN A CROWD MAY
WE DON'T STOP. I HAVE WORKED
FOR EIGHTY NINE YEAR OLD LADY
IN THEIR HOME FOR ALMOST FOUR
YEARS NOW. THAT'S PART. HI
PROBLEMS. HE YEAH I WOULD
CHOOSE TO WORK WITH OTHER
CLIENTS. I SAW. OR MY SON. BUT
LET ME THE SAME WAY AS WELL.
YEAH HOMES WILL COST I DON'T.
WE ARE ON THE FRONTLINE INCLUDE
CON WITH PEOPLE WAS MORE
VULNERABLE. BILLS FOR A GROUP
OF THE WHY THE PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. RATING THANK. WELL
WE ARE ALL ABOUT EVERY. A
NUMBER OF WHO CAN HELP ABOUT
THE COURT. SHE IT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY THANK YOU BUT
WILL NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB. TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN. SHE NO ONE WILL MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN SEE NO ONE
THERE IS WELL THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE. ON TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY
BE THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN AND WE HAVE-
ALLOWED FOR TEN MINUTES OF THAT
IN IF THE- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WOULD GIVE THEIR NAME
THEIR AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. IT WOULD
BE MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU WISH TO.
SUPPORT SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO HAVE MINE THREE
FORTY ONE MOMENT. LUNCH AT
THREE FORTY. GOOD SERVICE ON-
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE TO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I MEMBERS OF THE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE ALLEY RESPECT WE COME
BEFORE YOU OVER HUNDRED NUMBERS
AT THE CORNERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN WE WILL DO
OUR BEST TO GET YOU TEN MINUTES
THAT'S EXACTLY WE CAN- MAKE. AN
ASSOCIATE AT FIRST. RIGHT NOW.
OKAY BEGINNING AND I'LL BUY.
HELLO THANK. I THANK. YOU.
NOBODY ALL PLAN FOR YOUR LIFE
THERE WAS A INCREASED. LOCAL I
GOT A LOT. YEAH NEW GOVERNMENT.
THERE ARE YOU KNOW ARE THERE
ARE GOING TO GET ON THE- ARE
FOR YOU IT'S A HARD A LOT YEAH
UNITED MADE. FOR ALL. YEAH WILL
BE BACK WITH THE- I AM FROM THE
FILIPINO WHAT IT DOWN. AND I'M
BORED OF. IS THERE THEN THANK
YOU. YEAH. YEAH THAT VEHICLE
YEAH I KNOW THAT IN THE LAST
NIGHT OF THE BLAST. WELL YEAH
TERMS OF THAT IN THE RIGHT
THERE DOCTOR YOU THINK. ADAM I
I'M CAROL QUICKLY. AND CONTROL
PANEL AND THEN NUMBER AND HAND
IN HAND AND I HAVE A NANNY AND
A HOUSE CLEANER AND MY MOTHER.
ONLINE YOU FONG. WHEN IT COMES.
I'M SORRY YOU NO NO MA'AM WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO DO WITH IT. I
MY NAME IS YEAH TO DO Y. I AM
NOT WHAT THE AND THEN WELL YOU
KNOW I WAS JUST IT AND I LIKE
IT ONE FOUR FIVE THEN THANK YOU
FOR THE. HELLO MY NAME. OKAY NO.
YEAH I'M THE MAN. NOW THAT
RUBIO. I KNOW THAT WILL BE LIKE
EVEN THE FINAL I THOUGHT THAN
BEFORE YEAH I'M AND MARK MAY
LACK ALI I'M GONNA BE OUT OF
DATE AND I'M. APPALLED SB. AND
THE ONLY. I AM AM A MEMBER OF
THE WORK AND I HATE THE BOARD
AND THE AB. WE SAT AT THE END.
BY NINETY NINE. HI. MARKET OKAY
I'M NOT ONE FOR YOUR NINE AB
MEMBERS MIGHT. AND YOUR IDEA
AND YEAH. FOR YOUR FROM ABOUT
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. MANY
ATTRACT ON. MORE THAN. I
REMEMBER HAVING DIFFICULTY WITH
THE HERE. AND I'M DRINKING YA
COME BACK ONE LAST LOOK BACK
LNS LAMENTS. ONE OF THE NUMBER.
YEAH YEAH HE- YEAH YOU GOT EVEN
BEFORE YOU DAUGHTER. BUT I
YOUNG I HAVE BEEN TO YOU AND
THEY YOU WHERE THEY. YEAH WHEN
I BUT IN ORDER NOT. IT WILL
LIKELY ON BE THOUGHT. THANK
BOTH WHEN THEY GET. WHY NOT LOW.
BUT I THINK ONE. A BY MAKING
THE NUMBER COUNTY AND I IT THE
WILL BE. THANK YOU. YEAH I THE
LAST. THANK YOU VERY. HAVING
THE- THERE YOU ARE OUR OUR
STANDARD- I LIVED IN PALO ALTO
AND EMPLOY A AND I SUPPORT AT
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN. YOU CAN
READ THE MAN THANK YOU I'M
GOING TO HOLD THE THAT CALL
RIGHT NOW SENATOR ROGER I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE. BUT WOULD
YOU PLEASE HOLD THE COALS.
WE'RE I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
SOME PEOPLE THAT WANTED TO
SPEAK NO I UNDERSTOOD THAT
THERE'S OTHERS- WAITING THERE'S
LIKE TEN OR TWELVE OTHER PEOPLE
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
I DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER TWELVE
THOSE WOULD BE YOUR HOW TO GET
THOSE THAT IS AT A PARTICULAR
TWELVE YOU'RE LOOKING TO SPEAK.
NO NO NO. TO JUST LET THEM
SPEAK OKAY. THE PROBLEM
MODERATOR COULD YOU PUT THOSE
PEOPLE IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
THE TWELVE PEOPLE THAT
UNDERSTAND WANTED TO SPEAK. YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF. MY TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD SEVEN. HI THIS IS DEVIN
MEN CAN WITH VOICES FOR
PROGRESS CLEAR AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. NINE
THREE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS WROTE ON BEHALF
OF PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES AND
CALIFORNIANS WERE HEALTHY AND
GREEN ECONOMY AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
THEY WILL ENSURE DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND THEY WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS ARE NO LONGER. NEEDED
I'M WORKING PROTECTIONS AND
HAVING PROACTIVE. SAFER
CONDITIONS THANK. NINE SEVENTY
SIX LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE ON
YOUR MIND SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS- GREEN I'M
FREE FROM WORK STATE AND- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THE TOP OF
THE SEVEN THANK YOU. NINE TO
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JESSICA BY PHONE TO
LET YOU CLARA MOM POVERTY IN
SUPPORT OF THE LACKEY OCCURS
AND THE PEOPLE THAT. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME BUT I'M NOT
BAD AND I AM THE LORD. YEAH
WHILE. SENATE THANK YOU NINE
THREE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHICH DUGGAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND
THREE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BREAKING NEWS HERE WITH A
GARMENT WORKER CENTER LOS
ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE THREE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I MERRY GO
YOSHIHARA WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE PORT THANK
YOU. NINE THREE ZERO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE NINE THREE ZERO SEVEN.
NINE TWO NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE CUSTOMER ON BEHALF
OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE AND A
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. MINE THREE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NAY BAYARDO WITH YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WOULD YOU LIKE
SEVENTY ONE YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES AND CALL THE SUPPORTERS A
ONE MORE TIME PLEASE. THANK
YOU. AND IF YOU DO WISH TO
SUPPORT. SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND MY TWO SEVENTY ONE
ONE MOMENT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT AFTER THAT AMERICAN OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE THREE
ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS CHRISTINE ABOUT HIM
OKAY WOULD YOU DO W. UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS WHO ARE ALSO
NOT COVERED UNDER CAL OSHA WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH- THANK
YOU- MODERATOR HOW MANY COKE
LUNCH WE HAVE A STILL ON THE
CALL. THE COMMENT QUEUE IS
CLOSED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT
WAS. THERE'S NO TIME SO THANK
YOU WE WERE EXTENDED THE TIME I
WANTED TO ALLOW FOR THE
TRANSLATIONS TO BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE THAT AWAY
FROM FROM THE GROUP SO I ADDED
THAT TO IT SO WHAT WE ONE HOUR-
FRIEDMAN HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORTERS WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS TO HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. TO SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
SEEN NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN TWENTY FORTY. TWO
SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN SEEN AND
NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO WITH THIS
JUST WAITING TO TESTIFY BE THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. CAN WE ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME-
IT VARIATION IN POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. THEN WE WILL ALLOW
TEN MINUTES OF TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU DO HAVE AND-
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME FOR COMMON. WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY COMMENTS FOR
OPPOSITE THIS. IF YOU COULD
JUST CALL AS- OF LATE ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU. AND IF THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION COMMENTS FOR SB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN. PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT TO MAKE YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT TO GOOD
WORK- THANK YOU TO ALL THE
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS. MEMBERS OF
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR
FOR ACTION AND THEN VICE CHAIR
MORAL YOU KNOW I THOUGHT I'D
LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF HOW IT
IS THAT WE HAVE EXEMPTED
EXCEPT- DOMESTIC WORKERS FOR
MANY OF THE PROTECTIONS AND IT
REALLY. WHEN IT CAME DOWN TO
THE SOUTH. OF THE NOTION THAT
THEY WOULD NOT AGREE TO I DON'T
KNOW IF WAS THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT OR WHATEVER BUT- THE IS
THIS REALLY WAS IN. TOTALLY
RACIALLY MOTIVATED AT THE TIME
AND IT'S BEEN PERPETUATED OVER
THE COURSE OF YEARS. SO IAGREE
THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE THAT I
DO THINK THOUGH THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN GOING TO THIS AS WELL SO.
I'M GONNA SUPPORTED OF BIG- ON
PRINCIPLES MATTER POLICY BUT I
DO THINK THERE ARE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT NEED TO
BE- INCLUDED IN THIS WHOLE
PROCESS GOING FORWARD SO. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR ON THAT- BUT-
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS READING
ABOUT THIS NOT TOO LONG AGO
THIS IS JUST THE WAS SUCH A
BLATANTLY RACIST COMPROMISE-
BECAUSE MOST OF THE- DOMESTIC
WORKERS WERE BLACK. WOMEN
PRIMARILY IN THE SOUTH WHO WERE
COOKS AND TAKEN CARE OF WHY
PEOPLE'S CHILDREN AND- THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE THEM THE
STATURE. GOD THAT THE OTHER
EMPLOYEES WERE GIVEN SO AS A AS
AS A WAY TO TRY TO ADDRESS AN
INEQUITY THAT HAS GONE ON FOR
FAR TOO LONG RIGHT I AM GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SO. BASED MERLE. THANK YOU.
CENTER ALSO I WOULD JUST HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE I I'M-
TRYING TO. GET A BETTER HANDLE
ON US WOULD WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. AFFECT PART
TIME BABYSITTERS LIKE MAYBE A
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR OUT WOULD
FALL UNDER THAT CATEGORY. NO I
MEAN YOU HAVE TO BE A- AN
EMPLOYEE BUT IF I COULD HAVE
THE- WE CAN HAVE THE- OUR
EXPERT. WITNESS. ERA OF FOR
SURE ANSWER ON THAT SHOULD
LARA'S AS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND
NO. NO UP BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THERE S THERE ANYONE IN
PARTICULAR YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CALL SENATOR DORADO VISIT MISS
ORTEZ. YEAH SHE'S. YEAH THEY
WOULD NOT. IT DOES NOT INCLUDE-
LIKE PART TIME BABYSITTERS
TEENAGE BABYSITTERS HI. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YES SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO- FOR
HIS BILL FORD- I UNDERSTAND
THAT. SO I GUESS THE QUESTION
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HERE
IS THAT- CERTAINLY. TERMS ARE
JUST EXEMPTING HOUSEHOLD
DOMESTIC- SERVICE. DOES THIS
PROBLEMATIC AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S SOME USE EXAMPLES THAT
YOU GET FOR EXAMPLE LIKE IN A
DISASTER THAT THEY CAN'T
EVACUATE SO THAT SOUNDS PRETTY
STRAIGHT FOR BUT I GUESS THE
OTHER I DO WANNA TRY UNDERSTAND
SORT OF WHAT THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL WOULD BE- SINCE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WORKING
INSIDE HOMES SO- DOES CAL OSHA
CURRENTLY HAVE STANDARDS FOR
RESIDENTS THE FOR RESIDENTIAL
HOMES AND WOULD INVOLVE FOR
EXAMPLE REQUIRING. A HOMEOWNER
TO HAVE TO I GUESS A YELL
REDESIGN THE STAIRS OR SOME ANY
I GUESS THE QUESTION YEAH SO DO
YOU THE INTELLIGENCE USED TO
DEALING WITH WORKPLACES SIDE SO
YES SENSE OF WHAT WE'RE AT WILL
BOB WHAT IS- WHERE THE
BOUNDARIES ARE FOR CAL OSHA DO
THEY HAVE STANDARDS FOR
RESIDENTIAL HOMES ARE YOU
EXPECTING THEM TO DEVELOP THEM
AND- SO WHAT ARE AND WHAT WOULD
BE THE SCOPE OF THOSE TYPES OF
REGULATIONS SO I AM HERE VIEWS
TALK ABOUT AIR QUALITY AND-
YEAH YOU TALKED ABOUT. CO THE
MAKER OF IT'S ALWAYS THE NOW
BUT THERE ARE YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES YOU CAN HAVE OTHER
PEOPLE IT WAS A OF KIDS AND-
VOTERS WAIT THEY DON'T GET
VACCINATED IN MY GET CHICKENPOX
OKAY HOPE THEY ARE VACCINATED.
AND ACTUALLY MAYBE IF THE
REQUIRED KIDS GET VACCINATED
THAT MIGHT BE GOOD THANKS- THE
OF A DOMESTIC WORKER BUT- BUT I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE SO WHAT KIND
OF. THAT WHAT IS THE CURRENT
STATUS IN TERMS OF SO YOU'RE
SAYING OKAY CAL OSHA STANDARDS
AT THE PLIGHT. THEN IF THIS
BILL SHOULD PASS AND THE LAW.
WHAT THEN HAPPENS IN TERMS OF.
IN TERMS OF SETTING
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE- THAT THE
FOR THE EMPLOYERS TO THEY ARE
WORK AND FOR THESE EMPLOYEES
ARE WORKING INSIDE SOMEONE'S
HOME. AND IT IS A WORKPLACE
THAT WE WANT TO SHOW THEIR SAFE
BUT WHAT WHAT EXACTLY WOULD BE
THE EXTENT. OF THE REQUIREMENTS
ON. THE EMPLOYER NOT ONLY YOUR
TERMS OF HAVING TO CHANGE
STRUCTURES OR OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS. WELL AS I UNDERSTAND IT
CAL OSHA IS A COMPLAINT DRIVEN
AGENCIES SO- THEY WILL. NOT
JUST GO OUT. TO HOMES AND CHECK
YOU OUT AND SEE WHAT ARE YOUR
YOU KNOW HEALTH AND SAFETY YOU
KNOW CONDITIONS- WHAT CAL OSHA
WILL DO IS ISSUE THE GUIDANCE.
FOR THAT INDUSTRY. SO THEY'LL
COME UP WITH AND THEY'LL WORK
WITH DOMESTIC WORK. WITH YOUR
WORK EMPLOYERS. UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW THEY WORK
TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY YOU KNOW
WHAT OTHER COMMON HAZARDS- HOW
TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO CORRECT
THE HAZARD. THEY'LL WORK WITH-
WORKERS ALSO ON THE WORKERS
SIDE- WITH TRAINING AND TOOLS
TO PREVENT INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES IN THE WORKPLACE. SO
THEIR WHOLE PURPOSE OF HAVING
CAL OSHA IS TO HELP BOTH THE
EMPLOYERS. AND THE WORKERS BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY ARE THERE
PARTICULAR WAYS THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT KIND OF CLEANING YOU KNOW.
LIQUIDS AND WHICH ONES ARE SAFE
AND WHICH ONES ARE AND HOW DO
YOU USE THEM- SO THAT'S THE
WHOLE POINT OF HAVING AN
AGENCY. BE ABLE TO GUIDE. THE
EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS AS THE
THEM DOMESTIC WORKERS SO THEY
KOW WHAT'S SAFE AND WHAT WHAT
IS IT. AND IF THERE IS A
PARTICULAR COMPLAINT WHICH IS
OF. A VERY SPECIFIC TO THAT
LOCATION THEN THEY'LL GO OUT
AND AGAIN THEY'LL TRY TO FIGURE
OUT. WHAT HAPPENED WHAT'S THE
ISSUE HOW DO YOU CORRECTED HOW
DO YOU. BECAUSE THE WHOLE POINT
IS TO HAVE BETTER WORKING
CONDITIONS AS NOT TO. YOU KNOW
JUST GO AFTER AN EMPLOYER SO
THAT'S HOW I UNDERSTAND THAT I
DON'T KNOW MR DEES IF YOU CAN
ADD ANYTHING TO THAT. SENATOR
GLASS SO YOU YOU GOT IT
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND I THINK
JUST TO GIVE A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
FOR WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE WERE
AND MERGING KEY STANDARDS THAT
CALLOSUM PASSED. FOR EXAMPLE
WITH ALL THE RECENT WILDFIRES.
THE BEST WORKERS ARE NOT
COVERED. UNDER ANY OF THOSE
STANDARDS- IN TERMS OF BEING
EXPOSED TO SMOKE FOR EXAMPLE-
OR EVEN HAPPY SO- WHEN THEY'RE
THEY ARE WORKING THEN
EVACUATION DOLLARS. THIS REALLY
IS ABOUT HOW DO WE ISSUE
GUIDANCE. TO EMPLOYERS TO WHAT
THEY HAVE THOSE SO CALLED TO
UNDERSTAND OUR OBLIGATIONS THIS
IS NOT ABOUT SENDING PEOPLE TO
KNOCK ON PEOPLE'S DOORS. OKAY
NINE I GET THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE
AREN'T GOING. TO BASICALLY EN
MASSE GOING BUT WHEN SOMEONE
FILES A COMPLAINT. THEN SOMEONE
IS. COMING INTO SOMEONE'S HOME
AND SAYING. WE NEED SO RIGHT SO
YOU NEED TO THE HEALTH ACCESS
OR SOMETHING. FIRST THERE WILL
BE A PHONE CALL AND OR EMAIL-
AND THEN IT WILL MOVE FROM
THERE AND IT IS THAT WE'RE
GRANT THAT'S YET TO BE DESIGN
SO JUST LIKE WITH AGRICULTURE.
THERE'S GONNA BE A YOU KNOW OUT
REACH PROGRAM THAT'S GOOD THAT
YOU KNOW EDUCATE AND INFORM
BOTH THE EMPLOYER- AND THE
WORKERS ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS AND
OBLIGATIONS. SO I DON'T THINK
THAT WE SHOULD EXPECT THAT.
WELL I AM AT NAY A. B. HELPFUL
THAT ARE MORE BOUNDARIES ARE
DEFINITIONS. HERE BECAUSE.
RIGHT NOW JUST AS WITH THE LEAD
AT. AND WE ARE TO AMIN THIS IS
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN-
SOMEONE'S RESIDENTS BECAUSE THE
AND SO IT'S NOT. I GUESS. TERMS
OF THE NATURE OF THE WORKPLACE
ITSELF I GUESS WE CAN SAY THAT
IF YOU HIRE ANYONE TO WORK IN
YOUR HOUSE I THINK IT GOES TO
THE NOTED THAT THE NOW YOU
BECOME A WORKPLACE SO. MAYBE IT
IS I GOT TO GET BUT IT BUT I'M
NOT SURE IT WAS GOING TO VIEW
IT THAT WAY AND WHAT I'M YOU
KNOW THE CONCERN WOULD BE. ALSO
IS THAT- IF. SOMEONE'S HOME- IS
VIEWED AS BASICALLY A PUBLIC
SPACE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
BUSINESSES ARE AT LEAST DOWN ON
TIGHTLY PUBLIC BUT SOME
SOMEWHAT MORE PUBLIC THAN OF
SOMEONE'S RESIDENTS- THEN WOULD
THAT ALSO BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
THAT PEOPLE TO DRIVE THIS
UNDERGROUND RIGHT AND- AND WE
CAN MAKE IT MORE PROBLEMATIC AS
WELL. SO BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT INVASION OF
PRIVACY RIGHTS SO SOMEONE DID
THEIRWORK AND COMPLAINS CAL
OSHA MASON AN EMAIL OR PHONE
CALL BUT NAY EVENTUALLY SHOW UP
AND SAY HEY I WANT SPEC THE
HOUSE. RIGHT AND- AND TRIGGER A
BUNCH OF THINGS RELATED TO THAT
SO IT SO I THINK OF. BE HELPFUL.
TO FIGURE OUT. SOME BROWN TO OR
SOME GUIDANCE THE CALLOW RIGHT
YOU SAID TO SOME OF THAT HAVE
TO BE DEVELOPED BECAUSE IN IN
RELATION TO THE FACT THAT WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE'S
HOMES THAT THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO
HIRE SOMEONE- TO WORK THERE SO
THAT YOU KNOW IN SOME SENSES
STATE THE TO MAKE THAT DECISION
BUT WHAT EXACTLY WOULD BE THE
PARAMETERS UNDER WHICH CAL OSHA
WOULD BE ABLE TO OPERATE IN
TERMS OF- BOTH ASSURING THAT
WORKER SAFETY WHILE ALSO
ENSURING THE PRIVACY OF THE
HOMEOWNER AND IT WILL BE OURS
SO STRIKING THE BALANCE THERE.
WELL AT. WELL FIRST OF ALL
THERE'S ALREADY A RELATIONSHIP
THERE BECAUSE YOU'RE AN
EMPLOYER IN YOUR SUBJECT TO
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME SO
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN OVER MANY
YEARS THAT YOU KNOW SLOWLY
ADDING MORE AND MORE TO THAT
WHAT THAT RELATIONSHIP IS GOING
TO BE IT SHOULD BE EVEN THOUGH
IT'S YOUR HOME IT SHOULD BE UP
THE LOSSES IS THERE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP SO THAT'S
ALREADY THERE REGARDLESS OF
ADDING BOMB- CAL OSHA- BUT
AGAIN I THINK THE WHOLE IDEA IS
WE HAVE TO GIVE CAL OSHA THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THE EXPERTS THEY KNOW
WHAT'S- WHAT'S SAFE THEY KNOW
WHAT'S HARMFUL THEY KNOW WHAT
ISN'T- AND WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY DEVELOP THOSE
GUIDANCE SO I THINK THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHERE IS THE
SCOPE OF WHAT WILL THEY COVER
HOW WILL THEY DO IT WILL COME
IN THAT PROCESS TO ALLOW CASH
CAL OSHA TO THE- DEVELOP THAT
PROCESS AND COME UP WITH MORE
PARTICULARS I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
COULD. DEVELOP THOSE
PARTICULARS AT THIS POINT OTHER
THAN TO AS CAL OSHA'S THEIR
AGENCY GIVE IT TO THEM TO
FIGURE OUT THE DETAILS OF IT
YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
THEIR WHOLE POINT WELL IN THE
ABSENT FISHINGGOLDENSON OUT
BASICALLY I THINK I THINK MY
CONCERN IS THAT. IT'S NOT A
TYPICAL WORKPLACE AND- YES THE
COLLEGE YOU WILL FIGURE OUT THE
DETAILS BUT WE MIGHT WANT TO
PUT SOME GUIDANCE INTO THIS
BECAUSE OF THE FACT RECOGNIZING
THAT THIS WORK PLACES ALSO
SOMEONE'S RESIDENTS AND THERE
ARE SOME THERE MAY BE SOME
PRIVACY OTHER TYPES OF ISSUES
INVOLVED IN TERMS OF HAVING
INSPECTORS SOMEONE GOING INTO
THE HOME THAT MAY NOT QUITE BE
THE SAME AS SOMEONE GOING TO
WORKPLACE HIM WHAT WHAT YOU GET
PAID IN YOUR HOURS AND SO
FORTH- THAT THAT'S THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARY GET INTO THE DETAILS
OF SOMEONE ELSE'S LIFE BUT
SOMEONE WALKING AROUND THE
HOUSE AND- THE EVENTUALLY TO
SAY WELL OOK THE STRUCTURALLY
WHATEVER ELSE BUT THEY'RE ALSO
LOOKING OUT OF THINGS TO. MADE
MAYBE BLOW. MORE CONCERNING FOR
SOME THAT IN TERMS. WHAT'S
HAPPENING AROUND HOMES I JUST I
THINK WE JUST WE TO RECORD.
THAT BECAUSE IT IS SOMEONE'S
HOUSE THAT IS THAT THE WORKING
AND. SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU AS I JUST LISTEN TO DOCTOR
PAN AYE THIS KIND OF BEGAN TO
MAKE A NOTE OF AYE OF ACTIONS
WE'VE TAKEN WHERE PEOPLE RUN
BUSINESSES OUT OF THEIR HOME
FAMILY CHILDCARE DSS HAS TO
INSPECT FOSTER CARE WE ARE IN
HEALTH COMMITTEE A COUPLE YEARS
AGO YOU KNOW WHEN TO THIS WHOLE
PROCESS OF KIND OF REGULATING
ALLOW PEOPLE TO COOK FOOD IN
THEIR HOME AND SELL IT AND
THERE WAS AN ISSUE AROUND
INSPECTING THE LOCATIONS FOR
THE SAFETY AND SO I HEAR YOU IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW PRIVACY BUT
IF YOU MAKE THE DECISION TO
EMPLOY SOMEONE TO COME INTO THE
HOME. BUT I THINK YOU HAVE TO
STEP UP TO. BE A REASONABLE
EMPLOYER. I THINK IT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
WOULD BE IN OUR IN IN THE
COLLECTIVE BEST INTEREST IF WE
WERE THAT PRESCRIPTIVE IN
LEGISLATION THIS BILL OR ANY
OTHER B. L. BUT TO ALLOW CAL
OSHA. THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
UP WITH A FRAMEWORK THAT MAKES
SENSE I DO THINK THAT THAT
WOULD PROBABLY BE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT ENTITY TO
DO THAT. VERSUS US TRY TO DO IT
IN THE CONTENT OF THE BILL
ITSELF. BUT I JUST I JUST AS I
LISTEN TO HAVE THAT WILL THERE
IN ANY NUMBER OF OTHER
EXAMPLES- THAT WE'VE ALREADY
SORT OF CROSS THE LINE. IN
TERMS OF GOVERNMENT ENTITIES-
IT'LL REGULATING- UP IN SOME
WAY INSPECTING PRIVATE
RESIDENCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL AND- THE FOR THE
COMMENT ARE. I OF. EIGHT YOU
KNOW I JUST I THINK THE EFFORT
THE ENERGY AND CERTAINLY THE
COMMITMENT THAT YOU MADE TO
THIS ISSUE AND IT DEFINITELY
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED THERE ARE
SOME CHALLENGES HERE WE WANT TO
PROTECT THOSE WORKERS BECAUSE-
IT'S SO OFTEN AND I THINK. THAT
THE STORIES WE'VE HEARD OVER
THE YEARS ARE JUST NOT VERY.
NOT VERY GOOD- DAR POSITIVE BUT
THEIR EYES HAVE YOU'VE HEARD
THERE ARE A LOT OF CHALLENGES
WITH A WITH THE BILL THAT- AND
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS WE
DON'T KEEP TRACK OF WHO'S AN
EMPLOYER IN THE INDUSTRY- AND
SO HOW CAN WE EXPECT THE STATE
TO DO THAT IT IN. ITS COMPLAINT
BASED THAT WE PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS WHILE ENSURING
DOMESTIC WORKERS RIGHTS AND
SAFETY AND THAT- THE
ENFORCEMENT IN A PRIVATE HOME-
IT SHOULD JUST BE EITHER A LOT
OF THINGS IN HERE THAT ARE
CHALLENGING AND I WOULD. I
WOULD THINK THAT WE CAN GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS SAY THEY GET AN
APPROPRIATION I BELIEVE LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET TO. LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE AND TRY TO DETERMINE A
WAY TO CREATE MORE AWARENESS
AND COMPLIANCE WITH THE LABOR
PROTECTIONS THAT AFFECT THE
DOMESTIC WORKER INDUSTRY- SO I
COMMEND YOU FOR THIS I WILL BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY- AND- BUT- IF. IT WILL
NEED SOME. BEFORE AND SOME REAL
TO FIND. THAT I THINK WE CAN
CLEARLY GET OUR ARMS AROUND-
BEFORE- I COULD SUPPORT ON THE
FLOOR. THAT IS WHAT I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO DO THAT SENATOR PAN OKAY
AND I JUST WANT TO DO THAT. IN
A PRICE SIX SOMETHING SIMILAR I
KNOW YOUR HEARTS IN THE RIGHT
PLACE AND SO FORTH I. WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE MORE WORK
HAPPEN UNLESS AND WE GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSER TO DRUGS OF THIS TIME TO
VOTE I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR
SUGGESTIONS ARE APPRECIATED
THANK YOU- IS THERE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. A MOTION BY SENATOR
JACKSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO
VOTE HELLO HI CENTER HILL HI
SENATOR MOREAU. SENATOR JACKSON
HI SENATOR JACKSON HI SENATOR
MITCHELL HI SENATOR MITCHELL HI
SENATOR PAN HI SENATOR PAN HI
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES ITSELF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN A MOVE
TO SENATOR TRACTION SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. PLEASE PROCEED AT
YOUR CONVENIENCE THANK YOU SIR
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING FORWARD SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THIS IS A BILL
THAT I HAVE INTRODUCED IN
RESPONSE TO THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC. ALONG WITH FACING THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND ECONOMIC
ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PANDEMIC THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE ALSO FACING
THE DEVASTATING IMPACT OF
SCHOOL CLOSURES ON THEIR
ABILITY TO KEEP THEIR JOBS AND
BALANCE WORK AND FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES NOT THE LEAST
OF WHICH IS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO EDUCATE THEIR
CHILDREN- POTENTIALLY WITHOUT
AN EDUCATION DEGREE OR TEACHING
CREDENTIAL- ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS AND
ANOTHER 70% OF CHILD CARE
CENTERS HAVE CLOSED. AND THIS
IS FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
AND EVEN IF THEY DO OPEN THERE
IS AN EXPECTATION THAT IF THERE
IS A SPIKE OR ANOTHER SURGE
WHICH IS ALSO VERY MUCH A
POSSIBILITY- THOSE STAYED HOME
ORDERS WILL BE. PUT BACK IN
PLACE SO THESE CURRENT ORDERS
ARE PREVENTING PERRANCE FROM
BEING ABLE TO CALL ON EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS SUCH AS
GRANDPARENTS OR BABYSITTERS FOR
BACKUP CHILDCARE PARENTS ARE
ALSO BEING ASKED TO ACT AS I
MENTION IS THEIR CHILDREN'S
TEACHERS. BY FACILITATING
DISTANCE LEARNING DALY SCHOOL
ASSIGNMENTS THAT THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO- PRODUCE AND TO
ASSIST THEIR CHILDREN IN
PRODUCING AND LET'S FACE IT TO
CULTURAL EXPECTATIONS ARE THESE
BURDENS FALL MOST HEAVILY ON
MOTHER'S I'M NOT SAYING DAD'S
DON'T HELP- BUT THEY DO
HISTORICALLY AND CULTURALLY
TEND TO FALL ON MOTHERS. WOMEN
HAVE ALSO MADE UP 60% OF THE
JOB LOSSES IN THIS CRISIS AND
THEIR JOB LOSSES HAVE
OUTNUMBERED MAN'S IN NEARLY
EVERY SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY SO
WOMEN ARE NOW
DISPROPORTIONATELY LEFT WITH NO
CHOICE TO GIVE THEIR JOBS TO
PROVIDE CARE. WITH NO GUARANTEE
OF AN OPPORTUNITY TO RETURN AND
LEAVING THE JOB MARKET WE KNOW
CAN HAVE LASTING IMPACT ON
WOMEN'S CAREER TRAJECTORIES
WAGERS. AND THOSE FURTHER
FURTHERING THE GENDER WAGE GAP
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE ALL
TRYING TO. REDUCE AND ELIMINATE.
SO ALL OF THIS IS PLACING AN
EXTRAORDINARY STRAIN ON WORKING
FAMILIES AND LAYING BARE THE
SIGNIFICANT WEAKNESSES IN OUR
LEAVE LOSS. AT A TIME OF
UNPRECEDENTED JOB LOSS WE
SHOULD NOT LET INADEQUATE LEAVE
LAWS FORCE MORE PARENTS INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THEY CANNOT
KEEP THEIR JOBS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN CARING
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. AND GOING
TO WORK IT'S IN THIS CONTEXT
THAT I BRING FORWARD THIS BILL
WHICH STRENGTHENS THE UNPAID.
UNPAID JOB PROTECTED PROTECTED
TIME AVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIANS
AS A RESULT OF SCHOOL IN
CHILDCARE CLOSURE EMERGENCIES
THROUGH A LAW THAT IS KNOWN AS
THE CHILD OF THE SCHOOL FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP PACKED. THERE WERE
A FEW YEARS AGO I AUTHORED A
BILL THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
TO INCLUDE SCHOOL IN CHILDCARE
A MERCHANT SEES AS ELIGIBLE
REASONS FOR USING TIME UNDER
THE SCHOOL FAMILY PARTNERSHIP
ACT. TO GIVE ALL WORKING
PARENTS TIME TO ADDRESS
UNFORESEEN EMERGENCIES THAT
PROHIBIT THE CHILD FROM
ATTENDING SCHOOL ARE GOING TO
CHILD CARE THIS MEASURE
STRENGTHENS THE FAMILY SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIP BACK TO DO THREE
THINGS. FIRST IT WILL CLARIFY
THAT A SCHOOL CLOSURE PURSUANT
TO A STATE OF EMERGENCY
DECLARATION. FEDERAL STATE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENTS
QUALIFIES AS AN EMERGENCY THIS
INCLUDES STATE OF EMERGENCY
DECLARED AS A RESULT OF COURSE
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BUT ALSO EMERGENCIES AS A LOOK
ASSOCIATED WITH THINGS LIKE
WILD FIRES AND EARTHQUAKES.
SECOND IT WILL PROVIDE WORKING
PARENTS THE ABILITY TO TAKE
UNPAID JOB PROTECTED LEAVE FOR
THE DURATION OF THE SCHOOL OR-
CARE A MARGIN AND NOT SHOW
STILL A MINUTE. HOURS CURRENT A
LAW UNDER STATE LAW. FAR
BECAUSE THE MORE NEVER SPENT
ANY OF US. THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
CAL. TO TAKE SHARPER TECH.
UNPAID TIME OFF TO CARE FOR
THEIR CHILDREN SCHOOL CHILDCARE.
BARTLET'S OF THEIR EMPLOYERS.
NACHOS THOSE WHO WORK AND- WITH
TWENTY FIVE OR MORE EMPLOYEES.
AND WITHOUT THE CHANGE MANY
PARENTS PUT. THOSE WHO WORK
HOURS JOB AND WHO ARE FROM LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME BACKGROUNDS
WILL BE LEFT WITH A HOBSON'S
CHOICE. THE CHOICE OF CHOOSING
BETWEEN THEIR CHILDREN- THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND THEIR ABILITY TO
KEEP THEIR JOB TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS AND OTHERWISE MAKE ENDS
MEET. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO ADDRESS CONCERNS.
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AT A AT A
LATE MOMENT AND I RECOGNIZE WE
ARE IN A VERY- CONSOLIDATED
PERIOD- I AM HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE- ENTITIES WHOSE OPPOSITION
WE WOULD TRUST WE JUST
RECEIVED. THE CHAMBER AND THE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION ABOUT
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL. I'M
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THEM I APPRECIATE THEIR INPUT-
THIS BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS GOING FORWARD. SO
IN CLOSING THE GOVERNOR OFFERED
TALKS ABOUT RISING TO MEET THE
MOMENT IN THIS SPACE MEETING
THE MOM. AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT THIS MOMENT CREATES THIS
IS A PANDEMIC THIS MOMENT IS
UNDERSCORED THE CRITICAL NEED
TO STRENGTHEN OUR LEAVE LAWS
FOR PLANNING FOR COUNTLESS
OTHER EMERGENCIES THAT COULD
RESULT- BASED UPON JUST
CALIFORNIA'S VERY NATURE BEING
EARTHQUAKE WRITTEN- WILDFIRES
FLOODS. AND OF COURSE THE
POTENTIAL- THAT WE WILL SEE
OTHER PANDEMICS BEYOND- THE
CRISIS WE'RE DEALING WITH NOW.
THAT COULD RESULT IN SCHOOL AND
DAY CLERK AT DAYCARES CLOSURES
LIKE THIS IN THE FUTURE AND
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. I KNOW
THAT JOINING ME REMOTELY- TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
KATIE WITCHER TO AN ATTORNEY
WITH LEGAL AID AT WORK- THE
ENTITY. IS SPONSORING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. PLEASE SERVICE
WHICH IT PLAY PROCEED. IN YOUR
COMMENT YOU HAVE THREE UP TO
THREE MINUTES. AND I'M A STAFF
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT WORK A
CROWD SPONSOR OF SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. LEGALLY AT WORK
AT THE NONPROFIT THAT FIGHT FOR
THE RIGHTS OF LOW WAGE WORKERS
ARE WORKING FAMILY PROGRAM MUST
BE CALLED FROM OVER A THOUSAND
FAMILY PER YEAR WHO ARE DEALING
WITH A FAMILY OR MEDICAL
CRISIS. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THEY CAN HEAR FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY
WITHOUT LOSING THEIR JOB AND
THEIR INCOME. MARCH MANY OF THE
CALLS WE RECEIVED BANNED FROM
PARENTS. WHOSE CHILDREN SCHOOL
EVERY DAY CARES THE CLOSED. DUE
TO THE CUP IN NINETEEN RIGHT
THAT. WE HEARD FROM ONE MOTHER
WORKING FOR A RESTAURANT CHAIN.
FOUR DAUGHTERS WERE WITHOUT
CARE BECAUSE THEIR SCHOOL HAD
CLOSE. SHE AFTER EMPLOYER FOR
TIME OFF TO CARE FOR THEM IN
THE TOLD THAT IF SHE TOOK A DAY
OFF SHE WOULD BE FIRED. EVERY
SINGLE PARENT AND THE PHONE
PROVIDER FOR HER FAMILY SHE WAS
DEVASTATED. BY IT WHAT CHOICE
DID SHE HAVE SHE COULDN'T LEAVE
HER CHILDREN ALONE AT HOME.
SIMILARLY BUT WE HEARD FROM A
FATHER WHO CALLED BECAUSE AFTER
A FOR A LOT OF. HIS EMPLOYER
WITH ASKING HIM TO COME BACK TO
WORK BUT HE HAD NO ONE TO WATCH
IT THEY WILL SIGN BECAUSE HIS
UNCLE HADN'T YET REOPENED. WE
ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF MANY
THAT WE'VE HEARD WITHIN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS. PANDEMIC A
CLOSE CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND
DAYCARES AND MADE IT UNSAFE FOR
EXTENDED FAMILY OR OTHER DAY
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE BACK UP
HERE. IN THE CALIFORNIA PARENTS
OF SMALL CHILDREN HAVE HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO PROVIDE THAT CARE.
BUT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THE
CALIFORNIA AN ADEQUATE
PROTECTION THESE PARENTS CHOICE
THE- CHOICE AND NOT LEAVE SMALL
CHILDREN UNATTENDED AT HOME.
CAN RESULT IN THE LOSS OF THEIR
JOBS. THIS BILL WOULD PREVENT
THAT THE WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEXT GENERATION
MATTERS TO ALL OF US AND THAT'S
WHY WE MUST ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN TO RECEIVE THE
ADEQUATE CARE THAT THEY NEED.
IT DOESN'T DEPEND ON THE SIZE
OF THEIR PARENTS EMPLOYER. AND
SOMETIMES THAT CAN LAST FOR
MORE THAN FORTY HOURS. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL
ALLOW PARENTS TO TAKE UNPAID
TIME OFF WITHOUT LOSING THEIR
JOBS WHEN AN EMERGENCY CLOSE
WITH THEIR CHILD'S SCHOOL OR
DAYCARE OR REQUIRES THAT THE
TRIAL BE PICKED UP FROM SCHOOL
OR DAYCARE. NO MATTER THE SIZE
OF THEIR EMPLOYER IN FOR THE
DURATION OF THE EMERGENCY THAT
CREATES THAT NIGHT. WE CAN'T
ALWAYS PREDICT AN EMERGENCY AND
PARENTS NEED THE PROTECTION NOW
AND FOR WHEN THE NEXT DISASTER
STRIKES. ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
FOR STABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES. IN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY- TRIBUTE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE TESTIMONY OF WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO. ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THREE NO
ONE WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. SHE NO
ONE THERE THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY BE
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR PLEASE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WISHING TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF
SEVENTY ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATOR MY NAME WITH THE
BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EDUCATED THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND FROM SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE TESTIMONY.
NINE TO SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BUT THAT CAN GONZALEZ
SPECIALIST THAT STATION THE
FIRST WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY A IN GRAND ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE TO SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BUT I THAT ALL
REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE FIFTY SEVEN HERE LINE IS
OPEN. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE NINE
THREE FIFTY SEVEN. NOW IT'S AT
THE CALIFORNIA AND I THINK
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN I
BAYARDO AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. NINE
THREE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MAY I HAVE THAT I AM A
MOM OF TWO KIDDOS AND I AM A
CONSTITUENT OF DISTRICT THIRTY
SEVEN AND I AM AND- APART.
THANK YOU YEAH. NINE THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PITCH TIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL TO
CHERRY BOMB HAPPENED A
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KEVIN INS CO FOR FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THREE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CATHERINE FAYE FOR CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NINE TWO NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
GUEST AND ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE SUMMER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR EGO YOSHIHARU BUT THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER TRADE THE
CALIFORNIA AND THE COURT THANK
YOU. MY TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SEVEN HI SEVEN MEN CAN
WITH PLACES FOR PROGRESS IN
SUPPORT. NINE THREE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE WATER BUT
THE CALIFORNIA OREGON FAMILY
COLLISION AND SUPPORT. MINE TO
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE BIKE ALONE SELECT PRINT AND
I'M ON POVERTY THE COURT.
TWENTY THREE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JUSTIN ROUSER ON
BEHALF OF GROUPS OF CHANGE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A MURDER
COULDYOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU. WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR AND
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS BUT HAVING COME OUT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. WE
APPRECIATE WHAT THE SENATORS
ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE AND
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND MANY
PARENTS ARE- DEALING WITH
SCHOOL IN CHILDCARE CLOSURES AT
THIS TIME- AS A SENATOR
INDICATED WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL WE HAD A GOOD VERY GOOD
MEETING WITH THE SENATOR'S
OFFICE ON MONDAY. IS TO POINT
OUT THIS BILL MAKES TO
PERMANENT CHANGES TO THE
ENTIRE. SECTION OF THE LABOR
CODE- DEALING WITH THE SCHOOL
RELATED. LEAVES THAT WE THINK
MAY BE BROADER THAN IS
NECESSARILY. NECESSARY TO DEAL
WITH THE CURRENT CRISIS OR- A
SIMILAR WILD FIRE ISSUES- IT
DOES REMOVE THE TWENTY FIVE OR
MORE EMPLOYEES THRESHOLD. IT
DOES SO FOR THIS ENTIRE LABOR
CODE SECTION NOT JUST THESE-
ADDITIONAL A STATE OF
EMERGENCIES AND IT REMOVES THE
FORTY HOUR CAP AGAIN FOR ALL.
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS NOT JUST-
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS SO. THE CURRENT
STATUTE DEFINES EMERGENCIES TO
INCLUDE DISCIPLINARY REASONS SO
THIS WOULD REMOVE THE FORTY
HOUR CAP FOR DISCIPLINARY
REASONS WHICH- WE DON'T
NECESSARILY THINK REQUIRES THE
SAME LEVEL- OF TIME. AS THE-
OTHER TYPES OF LEADS. JUST A
NOTE ON THE STATE OF
EMERGENCIES WE'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSION EARLIER- OFTEN THE
STATE EMERGENCIES ARE ON THE
BOOKS FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
SOME OF THE WILD FIRE STATE OF
EMERGENCIES FROM TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ARE STILL IN A FACT-
AND IN DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR
GOVERNOR NEWSOME JUST
TERMINATED SEVENTY- EMERGENCY
DECLARATIONS THAT HAD BEEN.
ONGOING SINCE- DATING BACK TO
TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN SO
SOMETIMES THESE EMERGENCIES
JUST STATE OPEN AND SO I DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT'S THE PROPER
METRIC WE SHOULD BE LOOKING OUT
HERE PERHAPS WE CAN LOOK AT.
WHEN THE SCHOOL CLOSURE- IS IN
DURATION RELATION TO THE THEY
EMERGENCY RATHER THAN THAT THE
DECLARATION ITSELF- SO WE WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS BASED ON ALL THE
PLETHORA OF LEAVE PROVISIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN ENACTED IN
RECENT WEEKS. AND MONTHS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL DEALING WITH SCHOOL
CLOSURES- IN MANY STE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WE HAVE SOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT- PENDING LEE
PROPOSALS IN THE ASSEMBLY AS
WELL. THAT WOULD COVER THIS
SITUATION AS WELL SO WEIRD WE
WANT TO FIND A WAY TO FIND OUT
HOW ALL THESE LEE PROVISIONS
ARE GOING TO INTERACT WITH EACH
OTHER- FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSE BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO A SB.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE SEE NO
ONE WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE SEEN NO ONE WE
WILL NOW THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE.
TO WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONE LINE SO- IF YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES IN CALL
OF THE OPPOSITION WINDOW
INDIVIDUALS- MODERATOR THANK
YOU. ONE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE OPPOSITION. THANK YOU CAN
JUST WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MAYBE JUST A
BRIEF MOMENT. LINE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
MAY BE AND I THOUGHT ABOUT I
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT ONLY IF
YOU'D LIKE YOU CAN G HERE TO
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
ARE WE ARE GOING TO COMMENT. ON
THE CHAMBER AND IN EVERY
APPLICATION. YEAH WELL. NINE
THREE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE ENTER MEMBERS
DAVID PRETTY GROUND AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS LOCATION-
IN OPPOSITION SB THIRTY. AND
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE THREE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS BRIAN
LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
ARTICULATED BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CHAMBER THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
COMMON. MOTOR YOU CAN YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO BE SURE WE HAVE HEARD
FROM ALL OF THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NO FOR THEIR
OPPOSITION COMMON THANK YOU
MODERATOR THANK YOU ALL THE
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. WHEN I BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I THINK COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS YES SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU CENTER- JACKSON-
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO. I GUESS MY CONCERN IS THAT-
THE SIZE OF THE BUSINESS SO
YOUR LIMINE TWENTY FIVE
ESSENTIALLY MAKING IT. SINCE
THE ONE. AND YOU KNOW MY FAMILY
WERE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS-
WHAT- WE'VE AT ONE POINT I HAD
A TIME WHERE WE HAD AN EMPLOYEE
WHO WAS OUT FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD TIME WHERE WE KEPT. THEM
PLEASE JOB OPEN WHILE THEY WERE
GONE IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT AND
VERY EXPENSIVE TO DO THAT- IT'S
NOT EASY BECAUSE THE PROBLEM IS
THAT WHEN SOMEONE IS OUT AND
YOU HOLD YOUR JOB. THEN YOU
CAN'T OFFER THE PERSON WHO'S
GONNA BE FILLING IN FOR THEM
ESPECIALLY THE SMALL BUSINESSES
THE MORE CRITICAL EVERYBODY IS.
TO BE ABLE TO SAY WELL I CAN
GIVE A JOB BECAUSE WHEN THAT
PERSON COMES BACK I CAN AFFORD
TO OF THEM I CAN ONLY AFFORD
ONE RIGHT SO THAT MEANS WHOEVER
YOU BRING IN IS CERTAINLY NOT
GONNA BE COMMITTED TO YOUR
BUSINESS. THEY'RE IN THERE TO
YOU KNOW THAT MEAN THEIR DOCTOR
TO WORK AND THEY'LL DO WHAT
THEY CAN BUT IT'S REALLY HARD
TO TRAIN THEM BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THEY'RE NOT STAYING IT'S REALLY
HARD TO RETAIN THEM BECAUSE AS
SOON AS THEY HAVE A JOB THAT'S
MORE PERMANENT THERE OFTEN GUY
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO FIND
SOMEONE ELSE. FOR NOW THE EVEN
SHRINKING DAY ON THAT THE
REMAINING TIME AT CETERA. SO
ANY I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND- IS
A- IS A- OF A FATHER AND
SOMEONE TO IN TERMS OF ON THE
OTHER SIDE- BUT ALSO WANTED.
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW THE LOW WE
WILL ONLY KEEPING THE JOB AS
LONG AS A BUSINESS STILL EXISTS
RIGHT AND I THINK WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE HELP THE
BUSINESSES TO ESPECIALLY START
GETTING SMALL SO MAYBE TWENTY
FIVE THEY CAN HANDLE IT I DON'T
KNOW MAYBE SMALLER BUT- I MEAN
WE START GETTING DOWN TO. LIKE
YOU JUST HAVE A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE AND DEPENDING ON WHAT
BUSINESS YOU'RE AND HEALTHIER
ONE THAT BRINGS A LITTLE MORE
REVENUE. MAYBE NOT SO MUCH OF
AN ISSUE BUT IT AGAIN IT. YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE A HOLE IN YOUR
STAFF AND THAT'S A CRITICAL AND
YOU HAVE A VERY SMALL STAFF
EVERYONE'S CRITICAL AND YOU TRY
YOU YOU TRY TO BE FLEXIBLE AND
SO FORTH. BUT CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP THE
BUSINESS ARE IS THERE SOME
OTHER THRESHOLD. MEANS REALLY
GOING TO BE DOWN THE ONE
BECAUSE I AM REALLY I AM
CONCERNED- AND ABOUT AND
CERTAINLY COVERT NOW IT'S MORE
BLANKET ACROSS EVERYONE BUT EAT
YOU KNOW EVEN BEYOND COVE IT.
KNOWING WHAT HOW HARD IT WAS
FOR A BUSINESS- FIRST HAND TO
TRY TO. CONTINUE TO STAFF A
POSITION WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
HOLD OPEN FOR SOMEONE TO KEEP
THEIR JOB HOW HARD IT WAS TO
ACTUALLY. DO THAT AND ALSO KIND
OF EXPENSIVE TO DO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO OFFER REGULATORY FIND A
TEMP AGENCY OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT AND WE JUST IT WAS REALLY
HARD TO TRY TO FIND. PEOPLE TO
FILL THAT POSITION SO CAN YOU
TO STRESS THANK YOU. WELL AGAIN
REMEMBER WE'RE TALKING A- IS.
OF THE- WARD. ABOUT A
CATASTROPHIC EVENT. WHETHER
IT'S LOCAL. STATEWIDE OR
NATIONAL SO WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING ABOUT A SITUATION WHERE
SOMEBODY- IT THE SAYS I NEED TO
TAKE SOME TIME OFF AND IT. IT'S
AN EXTENDED PERIOD TIME AND I'M
SYMPATHETIC TO AYE I ACTUALLY.
HAVE A SMALL BUSINESS I KNOW
WHAT IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU'VE GOT.
YOU'VE GOT A DOUBLE TIME FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S OUT. BUT WE'RE
TALKING NOW ABOUT SITUATIONS
WHERE SCHOOLS CLOSE WERE TO YOU
KNOW THIS ISN'T JUST THE- THE
BUT LIFE GOES ON TYPE OF THING
THAT CAN HAPPEN THIS IS A
CATACLYSMIC. EVENT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL COVERS. AND YOU KNOW IT AT
SOME POINT FRANKLY. IF WE HAVE
THIS UNIQUE SITUATION WHICH MAY
NOT. BE UNIQUE GOING FORWARD
DRAGGING A WE RECOGNIZE THERE
ARE VIRUSES AND- WE HAD SARS
AND WE HAD THE EACH ONE AND ONE
AND WE WERE LUCKY THERE TO. TO
CONTAIN THAT BUT THIS REALLY
DEALS WITH THE SITUATION WHERE
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED- AND PARENTS
ARE CHEST ON ABLE- OR WE ARE
FORCING THEM TO DECIDE THAT
THEY GO TO WORK. OR DO THEY
QUIT THEIR JOB AND STAY HOME
WITH THEIR KIDS AND THEN IF
THAT'S THE CASE. HOW TO THE
GOOD GET BACK INTO THE
WORKFORCE SO- CERTAINLY. HAPPY
TO CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION- ON
THE SIZE OF THIS BUT WHAT WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT NOW WITH HIS
IF YOU'RE AN EMPLOYEE- AND
THERE'S A PANDEMIC. AND YOU
JUST HAPPENED TO BE UNLUCKY
ENOUGH TO WORK FOR A SMALL
EMPLOYER. THAT. AND SO- I MEAN
THIS IS A DISCUSSION THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO. TO HAVE GOING
FORWARD- BUT IT DOES ADDRESS A-
LARGE SALE PROBLEM AND NOT
SORT OF- YOU KNOW I HAVE A
STAFFER WHO. NEEDS OF
ACCOMMODATIONS THIS IS SO FAR
BEYOND AN ACCOMMODATION THIS IS
A CRISIS WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY
SUCH WIDE IT CALLS FOR AN
EMERGENCY. AND OF COURSE WE CAN
WORK ON- WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT AN EIGHT YEAR EMERGENCY
WE'RE TALKING BUT WHAT HAPPENS
ESSENTIALLY WHEN OUR SOCIAL
SAFETY NETWORK COLLAPSES. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
HERE. I GUESS SAID NO IT
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE HOW
THOSE DISCUSSIONS GO I THINK IT
I THINK IT WAS REFERENCE THAT
THE DECLARATION WRITTEN AND I
REALIZED WHAT TRIGGERS THIS
BILL IS ACTUALLY THE SCHOOLS
BEING CLOSED SO IT'S NOT JUST A
STATE OF EMERGENCY SO I REALIZE
SOME IS THE EMERGING LAST A
LONG TIME. SCHOOLS GENERAL TRY
TO GET BACK OPEN WHEN THEY
CAN'T. AT THE SAME TIME-
DEPENDING AGAIN ON THE NATURE
OF THE BUSINESS IF THEY'RE
DOING. LIKE VITAL SAYING THIS-
IT CETERA I MEAN I AM. I JUST
THINK THAT THERE IS- HAVING
SEEN WHAT'S LIKE ON THE OTHER
SIDE TOO I MEAN I'VE SEEN WHAT
BOTH SIDES- TRY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE- BECAUSE IT SAID
IN THE END THE PERSON'S. JOB
MILLER SAYING WITHOUT PROMISE
SOMEONE THERE TO HAVE A JOB TO
COME BACK TO. WE DON'T KNOW A
WHOLE LOT YOU KNOW THAT
OBVIOUSLY THIS ASKED WE DON'T
KNOW HOW LONG SUMMER LONGER
SHORTER. THAN THE PROBLEM IS
THAT- THE BUSINESS OWNER MAY
END UP IN A SITUATION WHERE IT
IS LIKE OKAY WELL NOT ONLY DO
YOU KNOW OKAY I CAN'T KEEP YOUR
JOB OPENED BUT THE ONLY WAY I
CAN. DEAL WITH THIS IS ACTUALLY
JUST SHUT DOWN MY TIRE BUSINESS
AND EVERYONE IS THEIR JOB NOW
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT BIG YOU
KNOW. COMPANY BUT BASICALLY IS
BUT BASS TO THE ACT I JUST
CAN'T MAKE IT WORK ANYMORE AND
I THINK THAT- BECAUSE I HAVE TO
YOU KNOW EITHER I VIOLATE THE
LAW ARE PROMISED A PERSON THE
JOB BACK BUT YET I CAN'T
FUNCTION BECAUSE I CAN'T AFFORD
TO. THE PERSON WHO FILLS IN THE
HOLE AND I THINK THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE OF LOOKING AT LEAST
TIGHTLY CERTAIN OF A REALLY
SMALL BUSINESS RIGHT WHEN IT'S
A LETTER TWENTY FIVE IS. YOU
KNOW MAYBE CAN STATE AND I I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THE LINE IS WE'RE
NOT TALKING OBVIOUSLY BIGGER
BUSINESSES BECAUSE THE LINE
CURRETLY TWENTY FIVE. BUT IT I
AM CONCERNED THAT. KILLED
SMALLER THE BUSINESS GET. GETS
THE MORE CHALLENGING AND ALSO
BY THE WAY WHEN YOU REALLY
SMALL BUSINESS YOU ARE YOU CAN.
YOU DO. MORE I MEAN. IF YOUR
EMPLOYEES ARE NOT LIKE SOME
NAMELESS PERSON I MEAN AT THAT
POINT. YOU'RE WORKING SHOULDER
TO SHOULDER WITH THEM YOU HAVE
THAT REALLY SHOULD YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO TRY. FOR MOST PART AT
LEAST AND PLAY PROBABLY WAS ONE
WANT TO COME BACK OF THEM PLAY
REALLY DIDN'T CARE AT ALL ABOUT
THEIR EMPLOYEES WHEN YOU HAVE
TO. BASICALLY WORK FACE TO FACE
EVERY DAY IN THE WAY THAT A
VERY SMALL BUSINESS WOULD HAVE
TO WORK. AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A CATACLYSMIC
SITUATION FOR PROBABLY
EVERYBODY- SO THAT THE- THAT
THE ONE PERSON ISN'T GOING TO
MAKE OR BREAK A BUSINESS LIKE
WHAT WE'RE HAVING NOW WITH WITH
SITUATIONS WHERE. BUSINESSES
ARE LITERALLY CLOSE THEY CAN'T
DO BUSINESS. WHAT FLOOD. WELL
CLOSE IT'S CLOSE THE RIGHT
CREDIT BUT IT. IS THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND I PRE.
YOUR AND CERTAINLY. LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS. THANK YOU. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR DR
YEAH I JUST THINK WAS THAT YOUR
CLOTHES WHICH THAT CLOSE TO ME
JUST ADD TO IT THE THAT. AGAIN
WE HAVE THIS DILEMMA THIS
HOBSON'S CHOICE DO I TAKE CARE
OF MY CHILDREN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE. YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOT SCHOOL I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU DO WITH THESE KIDS AT
THAT POINT WHERE DO I GO TO
WORK AND LEAVE THEM AT HOME- OR
DO I QUIT MY JOB BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE THAT OPTION SO. THIS
IS A SITUATION WHERE WE REALLY
NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE IT'S A- IT
IS A LOSING CHOICE ON EITHER
SIDE. SO WITH THAT I WOULD THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE BILL
AND TO WE NEED TO FIND. A WAY
TO MAKE THOSE ACCOMMODATIONS
RECOGNIZING THE VARIOUS
CONCERNS AND INTERESTS THAT ARE
INVOLVED. IN THANK YOU FOR THAT
FOR SAYING THAT BECAUSE I AGREE
WITH SENATOR PANTS COMMENTS AS
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT ONE FACES AT
THE ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE AT
THAT. CRITICAL FIVE PERSONS
THREE PERSON EIGHT PER WHATEVER
THAT SMALL NUMBER IS IT'S VERY
DELICATE. BALANCE OF. PROVIDING
THE WORK. THE LABOR AND THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES BECAUSE
IT'S- THERE'S A FINE LINE
ACROSS THERE AND I THINK THE
OPPOSITION AND THEY WERE LATE.
COMING IN ON FRIDAY. BUT
THEY'VE RATE SOME I THINK SOME
SOME SOME LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
SO I AM HAPPY TO CERTAIN OF
SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE I
THINK YOU DID DESERVES A
CONVERSATION. BUT YOU KNOW WE
GET TO THE FOR WE'LL SEE HOW IT
WORKS OUT AND IF I CAN SUPPORT
THEM SO. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IS THERE A MOTION. SUMMARY
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL WE
HAVE A MOTION TO PAST.
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FOR PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE IN ORDER TO VOTE
SENATOR HILL. BY SENATOR HILL
HI SENATOR MORALE. SENATOR
JACKSON HI SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR MITCHELL HI CENTER
MITCHELL HI SENATOR PAN. THE
BILL HAS THREE BOAT IT IS OUT
THANK YOU IN THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON FOR THAT
AND NOW THANK YOU ALSO FOR NOW
DO TAKING OUR NEXT ITEM SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOR YOUR
PRESENT IN THE BILL FOR SENATOR
MONEY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
DOING THAT IT'S AGAIN PLEASE
PERCENT STRICKEN WE AND HIS
WITNESS IS ON THE LINE. RIGHT
NOW. SO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER PLAYS AN
ADJUDICATORY ROLE IN THE BERMAN
HEARING. A BERMAN HEARING TAKES
PLACE WHEN A WAGE CLAIM IS
FILED BY AN EMPLOYEE. THERE
AFTER IF THE BERMAN HEARING
RESULT IN AN ORDER DECISION OR
AWARD OTHERWISE KNOWN AS A NO
DNA. IN FAVOR OF THE CLAIMANT.
AND THE EMPLOYER. FILES AID TO
NOVO APPEAL SAY THEY DON'T THEY
DON'T LIKE THE DECISION- THEY
GET TO FILE A DE NOVO APPEAL IN
THE SUPERIOR COURT. AND THE
CLAIMANT CANNOT AFFORD PRIVATE
COUNSEL SO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER IS REQUIRED TO
REPRESENT THE CLAIMANT. IN THE
TO NOBLE PROCEEDING. EXISTING
REGULATION DOES NOT PROVIDE
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO REPRESENT A
WAGE CLAIMANT. UNLESS THERE HAS
BEEN A BERMAN HEARING AND THE
RESULTING ORDER DECISION OR
AWARD IN THE CLAIMANTS FAVOR.
THUS A WAGE CLAIM AND FORCED TO
ARBITRATE A WAGE CLAIM AND
PROHIBITED FROM HAVING THE
CLAIM HEARD AND DECIDED BY THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER. IS DEPRIVED
OF THE RIGHT TO NO CONTEST A NO
COST REPRESENTATION OFTEN
CLAIMANTS CANNOT AFFORD PRIVATE
COUNSEL AND FACE A HIGHER
PROSPECT OF THE DEFEAT IN
ARBITRATION. OR THEY SETTLE
THEIR CLAIMS AT A SUBSTANTIAL
DISCOUNT THIS MEASURE WOULD
UPDATE EXISTING LAW TO ALLOW
CLAIMANTS TO RECEIVE NO COST
REPRESENTATION FROM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER COMMISSIONER IN AN
ARBITRAL PROCEEDING. SO THIS
PROPOSAL ADDRESSES THE
INCREASING USE OF MANDATORY
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS WHICH
SOME OF US DON'T PARTICULARLY
LIKE BUT THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
SEEING A PARTICULARLY IN AN
EMPLOYMENT CONTEXT. AND IT
WOULD ALLOW THE DIVISION OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT TO
REPRESENT WAGE CLAIMANTS IN
THOSE PROCEEDINGS WHEN THEY'RE
UNABLE TO RESOLVE THE CLAIM
DURING A BERMAN HEARING. SO
AGAIN THIS A RARE IT KNOWLEDGE
TO THE EXTENT TO WHICH THESE
PROCEEDINGS ARE OCCURRING AND
IT TO A PROVIDES THE CLAIMANT
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENTATION HOPING OF COURSE
THAT THESE ALL GET RESOLVED. AT
THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE STAGE
BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU DE NOVO
SOMETHING IT GOES THE SUPERIOR
COURT. AND WE KNOW PARTICULARLY
THE COURTS ARE GOING TO BE JAM
ONCE THEY RE OPEN- AND AFTER-
THE CODED- EMERGENCY IS A
PASSIVE SO- THIS DOES HAVE BOTH
THE COLD WOULD END OF FAIRNESS
ASPECT TO IT- AND- ARE WITH MY
WITNESS ORDERED. AS CENTER
MONIES WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL MARIE GO YOSHIHARA THE
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION- IS ON. THE LINE
READY TO TESTIFY. OUR ALL RIGHT
WE CAN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS MERRY GO USUALLY CAR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PLAN THAT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION CLEAR AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MONEY OR GREEN XBOX OR-
SENATOR JEFF TALK TO MENTION
THE BILL HOW DOES HELP RESPOND
TO THE EVER EXPANDING NATURE
FORCED ARBITRATION CLAUSES THAT
MOST WORKERS NOW FIND IN THEIR
EMPLOYMENT CONTRACTS. MANY
PEOPLE REALLY ARE SHOCKED TO
LEARN THAT FORCED ARBITRATION
CLAUSES NOT ONLY PREVENT
WORKERS FROM FILING A CLAIM IN
COURT BUT IT CAN ALSO PREVENT
THEM FROM ACCESSING THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE. AND I
JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON ONE WE
CAN CASE THAT I THINK
ILLUSTRATES WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT I'M IN THIS CASE THE
WORKER FILE THE WAGE CLAIM WITH
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
AND WAS AWARDED HUNDRED TO TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN UNPAID
WAGES SB FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
THE MIGRATED TO DAMAGE AND.
INTEREST AND PENALTIES. WHERE
TO COMPEL BUT- BE THE WORK HAD
BEEN FORCED TO SIGN IN OUR-
AGREEMENT AS A CONDITION OF THE-
LUCKILY THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
ENTERED. TO OPPOSE THE- TO
COMPEL THIS RECORD ARGUS. THANK
YOU TRY TO BAKER HIS THE WAY OF
THE LATE COMMISSIONER'S. THAT
THE SUPREME COURT WILL ON A-
ACTUALLY WHETHER THE- AGREEMENT
WAS UNCONSCIONABLE. AND FOUND
THAT IT WAS A GRADUAL BECAUSE
IT WOULD'VE FORCED THE WORKER
INTO A FORM THAT WOULD BE
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO NAVIGATE
WITHOUT AN ATTORNEY. WELL IT
WAS DIFFICULT TO ASCERTAIN FROM
THE GREEN HOW ABOUT THE WORKER
WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO FILE A
CLAIM IN ARBITRATION. AND IT
WOULD REQUIRE THE WORKER TO
RESPOND THE FORMAL DISCOVERY
DEMAND THE DISPOSITIVE MOTIONS
AND FOLLOW ALL THE TECHNICAL
RULES OF EVIDENCE. THE BERMAN
HEARING BY CONTRAST UP THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE THE
WORKER NEED ONLY FILL OUT A
COMPLAINT FORM THEY HAVE
EXPECTED FROM THE DEPUTY LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND ALL RELEVANT
OF AND IS TYPICALLY ADMITTED.
THE COURT GOT IT RIGHT IN THAT
CASE AND THAT WOULD THE
AGREEMENT WITH UNCONSCIONABLE
BUT THERE MAY BE INSTANCES
WHERE A WORKER IS ACTUALLY
COMPILED ARBITRATION BY THE
EMPLOYER AND WE DO NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER CANNOT THAT THE-
WORKERS. EITHER BY REPRESENTING
THEM IN THE ARBITRATION PROCESS
OR BY CHALLENGING THE
ENFORCEABILITY OF THE
ARBITRATION CLAUSE. WE KNOW
WORKERS ARE ALREADY AT A
DISTINCT DISADVANTAGE WHEN
THEY'RE FORCED TO PURSUE THEIR
CLAIM IN ARBITRATION AND IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT THAT
THE DAMAGE EVEN MORE PRONOUNCED
WHEN THEY'RE NOT REPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL. AND ARBITRATION
DECISIONS ARE BINDING AND
WORKERS CANNOT APPEAL AN
ARBITRATION DECISION LIKE THEY
CAN'T A COURT DECISION OR AN
ADMINISTRATIVE DECISION. IT IS
ALL THE MORE IMPORTANT WE
PROTECT WORKERS FROM LOSING ALL
OF THEIR RIGHT TO AN
ARBITRATION PROCEEDING WHERE
THEY ARE ON REPRESENTED. THE
FOR ALL THESE. REASONS WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO TESTIMONY IN-
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE IS THERE ANYONE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR SEEN NO
ONE TO HAVE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON. BEHALF OF IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR SEEING NO ONE THERE AS
WELL THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO A MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ITS B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU. AND FOR
EVERYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
OUR FIRST MY NEED TO BE OPENED
AS MINE TO NINETY THREE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JESSICA FENDER ON THE
HAD LEGAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE IN
THE COURT THANK YOU. ENTER NEXT
MINE IS MINE THREE FIFTY THREE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. NINE THREE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ALL MY BILLION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE- Q.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONCE AGAIN JUST TO BE SURE WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON H. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN.
THANK YOU HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS TO HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEN NO ONE
LOOKING AT TWENTY TWO ZERO FOUR
ZERO IS THERE ANYONE IN TWO
ZERO FOUR ZERO. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. SEE NO
ONE IN TWENTY FORTY. THANK YOU
WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY BE THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WE WILL
BEGIN. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE ARE AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO WINNING Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR- WE WILL NOW
BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR PUBLIC FOR COMMON
THEY'LL- THANK YOU WOULD YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR
TRACTION. THAT'S RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVALS FOR FREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR PAN OF PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BURNERS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THE VOTE. CENTER
HELP HI THERE HELLO HI CENTER
MORALE. SENATOR JACKSON'S BY
SENATOR JACKSON BY SENATOR
MITCHELL FIVE AND MITCHELL HI
CENTER PAN FIGHT. IN ORDER PAN
HI. THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES IT
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EVERYONE FOR THE VOTES THAT WE
WILL MOVE TO OUR FINAL ITEM OF
THE DAY SENATOR TO RAZA AGAIN
IN I WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR
YOUR- HAVING TO. SIT THROUGH
THIS AND BE HERE IN YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY BUT THAT'S THE
WAY WERE WORKING THE SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW. NO REASON TO
APOLOGIZE. WITH THIS IS THAT
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE PLEASE
THANK YOU AS I'M SITTING THERE
I WAS A SAYING WHAT. WHAT WHICH
I BE THINKING OF ASIDE FROM
MISSING YOU WALL AND SENATOR
MITCHELL I'M THINKING OF THE
EVENING THAT WE SPENT WITH THE
GARMENT WORKERS. IN THE PICO
UNION AREA AND HOW. ELATED THEY
WERE. TO RECEIVE SOME OF THE
LOST WAGES. TWO YEARS LATER
THREE YEARS LATER SO. YEARS
LATER SO I'M THINKING OF THEM
RIGHT NOW. SO RIGHT NOW
PRIMARILY WOMEN IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY ARE FINALLY AT HOME I
WAS GONNA SAY THEY WERE AT
WORK- MAKING THE PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT BUT RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
AT HOME AFTER TEN TO TWELVE
HOURS OF WORK MAKING PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT THAT ENABLES US TO BE
HERE TODAY. AND OUR BUSINESSES
AND SERVICES NEED TO REOPEN
REBUILD. THE GARMENT WORKER
WOMEN ARE DOING THIS SOMETIMES
IN VERY HARSH CONDITIONS AND
OFTEN FOR AS LITTLE AS FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. THESE MEN AND
WOMEN ARE DOING ESSENTIAL WORK
THEY ARE MORE VISIBLE AND YET
THEY ARE MORE VULNERABLE.
MOSTLY DUE IN PART TO
WIDESPREAD EXPLOITATION WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING TO EXPAND
LIABILITY FOR WAGE THEFT IN THE
GARMENT MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY.
SO THIS BILL WOULD PROTECT
THOSE WORKERS BY ELIMINATING
THE PIECE RATE IN THAT INDUSTRY
AND FORCING LIABILITY FOR WAGE
VIOLATIONS. ALLOWING THE
GARMENT WORKERS TESTIMONY TO
MEANS SOMETHING. WHEN IT COMES
TO IDENTIFYING THE GUARANTORS
OR OTHER WORDS BROWN'S. AND TO
EXPLICITLY AUTHORIZE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE TO
INVESTIGATE AND SITE THESE
GUARANTORS. SB THIRTY NINETY
NINE MAKES CLEAR THAT A
BUSINESS CONTRACTING TO HAVE
GARMENT MADE GARMENTS MADE IS
LIABLE FOR THE UNPAID MINIMUM
WAGE AND OVERTIME TO THE
WORKERS WHO MANUFACTURE THE
GARMENT. REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
LAYERS OF CONTRACTING THAT THAT
PERSON MAY USE. RESPONSIBLE
BUSINESSES WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
ARE ALSO SUFFERING. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND ENFORCEMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS WILL LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR THE
RESPONSIBLE GOOD BUSINESSES IT
WON'T HURT THEM. SO CALLED
RETAILERS CONTRACT WITH A
NETWORK OF MANUFACTURERS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS TO PRODUCE THEIR
GARMENTS AND THEY DICTATE THE
PRICING STRUCTURE WAGE THEFT
REPORT FROM UCLA DOCUMENTED
THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS IN
GENERAL AND IN THE LA ALONE.
LOSE TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
A WEEK IN WAGE THEFT VIOLATIONS
IMAGINE TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS MORE A WEEK IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE SCHOOLS
WHERE THEY LIVE. SOME OF THE
TWENTY FIVE LOW WAGE INDUSTRIES
SURVEYED THE GARMENT INDUSTRY
HAS THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF WAGE
THEFT VIOLATION BY INDUSTRY. SO
NOT ONLY DOES THE PRIVACY IN
STRUCTURE AND LAYERS OF
CONTRACTING UNDERMINE THE FORCE
IN THE PURPOSE OF LAW
MANUFACTURERS HAVE NO INCENTIVE.
TO FOLLOW THE LAW. UNLESS THEY
FACE LIABILITY. WE HAVE DO WE
MUST ESTABLISH THE UPSTREAM
LIABILITY SO THAT WE CAN STOP
THAT THE F. THAN EXPLOITATION
I'VE HEARD THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS ON SEVERAL OF MY OF MY
BILL MY AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AS
DETAILED ON PAGE NINE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS REMOVES THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AND THE
SECURITY BOND REQUIREMENT FROM
THIS BILL SO MY COLLEAGUES I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BE
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE. TODAY WE
HAVE TWO EXPERTS ON THE PHONE
GARMENT WORKER WITH HILDA ROLE
METAL AND MATTHEW D. CARLESS
FROM BED SET A LEGAL SERVICES
TESTIFYING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR THE TESTIMONY AND A
FOR THE- COMMENTS- SENATOR
DRAWS- AND- IS ROMERO. SAME
HERE CENTER THAT I SAW AND NINE
SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE DISHES
THEY DON'T GALLAGHER THE
GARMENT WORKER CENTER AND I'LL
BE TRANSLATING FOR YOU NOT A
METAL IN THE WORLD. MATTHEW
MEDIC. BUT I THINK. OKAY
HOMELAND. MAYBE I'M NOT ONE ON
THE LOCAL STORE. ONE HELLO BUT
ORDER. MY NAME IS A LITTLE
MENTAL I WORK IN BERMAN FOR
NINETEEN YEARS BUT I'VE NEVER
BEEN PAID FOR OUR I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN PAID IF YOU THREE. I'M WE
OUR IDEAS AND OUR LUCKY IS THAT
YOU ON'T AND BATTLES. WE MADE
BY THAT'LL OBSTACLES AND BY
WELL IO JUST IMPROBABLE TO BE
EXACT. YEAH THAT IN THE- WHAT
YOU THIRTY YES. BEFORE IT I WAS
TEN TO TWELVE A PIECE I
CULTURAL I WAS STATE OF FIVE TO
EIGHT HE'S TRIMMING MASS AND
HOSPITAL. BOB BACK IF WHAT
YOU'LL NEED BE IS THAT. ONE
MOMENT WHILE YOUR- AND THEY
ABOUT THEIR MOM ONE BILLION.
MAYBE CALL. YEAH GOT THEM BACK
NOT BE A LAST. THERE ARE A ALL
AREN'T. THEY MOST DAY IF THEY
ARE BASED. EIGHTY FIVE ALL TIME
LEADING. MADE BY LAW. I HAVE
BEEN FACING ORDER. LAST WEEK I
BELIEVE EIGHT THOUSAND PIECES I
WOULD HATE BY MY THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS THE
WEEK WHEN I COMPLAIN COMMAND
YOU I NEED YOUR FIVE P. I WORK
SIXTY HOURS LAST WEEK FROM SIX
AM TO SIX PM AND SATURDAY AS
WELL SO I MADE FIVE FIVE
DOLLARS AND SEVENTY FIVE CENTS.
PER HOUR. MY PHONE BY SHOW MALL
WHILE. THEIR MAINFRAME LITTLE
BOMB THEIR MAINLAND GRASS HE-
DOES. FIRST. BRANDON I'M
PRODUCING OUR FACTIONAL BUT THE
WHICH IS A GROUP OF BROWN AND
VARIOUS OTHERS. PROBABLY IF I
DON'T YEAH. THE PHONE NUMBER OF
OUR CURRENT A LOT OF PROPERTY.
NO ARE YOU TROUBLED. THERE NOT
EAT ARE YOU PROPONENTS. ONE BUT
THEY DON'T KNOW BOB BAER IDEA
BUT OUR GOVERNMENT. THE
FACTORIES ARE STILL SEEN MANY
PEOPLE WORK WITHIN THE FACTORY
THERE YOUR HAND SOAP IN THE
BATHROOM AND THERE ARE RATS IN
THE FACTORY THERE IS NO
VENTILATION I GET A FIFTEEN
MINUTE BREAK A DATE. SHE'S. IF
YOU'RE NOT SURE MAYBE ALL RIGHT
I'M ALL. BUT BROWN. THERE THERE.
ONE OF. NO MATTER WHAT IT YOLO
LITTLE. ORDERED OKAY THE LADY
BIGELOW OWNER ANY. SCANDALS OR
YEAH. OUR CANDLES. IT. IT WAS
BOB LAST LANCASTER. LOS. WELL
WHAT. WELL I'M. BUT NO I WRITE.
IF I MOST. I'M WE WERE SAYING
THAT. YEAH OR A LOT MORE YOU
KNOW GETTING ALSO A FAMILY.
HELLO BUT NOT ORDER YOU HAVE
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE. WELL YEAH.
ROGER THAT YOU'RE TAKING OVER
THREE MINUTES I WILL GIVE ONE
MORE MINUTE FOR YOUR ENTIRE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TESTIMONY
SO THAT YOUR OTHER WITNESS AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. I JUST WANT
TO TRANSLATE THE END OF THE
STATEMENT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ABOUT THAT WE WAITING
FOR WEEKEND. STATE GOVERNMENT
RIGHT. IN FRONT IT WILL BE
COMING FROM THE BAND THE BRAND
THAT I COULD USE. IT Y. WANNA
CHANGING A LOT OF. SB PICKING.
CRITICAL LOOK LIKE. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS MATTHEW TWO CAR LIST THAT
THAT TOPIC LEGAL SERVICES- MS
ROMERO STATED SO ELOQUENTLY-
THERE'S A HUGE ISSUE WITH NO
ONE REST BREAK VIOLATIONS- NOTONLY FOR THE WORKERS HEALTH BUT
FOR ALL OF SOCIETY DURING THAT
MAKE WORKERS DON'T HAVE TIME TO
SANITIZER WORKSTATIONS OR TAKE
THEIR BREAKS OR WASH THEIR
HANDS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING PAID- FOR THAT TIME.
BECAUSE OF THE PIECE RATE. SO
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
SPELLING SUPPORT THE GARMENT
WORKERS WHO ARE SEEKING JUSTICE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND
BEYOND. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CARLOS PROPITIATE THE
TESTIMONY THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO- TESTIMONY PUBLIC
TESTIMONY HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE SEEN NO ONE WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS OR
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY- WISHING
TO SUPPORT. THIRD SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE JEAN NO ONE THERE
BUT WE WANNA GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE TELECONFERENCE HARVEST
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU. AND IF YOU
WISH TO. COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OUR FIRST MINE IS MINE THREE
FORTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
RESPONSE IS A TRUE OF THE
COALITION FOR MANY AMERICANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
THREE SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN I WOULD PUT THE CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIXTY THREE.
BARTOLO ELECTIONS NAM ON
POVERTY ECHO FOSTER AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR. MINE TO NINETY
NINE. BY GRAHAM A VALUE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. NINE TO
THIRTY SEVEN. IN ORDER TO USE
WOULD BE IN THE TO THE LOOK AT
JUNGLE GLADNESS CALIFORNIA YOU
HAVE GOT DALY WORKING THE
MASTIC WORKERS IN SUPPORT. OF
GARMENT WORKERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MIND THREE FORTY FIVE.
NAY BAYARDO AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE TO SEVENTY ONE. MILEY
THAT ALL REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN SUPPORT. MY TWENTY SEVEN.
SEVEN MEN IN MY PLACES FOR
PROGRESS WHICH IS A PRIORITY
SUPPORT PRESS ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF AS ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE ELEVATOR CENTER
PROTESTED THE COURAGE CAMPAIGN
AND POLICY LINK ALL SUPPORTING
THE BILL. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
OH THREE. DOES THE REALITY OF
THE W. I STARTED COUNT ON
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU.
NINE THREE FIFTY THREE. WE ON
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN STRASBOURG THANK YOU. FIND
THREE SIXTY FOUR. THE HEART
WITH THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
COURT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
SIXTY SEVEN KEVIN AND FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE THREE SIXTY THREE.
NICHOLAS BRAUN WITH FASHION
REVOLUTION YOU AT BAY AND
STRONG THE CORE. NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT. NINETY
NINE. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY
ALSO BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE THREE SIXTY. DANCERS WITH
CORBELLING KREIDER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
NINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CORINNE I'M FREE FROM
WORK SAFE AND WE STRONGLY THE
CORE- AT THE THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NINE
THREE FIFTY FIVE. A LIFELONG
NECTAR FROM THE LA LAKERS AND
KERR NETWORK AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE.
NINE TWO NINETY THREE. DOES THE
DEFENDER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN FONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND OUR LAST NINE THREE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING MAILING
WITH A CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS COALITION ACCORDING
GARMENT WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
MURRAY BUT IF YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES AND CALL THE
SUPPORTERS INTO ONE MORE TIME
THAT WOULD BE. GREAT IS THERE
SUPPORTING THE BEST BE THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE. IF THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FOR SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO QUEUE UP. NINE TWO
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR YOU MAY BE
ANYA. NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR TO HAVING HEARD FROM
THE ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION WILL BEGIN
WITH ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS I BET
HAVING COME OUT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT BILL THAT MAKES
MAJOR CHANGES TO HOW WE
REGULATE- THE GARMENT
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA- THAT WAS-
IMPLEMENTED OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO AND EIGHTY SIX THREE THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEINBERG-
THESE ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES. YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS AT THAT THE
STAKEHOLDERS THE ADMINISTRATION
THE COMMITTEES- YOU KNOW ARE
LIMITED IN HOW MUCH ATTENTION
THEY CAN DEVOTE TO THIS THIS.
VERY SIGNIFICANT CHANGES A LOT
I MEAN HERE IT IS IT'S EIGHT
THIRTY AT NIGHT FOR THE LAST
BILL TODAY ALL OF YOU WANT TO
LEAVE WE HAVE THREE MINUTES TO
EXPLAIN OUR CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL. WE THINK FRANKLY THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE NOT THAT
IT'S NOT IMPORTANT AND WE KNOW
IT'S CLOSE TO THE SENATORS
HEART. WE THINK IT DESERVES A
LOT MORE ATTENTION THAN ANY OF
US ARE ABLE TO DEVOTE- DURING
THIS CRISIS WERE TRYING TO
FOCUS. ON ON VERY LIMITED
LEGISLATIVE TESTIMONY AND
OUTPUT. WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL- WE'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT WE JUST DON'T THINK
THERE'S BEEN YOU KNOW FULLER
OPPORTUNITY TO FLUSH OUT THESE
CONCERNS. NUMBER ONE IT
ELIMINATES PIECE RATE FOR THE
ENTIRE GARMENT INDUSTRY THAT'S
A VERY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE THE
LAW. WE GENERALLY DON'T LIMIT
HOW EMPLOYERS CAN PAY WORKERS.
PM HOURLY SALARY PIECE RATE AS
LONG AS YOU COMPLY WITH MINIMUM
WAGE AND OVERTIME AND ALL THE
OTHER- REGULATIONS IT'S UP TO
THE EMPLOYER HOW TO PAY WORKERS
AND WE HEARD DESCRIPTIONS OF
MINIMUM WAGE- VIOLATIONS AND
REST. BREAK VIOLATIONS THOSE
ARE ILLEGAL UNDER CURRENT LAW
AND THERE SHOULD BE ENFORCED TO
THE FULL EXTENT OF THE LAW.
THIS BILL ALSO IMPOSES JOINT
LIABILITY ON BRANDS WHICH IS A
HUGE CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD
HUGE DEBATES IN THIS
LEGISLATURE THE LAST FEW YEARS
OVER JOINT LIABILITY. AND WE
HAVE FUNDAMENTAL CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPOSING LIABILITY. ON ENTITIES
AUTOMATICALLY WHO MAY NOT HAVE
CONTROL OR KNOWLEDGE. OVER THE
ACTIONS OF ANOTHER ENTITY THIS
IS A HUGE POINT OF CONVERSATION
THAT WE SHOULD SPEND THE TIME.
DISCUSSING THIS BILL IMPROPERLY
CREATES TWO DIFFERENT
EVIDENTIARY STANDARDS AND WE
WISH THIS BILL IS GOING TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WERE
THANKFUL WE HAVE THIS CHAIR.
HERE THIS BILL SAYS A
PRESUMPTION OF JOINT
LIABILITIES ESTABLISHED IF THE
WORKER. I LABELS OF A BREAD.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND THE
EMPLOYER CANNOT DEFEND
THEMSELVES WITH WRITTEN
DECLARATIONS. AND SAID HAS TO
PROVIDE OTHER COMPELLING AND
RELIABLE WRITTEN EVIDENCE. WE
THINK THIS TWO DIFFERENT.
STANDARDS FOR EVIDENCE IS
IMPROPER AND PROBABLY VIOLATES
DUE PROCESS WE DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE IN THIS BILL. AGAIN
WE DON'T HAVE A FULL
OPPORTUNITY TO FLUSH THAT OUT
BECAUSE THIS BILL ISN'T GOING
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SO
AGAIN THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE WE DON'T WANT TO- GIVE
ANY IMPRESSION THAT IS NOT
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO THE CONTRARY
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
MAKES IT VERY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE LAW. WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD SPEND
THE TIME TO GET IT RIGHT- YOU
KNOW SPEND PERHAPS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. TIME
REALLY LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES
IF WE'RE GOING TO ADOPT
WHOLESALE CHANGES SUCH AS
OUTLINED PIECE RATE. IMPOSING
AUTOMATICALLY LIABILITY ON
BRANDS- SO WE RESPECTFULLY
WOULD REQUEST THAT THIS THIS
THE ISSUE BEING TAKEN UP NEXT
YEAR WHEN ALL OF THE PARTIES
CAN DEVOTE THE PROPER ATTENTION
THAT IT DESERVES. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS RESPECTFULLY WERE
OPPOSED THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THAT WAS PERFECT
EXACTLY THREE MINUTES AND NOW
WE WILL MOVE TO ANYONE ELSE IN
THE. IN THIS ROOM. I WANTED TO
SPEAK WITH ANYONE HERE AT
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY VERY GOOD THEN
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE. PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS MODERATOR
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE AND THEN WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE THREE
SIXTY EIGHT I'M SORRY- JUST A
BRIEF MOMENT HERE. NINE THREE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI. YES THANK YOU- UNLESS
YOU CARE MEMBERS NICOLAES
CALIFORNIA AFTER GOING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION I WON'T
BE LABOR- COMICS FOR TONIGHT
WHICH IS TO SAY THAT WE
STRONGLY AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE CHAMBER IN
WHICH YOU ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN THE QUEUE MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO BE SURE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL OF THE OPPOSITION. TO
SB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE. AND
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR. THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE WANT TO BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS.
SENATOR JACKSON'S IT'S THANK
YOU- I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL I THINK THE FACT THAT
WE'VE HAD LAWS ON THE BOOKS FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND WE'RE STILL
HEARING ABOUT RAT INFESTED
RIGHT- BATHROOMS. AND PEOPLE
WORKING- SIXTY FIVE HOURS A
WEEK AND- GETTING PAID OF FIVE
DOLLARS AND SIXTY FIVE CENTS. A
BEGS THE QUESTION AS TO. WHAT
IS GOING ON HERE AND I DON'T
THINK WE CAN WAIT ANOTHER YEAR.
TO RESOLVE THIS THERE MAY BE
SOME. QUESTIONS ABOUT PROCESS
AND I'M HAPPY EVEN THOUGH THE
BILL DOESN'T GET TO COME TO MY
COMMITTEE. TO TRY TO BE HELPFUL
ENACT WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE ARE CONSISTENT THAN
THAT WE PROVIDE ALL OF THE
PROTECTIONS AVAILABLE BUT I
FIND IT SOMEWHAT INTERESTING
THAT THERE'S A CALL TO ENFORCE
THE LAW TO THE MAXIMUM. EXTENT
AVAILABLE EXCEPT THAT YOU HAVE
TO REMOVE THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION. FROM THIS BILL WHICH IS
ONE OF THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS THAT ACTUALLY- OF
FREQUENTLY DOES- GET COMPANIES
TO TAKE THE LOSS SERIOUSLY. I'M
ASSUMING RIGHT NOW WITH THIS
WITH THE ONLY ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IS A- THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS IS THAT THE- AGENCY
IN A COURSE THEY'RE
OVERWHELMED. AND SO- THE I FIND
THE PROTESTATIONS TO BE A
LITTLE DISINGENUOUS FRANKLY
BECAUSE- THIS IS SOMETHING NO
ONE SHOULD TAUGHT WHEN WE
SHOULD BE TOLERATING THIS THESE
ARE STORIES WITH. THAT HAPPENED
IN NINETEEN HUNDRED. WITH THE
GARMENT WORKERS IN NEW YORK AND
IT COULD HAPPEN IN LOS ANGELES
AND- YOU KNOW YOU CAN PAY
PIECEMEAL AS LONG AS IT'S A
MINIMUM OF THE MINIMUM WAGE BUT
THEY THE CLEARLY THAT ISN'T.
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND- I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD BE WAITING ANY
LONGER TO TRY TO FIX THAT BUT I
WILL. OFFER MY ASSISTANCE AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN. WORK TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS WHAT ARE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS BUT AS FAR AS THE
RESTAURANT DELAYING AND
DELAYING THIS IS. JUST AN
UNCONSCIONABLE SITUATION SO I'M
GOING TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND THANK THE
OFFICE INTERJECTING OTHER
COMMENTS. CONCERNS HEARING NONE.
ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND- ON BEHALF OF ALL OF THOSE
WORKERS APPRECIATE YOUR-
CONCERNS AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THE OTHER ISSUES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN MY ROOM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AND I
THINK YOU MADE SOME GOOD VERY
GOOD POINTS AND WAGE THEFT IS
JUST TOLERABLE AND WE KNOW
WHICH IN THE INDUSTRY AND IT
HAS BEEN THERE'S BEEN SUCH
ABUSES AND SO THAT THERE'S
SOME. SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE
DONE I APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT- THEY'RE
OFFERING THOSE AND PUTTING THEM
IN THE BILL- IT NEEDS TO MAKE
THE INDUSTRY MORE ACCOUNTABLE
IN THERE BUT I DO TO IT IT IS A
BIG BILL AND THERE'S A LOT IN
HERE. AND I JUST WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO PLEASE WORK
OVER THE NEXT WHATEVER AMOUNT
OF TIME WE HAVE TO. TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE I
REALLY DON'T WANT TO SEE THOSE
RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES HARM I
MEAN THERE ARE. GOOD APPLES AND
BAD AND THE GOOD ONES I DON'T
WANT TO SEE THEM
UNINTENTIONALLY HARMED BY THIS
BILL SO I HOPE THAT WE CAN SEE
SOME OF SOME PROGRESS ON THAT
AS WELL SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR JACKSON. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN
ORDER TO VOTE. SENATOR HILL HI.
SENATOR HILL. HI SENATOR MOREAU.
SENATOR JACKSON HI IN ORDER
JACKSON HI SENATOR MITCHELL BY
SENATOR MITCHELL BY SENATOR
PENN HI SENATOR PAN HI. THE
ADDRESS OF THE BILL IS OUT WITH
FOR VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS OR PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFIED
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY AND YOUR COOPERATION.
THANK THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU.